[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome to day two of the air things
Masters what are you up today with owls
sorry
I was just setting up a little Easter
egg for our viewers all right something
special for them we're predicting the
future we predict that the position on
the board will happen at least once
today all right well can you spot David
Howell's little Easter egg in the studio
this is the second day of the air things
Masters two players will be knocked out
so welcome to the action of the air
things monsters
himself
you can't move wait wait wait wait wait
wait this move is breaking the rules
whoa everything under control but
suddenly the position has changed this
just looks glorious for one big Choice
from origin irrigation there we go the
other lunch continues
[Music]
his genius
and he certainly started off with some
genius Chas yesterday Magnus Carlsen he
uh had a fantastic first day off the air
things monster is done here again to
guide you through the second day of the
tournament Grandmaster David Howell
International Master Tanya and
Grandmaster Rover test and Robert what
did you take away from the very first
day of the 2023 season we saw some
brilliant chests some absolute dominant
performances from some of the best
players in the world and some surprises
when Arjun aragaisy sweeping aloe is a
Frugal and today Tanya the first two
players will be knocked out of the
tournament a lot today so much Kyra they
use the one life they're on their very
last chance at that Championship now
they have to block out what happened on
day one give it their all it's go big or
go home for these four players yes and
David you commented two seasons on the
Champions chess store with a Time
control of 15 plus 10 yesterday we had
15 plus only three seconds increment did
you like it I did Kaya it's faster it's
more Furious and but yesterday there was
still a very high quality of Chess we
didn't see too many one move blunders we
saw the players adapting to that faster
time control and it's only going to
promise more drama for us here in the
studio also for the fans yeah and we
still have eight players in division one
in the air things Masters they are
spread out across the world sitting in
many different time zones Magnus cross
and he has actually traveled to Canada
to visit his friends the chest brows and
it did seem like he enjoyed himself
yesterday Tanya he's got his
cheerleaders with him narumah Hazard
that he is in Canada for the protest
league as part of the chess brought
teams but I also hear that he might be
there to have a little bit of fun okay
so it's really going to depend on how
disciplined he can be how much farting
he's doing but it worked out in
Perfection on day one yeah and it was a
team effort yesterday to uh to get all
the technical stuff working for Magnus
Carlsen he is the reigning champion in
the Champions chess tour and started off
the season in great fashion
now the white Rook has landed on a
square that the White Knight used to
occupy but still an outpost still
defended by White's past Pawn in the
center and
even if black trades off that Rook it
will just be replaced by an equally
powerful Magnus centralizes his Knight
wow nice move and adding even more
pressure onto those two kind of most
important Defenders exchanging pieces as
well as Robert mentioned helping when
you're ahead of material Serana I think
he is completely hopelessly lost I don't
say that very often as a commentator but
this position it's he's getting
obliterated in this one this is
Checkmate incoming uh Serrano's down to
a minute and a half and the clock is not
even his biggest problem Magnus did get
his Rook to the seventh rank answer
resigned
wow peace sacrifice and Tanya your first
instinct was what he's given up a bishop
his London Bishop for two points it's
total chaos despite the reduced material
and Black's King is on the run it feels
like every guy sees the nerves of
kicking in he's giving a few checks to
gain time on the increments are leaning
back though and it's over you want peace
he won a piece the black king now cannot
take that white knight because then you
lose your bishop and Eric I see we
almost missed it there but spun it in
his favor mostly so maybe the single
worst opponent to play when you need to
win
he's just breaking off in the center
targeting that D3 pawn and says come and
take my C4 Pawn not only do you double
up your own pawns but watch out for that
pawn in the center wow we're all
reacting here in the studio because
Ralph is maybe out of desperation
sacrifice to peace he's given up his
Knight just for a couple of Pawns Knight
in King versus King you cannot win that
it is a draw and that means what's this
song Moves off
what a day we had first day of the year
things Masters and I want to introduce
you guys also to our fourth expert in
the studio International Master Ivanka
houska who impressed you the most
yesterday that was such a frantic day
yesterday but I have to say the person
who I really liked and really enjoyed
watching was Hikaru Nakamura because he
wasn't playing from his normal home he
was paying from California because of
personal reasons but he still managed to
put all that behind him and just
demolish kukesh crushing win for Hikaru
Nakamura in his match yesterday same for
Magnus Carlsen winning in only three
games against Serana Wesley Seoul got
that one when he needed to win his match
against Ralph momondov
but the biggest surprise yesterday must
have been the match between Arjun
aragaisy and alireza fuja the two 19
year olds Arjun winning all three games
I mean it was actually quite shocking I
mean not the fact that far Asia lost but
the fact that he lost by such a margin I
mean he is after all number four in the
world but uh he has been in somewhat
hibernation and I think the rust really
showed so today the heat is on for him
yeah and luckily for furosha he does
have two lives because this is double
elimination that means you can lose one
match and still win the whole tournament
but the second you lose a second match
you are knocked out of the air things
master so the four players who won their
matches yesterday they will play winners
semi-finals starting later today the
four players who lost yesterday they
were knocked down to the losers bracket
and will play losers round one starting
in
eight minutes and first of all we have
Serana against Fu show what you expect
from us this one is going to be wild I
mean both players have very aggressive
Styles Serana this could be a career
defining moment for him so he will want
to be doing well especially with the
white pieces and when it comes to
farooja well his pride has been hurt and
he needs to recover and one of the
things about farooja is that he's a
little bit impractical and that keeps
his opponents on his toes and for Serana
you imagine it could actually be quite
important for him we know the two
players who go home to today they get
home with seven thousand five hundred
dollars but for him earning even more
money could be important exactly I mean
this type of money could actually mean
that he could employ a second he could
perhaps get a team behind him it just
gives him opportunities that he might
not have had otherwise yeah a lot at
stake today for Alexa Serrata a total of
000 is in the prize fund in the air
things Masters and we also have to
mention the other matchup in the losers
round one moment of against young dukesh
I know again another thrilling matchup
you have mamadolf he's very much a
romantic player he likes the coffee
house kind of Chess when you just throw
your pieces at The King and I have to
say mama doc actually came very well
prepared against Wesley and he could
have turned that match around and when
it comes to the 16 year old you cashed
over there I mean that kid is just
running at a fast pace you know of
course he won the play-ins but yesterday
it was his off day but uh well boy yeah
this is going to be a fight yeah at only
16 years old a young chess genius who
has and you brought this with you today
Ivanka he has composed a quite
sophisticated study yeah I mean it's
super sophisticated he composed it when
he was just 15 years old in honor of the
Dutch Grandmaster Yan Timon now the
position that you're going to see ahead
of you is actually the end of a study
that he he did that was actually like 13
and 14 moves long and here we've caught
the very end of it it is white to play
and it's very sophisticated very
difficult so get your friends around
solve together and I'm going to give you
a small clue okay and it all hinges on
this Black Knight stuck there on H4 it's
kind of offside it's not doing anything
and chess is all about timing and now is
the time for white to strike so enjoy
this complex puzzle courtesy of good
cash but I hope you guys all enjoy it
wow we are challenging all of you at
home to take a look at this study and
find the next move for white a fantastic
study composed by at the time 15 year
old gookash and we will pick a winner
tweet your answer using hashtag chess
Champs and uh one winner will go home
with an air things device signed by
Magnus Carlson and
he is definitely one of the big
favorites to win the whole Championship
story 20 23.
if I can ask you to write how you think
the top five overall standings in
Champions Chester all of life this
season is Ali wrestler playing or is he
into fashion now should I put myself
yeah okay
okay I'll go with Magnus okay first one
is a long name
my mother is watching us I have to be
careful
you know what I can be confident no I
can put my name of course
you know I just beaten Magnus here and I
can say I'm returning my favorite there
returning a favor it's a good old friend
[Music]
yeah he's just been like winning all his
events whenever I see him play he wins
so he's probably gonna take this one as
well um dink has bad internet so he he
is left out
[Music]
your handwriting is very nice
that's all that's your only bet yeah all
right
look at that Magnus Carlson a little
arrogant or refreshingly feisty David
well it's uh the topless they don't lack
for confidence do they and they do back
it up on the board so fair play to them
definitely and one name that actually
many of the players put in the list
there was Jana pomyachi where is he on
the pony actually he's not playing
division one he is playing division two
in the air things monster some huge
names competing also in division two and
uh he did win as much yesterday against
Olympus was there any pickup sets would
you say Robert in division two yesterday
I think Vladimir krumnik lives in his
match against uh Salem now salaam is a
monster it's not a surprise that he won
but I think the many fans of the former
world champion will be saddened to see
Vladimir lose and go to the losers
bracket yeah and there were some upsets
also in division three there's also a
division three with 32 players and there
were some upsets yesterday yeah 32
players know more because players like
Liam lay Alexander grishook Vincent
kymer all had to leave the tournament
they suffered two match losses they're
gone
some huge names but we are following
closely division one and coming up first
today is the losers round one Serana
against farusha and mamadolf against
gukesh later today Wesley so is uh going
to play against Hikaru Nakamura in the
winter semi-finals and you actually gave
me some info a minute ago Robert Wesley
song is currently playing some chess he
is he's playing a bullet chess and
chess.com I saw him getting warmed up
for Hikaru Nakamura his knee going to be
have to be perfect in time trouble
playing it's Nakamura who is the speed
chess champion wow so he's actually do
you think that's the reason David he's
actually now warming up to face Nakamura
later today yeah there's mixed opinions
on this weather it's actually a good
form of preparation I remember doing the
candidates for Russia staying up all
night playing hundreds of bullet games
and then
falling to defeat the next day when it
came to classical chess but it's fair
enough he wants to get some confidence
he wants to get those mouth skills
working and you need him against
Nakamura yeah but first it is losers
round one and I'm the loser is round one
they play best and two rapid games and
the winner will go through to the losers
quarter final the loser in the match
today will be knocked out we're gonna
follow the first game between Alexa is
Serana and alireza farusha farusha had a
bad day yesterday so what you expect
from him today Tanya I'm expecting an
angry alibraza today that was the
Shocker of day one all the favorites
went through won their matches in
dominant style and Arjun versus alireza
was the big match which which stunned us
all and just the style in which alireza
lost as well I mean three to zero that
was unbelievable so I'm expecting an
angry Oliver looking for that win but
he's playing against Serana and Serana
is a dangerous opponent what kind of
styles are up against each other in this
match Roberts it's interesting because
Alexis serrana is extremely well
prepared otherwise the first doesn't get
that same nod for his opening repertoire
but you get him into a middle game where
it's a neutral position both sides
having to calculate all the raises at
his best uh-huh and it's been a little
bit it hasn't been a while since we've
seen the best stuff for shallow David
yeah we saw glimpses last year of course
he did play a in the candidates in the
St Louis rapid and Blitz he was on fire
just crushing everybody there but it's
just few and far between his tournament
appearances and that's why the rust
builds up and the longer you go without
playing especially as a young player the
harder it becomes and we saw that
yesterday Eric I see just blew him off
the board with some uh really impressive
tactics so uh he'll want to come back
today for a he will be better that's
guaranteed and he'll also be a bit angry
with which tends to help the top players
I'm looking forward to what is angry
chess how do you play when you're angry
uh more aggressively one two four
here we go this is day two of the air
things Masters game one on the losers
bracket and here we go we have some
wolves on the board we do it's a queen's
Pawn opening it's the Queen's Gambit but
uh the Queen's Gambit declined so far
um white here is very flexible the Night
comes out they call this the main
position or at least Alexander gristrict
does because black has six or seven very
viable uh moves here and what are we
predicting it's a big moment for black
to decide because you can't developed a
bishop just one square ahead on E7 David
and that becomes the Queen's Gambit
decline as you're mentioning or you
could be more aggressive and take it all
the way to B4 to pin that Knight on C3
and that would be the ragus in and I see
Ali Reza slowed down already so he's
thinking about what his approach will be
or will he just capture the C4 Pawn yeah
none of those but he's also going for
one of the most trendy variations wow
okay a capture here Queen takes D4 bring
the queen out early comes with some risk
attached uh warning there that your
queen will get kicked about a bit but uh
this is still very well known territory
there's been a lot of debate about this
opening
over the last couple of years I would
say and David you said yesterday you're
not a fan of the isolated Pawn you see
this Pawn on D5 the Queen's Pawn it's
all alone which means it's hard to keep
defended and look at White's forces all
them staring down at that pawn so that
is where the central tension lies it's
all about is white going to be able to
win that pawn and will black get
compensation if that pawn is indeed lost
yeah and it will revolve around that
square and maybe the square in front of
that pawn often if you can blockade an
isolated opponent uh you're doing well
in terms of stabilizing here white gives
a check Serana has played instantly up
to this point showing confidence we
mentioned he's just a monster with the
white pieces he's up there with the very
best in terms of opening preparation
when he has white maybe less impressive
with black but uh here already Persia
thinking I'm expecting him to just block
this check the Black Knight sitting at
home asleep on B8 comes out there we go
Knight C6 and uh yeah here white will
have a couple of moves I do believe that
you can just push your E Pawn forward
one square maybe even two squares to
really challenge Black's opening but it
definitely feels like up there's up to
this point for Asia I'm not sure where
these freestyling yet but he's just uh
less confident maybe he hasn't checked
this exact position uh this morning
and E4 they say is Best Buy test and I
think here is no exception push that
pawn two squares forward your King Pawn
and we just saw it on the board this is
threatening because the Rook stares down
the D file at the enemy queen that can
spell big trouble for farugia there's
this problem with the D5 Pawn being
isolated now under attack by most of
White's forces this feels like a
dangerous situation for alireza and
Alexei is the better prepared player of
the two yeah and the fact that Alexei is
better prepared and he paused for a
second means he didn't expect this black
uh night jump to C6 and he's really
trying to take advantage now if erosion
doesn't move quickly I fear for him in
this game uh you really need to know
your stuff here it's not the type of
position you can work out and be super
accurate in so uh what do we think what
is he contemplating big problems already
let's show uh the threats along the
defile of course this pin and pawn takes
Pawn monster threat right now uh you
could maybe even get rid of this Knight
traded off that is a defender of Black's
isolated Pawn in the center
hmm I'm wondering whether you can get
away with castling here but you have to
calculate Faris in calculation mode
trying to work out whether he can get
away with that one I don't really see
what else it looks like if you don't
Castle you're just losing a pawn anyway
and that's the big question for alireza
right now and as we can see he has gone
into a think tank so he's not familiar
with it understandably so because get
this guys only two games so far have
happened in this position with E4 on the
board so it is New Territory for these
players which is why alireza is taking
his time and David you're on point that
shot Castle is the way to go a D5 Pawn
looks so dangerous with that PIN it
needs to calculate these lines and I
think it's a good time to get into that
what happens after shot castle and
capture on D5 yeah process of
elimination black doesn't have that many
logical moves here actually no natural
moves at least and if you Castle your
king you should you seriously have to
calculate here not just uh Bishop takes
Knight but also maybe just a capture of
Pawns in the center and after the Knight
recaptures you're pinned along the
defile of course but maybe you're in
time to break the pin here black is
ahead in development if you look at
White's pieces the white bishop's still
asleep at home what hasn't castled this
king is very vulnerable on the open file
so it feels like this is hanging
together for black but maybe white can
finesse this somehow and just one more
move in this variation if white takes
the bishop on E7 and black takes with
the queen this showcases what the
problem is with keeping your king in the
center it looks like White's about to
scoop up a knight the rook and the
Knight team up on this 95 but look at
the queen on E7 staring all the way down
at the King on E1 once that Bishop moves
it is checked to the enemy King that
means you don't have time to take the
bishop with your Rook that leaves
alvareza not just okay but even better
leading in development and going after
the opponent's kick yeah and suddenly
this will backfire on white suddenly
whites in uh huge trouble a deadly
attack facing down against that
uncastled King this is why we always run
a castle by move 10 move 12 uh if we
don't want to take big risks and what's
making him pause then this doesn't look
too bad for black in the current
position if he does Castle maybe maybe
there's something else maybe white
doesn't take on the Square yet again I'm
hesitant to suggest a trade on the
center here because sooner or later
there will be a nasty check maybe we
flick in Bishop takes Knight we're
showing some long variations here but
this is what's going through mind
there's lots of captures in this
variation there's lots of forcing moves
so it's actually easier to calculate but
there's so many options that you
suddenly have to spend your time it's
such an important moment for furuja
right now with all these concrete
variations that need to be looked at and
this time format is so much about
psychology as well now Alexi Serrano
just did not get his kind of positions
against Magnus out of the opening but
here the more that alireza thinks the
more time he thinks I think Serana just
gets that much more confident he's happy
he's pleased with the opening outcome
that's not a good message you want to
send out to your opponent
yeah he's going to be gaining so much in
confidence every second that farisha is
in the tank here Serana and uh big
success for him in the opening and I
spoke to a few players just trying to
get their sense of what happened
yesterday and one of the words they used
for Serrano was unlucky they felt that
in the match against Magnus Carlson he
was not getting the openings that he is
most comfortable in and as we see here
in game one he is well ahead in the
clock the evaluation Bar says the white
is the side for choice at the moment and
we see by farusha the fact that he's not
making a move he feels like this is a
dangerous position there's tension in
the center it doesn't have to be
released that soon because of this pin
down the line from Rook on D1 to Queen
on d8 so this is a nice position for
serrana it's in his wheelhouse it's his
repertoire and this is really a danger
zone for farugia wow he's now down to
almost nine minutes on the clock that's
a huge thing the only pin is not the one
on D file the other one that he needs to
be careful about is that Knight on C6
which is spinned by that Queen on A4
which means that black doesn't have the
possibility to push that deep on and
block these Central files because if you
go D4 in fact whites two pieces uh the
Knight The Rook and the queen a third
piece as well targeting that pawn on D4
you just end up losing that pawn so this
is not even an option for black yeah
it's not an option and for sure just for
a second there he looked really pained
on the camera he looked like he hated
his position and as Tanya says here
Knight takes born you kind of attacking
everything and this will be almost
winning for white immediately so uh the
sticks are extremely high not just in
the tournament but also in this exact
position Pawn takes Pawn is a threat
version needs to deal with it and he
needs to do it quickly more than five
minutes can you actually allow yourself
that in this time control Robert I don't
think so and not only is it the time
Patrol is a problem this is a two-game
match so you start feeling the weight of
this game it's not like a four game
match you lose game one you get a few
whites to get back in it if he loses
game one I mean he has to give it his
all in the second game and he has to win
that on demand so he is in trouble right
now they're pins left and right uh the
both kings are in the Sun enter but the
problem is that this Pawn that sticks
out like a sore thumb on D5 that black
isolated pawn and that is the target
olly razor look at him he's biting his
sweatshirt he doesn't know what to do
he's worried does my opponent have four
or five more moves of theory up his
sleeve and that is scary territory for
the young player who now lives in France
yeah and uh serrana we joked yesterday
that was it a possible picture he looked
Frozen he was so stoic to drink as much
against Magnus but today just a few
moments ago he kind of uh kind of
stretched it out he was looking a bit
excited and I think he knows he has
caught vergia off guard this is as good
a chance as he's gonna get today in this
match and it looks like Oliver is hiding
his face behind his hoodie right now in
a big thing right out of the opening you
know in my opinion alireza is the kind
of player who when things are not going
his way tends to go on a bit of a tilt
and I'm just wondering his match against
Arjun was he that devastated out of it
that he just decided you know what I'm
not going to prepare I'm not going to
look at too much chess I'm going gonna
get my rest and see what happens I'm
gonna wing it but when you're playing
against Serana winging it is not a great
idea
that's the way to lose freestyling
against the top players you have to have
a match strategy you have to have an
opening plan and especially he's playing
one of the main lines uh playing C5 in
the opening like that with black
everybody's been doing it over the last
few years everybody knows their stuff
they've all been studying that exact
line Serana has prepared a tricky rare
variation we mentioned only been played
a few times uh but for Asia he maybe
should have known uh what he should be
doing here and down to six and a half
minutes already it's like it's frozen
someone needs to wake him up someone
needs to give him a shake and he knows
how critical this moment is right and
finally at long Lassie castles King
let's see how quickly Serrano plays
because if he keeps blitzing out moves
we know he's still in his repertoire he
has looked at this with our silicon
friends or mortal enemies whatever you
call the engines but Estrada keeps the
pace that is really okay he's moving so
quickly this is this is not over the
board inspiration this is preparation
this must be so annoying for alireza to
experience I like say just playing
immediately yeah it's Mind Games we talk
about the psychological battle sometimes
and in the opening there's uh so many
ways you can hurt your opponent either
with great preparation sometimes you can
Bluff them just by pushing them onto the
defensive Valley but he's doing all of
those Serrano he's bullying him on the
clock he's bullying him on the board
he's set up this really tense pin on the
defile and ferrugia was struggling to
find a move last move and castling was
by far the most natural he played a
natural move it still cost him what
eight nine minutes and now he's got an
even tougher decision ahead of him and
what hurts you the most is when you take
that eight minute make the right move
and then your opponent immediately
blitzes out a response and then once
again you go into a think tank where
what on move that's move number 10 and
alireza is down to five and a half
minutes Bishop E2 is the accurate move
that we were talking about the most
tempting option to take on D5 was not
the right choice to open up that file
the e-file with your king in the center
it looks like Serana is just on top of
this game he's got his preparation on
point and alireza is in trouble already
yeah and it's really unpleasant this
last move it's just a quiet move for
white keeping the tension and farouza
probably he spent the bulk of his time
thinking there just on the forcing lines
on the calculation your opponent plays a
quiet move and you're like wait I wasted
all my time working out all these
complicated lines and then you just do
that like it feels it feels like uh yeah
he's thrown away that time on the clock
and yeah so start those calculations
Anew because there still is the threat
upon capture's pawn bishop captures
Knight all of these captures available
to Alexis Serana and his King is feeling
a bit safer some of those variations
that save black were because there was a
check along the e-file the bishop sits
in front of the king so in some of these
tactical sequences white will actually
be uh for the good because that Bishop
blocks any sort of check not to mention
that if white has a free turn maybe the
best move is the castle the king get out
of the center and then continue to use
this pressure on the clock and the board
against alirez further this actually is
as scary as it gets for a top level
chess player yeah scary on the clock as
well four minutes now it's hard to kind
of offer him advice for Asia I don't
know what I would be doing here just
pure panic I think if I were in for your
shoes right now what is his biggest
problem because I have to say the black
king it looks quite safe I mean it
doesn't look like there's huge trouble
it's the clock Kaya he's down to four
minutes on the clock and we see he's
taken a drastic dramatic decision to
make this cream Panic he's pushed that
deep on because of course afraid of
giving that up on D5 with so many pieces
hanging D4 but it just loses a pawn you
can simply pick that up with a knight
white has got three pieces attacking
that pawn black has only two Defenders
and now furja down on the clock and down
upon yeah and I'm trying to figure out
what he wants next maybe he'll trade off
a set of nights and once white
recaptures again you can take with the
Rook you can take with the queen then he
might move the black queen out and start
at least creating some annoying threats
against White's undefended Queen side so
in terms of practicality it looks like a
decent decision he's at least going to
survive the opening but it has come at
the cost of a pawn and the cost of a lot
of time on the clock of course but the
best players in the world did rather be
down just one Pawn if it means that
their pieces get activity and as we see
in the analysis board Black's pieces are
free-flowing down material up in terms
of development the white King still
being in the center and if the Queens
come off the board let's say the Queens
get traded black remains down upon you
may think well I'm only down one Pawn I
have some chances here in an end game
because that pollen E4 while it's extra
it's not going anywhere so that is what
alireza fuja has considered I think with
the lead on the clock that Serana has he
can milk this end game in advance
forever and at some point the clock will
be a huge issue for farugia Yep this
looks like the best version can get
right now just an end game uh queenless
position at least down the port and
Serana he will stop to think he's played
very quickly up to this point but he's
saving that time in the bank for later
and uh yeah it just looks like a master
class so far I really need to go and
study for some Runners games when he has
white because every time I see him he
just seems to outplay his opponents or
seems to get a big Advantage even
against the best in the world it just
feels like if it was the same position
but fuja had 11 minutes on the clock we
might not have been so critical about
the whole approach he has sacrificed
upon to be able to get out of this
opening trouble makes a lot of sense it
really makes life easier you've got more
space you trade off more pieces at least
you're not losing on the spot but once
again the clock is going to tell at some
point and we see Serana doing what we
are advised when we start playing chess
when you're up on the material try and
trade off as many pieces as possible so
he goes for the idea of trying to get an
end game with Queen D4 and I don't
expect alireza to accept that trade he
says not happening moves away with the
queen yeah Dodges the queen trade but
immediately Serrano replies again he's
hammering home the point he's oh well I
was gonna say almost 10 minutes on the
clock he's more than 10 minutes up on
the clock at this point he drops his
Bishop back for a defensive move for
white that Bishop was previously very
proud on G5 but now he's just
controlling all the squares lining up a
discovered attack against the black
queen and he's covering everything he's
going to Castle next with a pawn
Advantage he's not here by accident he
defeated Fabiano caruana to make it
through to division one he has performed
admirably in the rapid Chess
Championship he beat video Gujarati and
chakra mom and jarov in match play in
the global championship and now against
alireza faruza he is playing instantly
and David I think you and I are two of
the biggest culprits of this we get
ourselves into way too much time travel
leaving our opponents well ahead on the
clock and here we see faruzo when we're
not playing it ourselves or watching
someone else it feels like suffering and
I feel for farooza here because he's
just down the pawn with minimal to no
compensation yeah that's why we're not
there Robert playing with these uh
Giants because we get into too much time
trouble ourselves uh but for Russia he
needs to dig himself out of this hole
how did you guys deal with kind of being
in a funk it feels like farouza right
now he's he's just not himself
but the one thing about fuja is you
cannot underestimate him just because he
is low on time we've seen what a beast
he is with just seconds on the clock
he's one of the fastest players in the
world so Serana also needs to be careful
about not falling into the Trap of
playing against feroza's clock he still
needs to make objectively good decisions
on the board and keep that Advantage
going and we can see alireza is creating
a mess on the board look at that last
move notice that last move Bishop to C5
now the queen on A5 is hanging a
discovered attack but alireza doesn't
care about that he actually
counter-attacks White's Queen in the
center and wow
what just happened oh no it's the attack
on his Queen and he counter attacks
against the black queen I'm not sure
that would have even been on my radar
that move Knight A4 what a cool move and
it's a double attack he hits the black
queen he hits the black Bishop he's
forcing the Queens off the board and
this has happened the Queens are gone
and what you were talking about when
your head material let's trade pieces
and now black shuffles back let's trade
those pieces when once the bishop goes
to E5 Bishop C3 just trade off more
pieces you have a healthy extra Pawn in
the center as long as you can defend it
and with the Knight okay he's doing just
that I think Alexis serrana is just
feeling it right now he got the exact
type of position he wanted as I was
mentioning a few moments ago that
players were telling me they felt like
Serrano was unlucky against Magnus just
didn't get the positions that he knows
very well and he has just that and more
in game one against faruga yeah ferrush
is in the funk and uh serrana is in the
flow he's just doing everything right so
far extra important okay no Bishop trade
there but uh plenty of options you can
just solidify your Central Pawn if you
want you can kind of go in with the
white knight there is an attack maybe
against this A2 Pawn uh the black Bishop
buying it from afar but I wonder whether
it's Serana cares too much about that
one uh he would like to keep performing
Advantage if he can this is very clever
I've got to say this last move from Far
Asia yeah and the more you look at it
the more you like it because you realize
that it's not just the A2 Pawn that's
hanging but also the E4 Pawn in the
center which means you kind of have to
give up one of them a natural looking
move like the advance of the the F Pawn
next to the Central Pawn to defend it
just means that you lose your material
advantage so Olivers are there being a
little tricky while Serana looking like
Mr Cool on camera yeah for the first
first time at least Serana has a
question to answer he's played perfectly
up to this point we do see that the
evaluation bar confirms his Advantage he
is a pointer Patrol but still some work
to be done converting these advantages
against the top there's Elite GMS it's
still a lot of work in such a position
when two pawns are attacked you're
always tempted to defend your Central
Pawn you don't want to give up your
Central Pawn so I'm expecting Serana to
make the decision of actually keeping
that E4 Pawn guarded while giving up the
A2 pawn and also opening up the a file
in that process
the Knight jumping in to see five
attacking the B7 weakness lots of
threats here yeah lots of threats for
Asia leaning back now two minutes
against over 10 minutes yeah this is the
right time to think this is the right
time to just calm yourself down you know
you've done a lot of uh good work
already and uh yeah how is he gonna
approach it that's the big question for
alireza remember on the losers bracket
it's best out of two rapid games this is
the first game one more rapid game if
they are tied then it will be decided in
Armageddon tie breaks and one of these
two players will be knocked out today
the winner of the match will go through
to the losers quarterfinals
and we have a move on the board wow
serrana he's just doing the one-two
punch he was thinking to figure out a
plan he played that pawn push that Tanya
was recommending keeping his Center nice
and defended and then hops forward with
his Knight putting farooja back on the
clock and alireza farooja was the 2021
bullet chess champion he took down a car
knock more in the process we know what
he's capable of but bullet chess is when
both sides have one minute it's faruga
with one and almost two at this point
and then we have Serrano with 10 that is
not good news for alireza yeah it's a
rapper chess against bullet chess and I
think we know who we would want to be
here in the studio whose time we would
want to have yeah and uh yeah the
knights attacked options do we move that
night we can bring it to some juicy
squares we can bring it into maybe the
A6 Square attacking Black start Square
Bishop I'm looking for options here
maybe we can land it on D7
and okay of course he doesn't go right I
don't know if he goes for something
potentially even stronger he's playing
an amazing game because there are a
series of one move threats that he feels
like he can ignore and create better
threats for himself what he's doing is
giving up his Knight where it sits
taking this bishop in return so not only
will black have a compromised Pawn
structure where it will also have the
pair of Bishops look at that black
knight it's dominated by White's pawns
they're just keeping control of the
forward jumps and that means the bishop
pair will thrive in this position
serrana is playing a masterpiece thus
far let's see if he's able to convert it
because I would not envy the task of all
the Reza farusia yeah these Bishops are
just gonna be so beautiful uh I think
having the two Bishops is my favorite
thing in the whole uh it's gonna say uh
it's just my favorite thing
but uh yeah I mean here is like the uh
epitome of uh strong Bishops you can
just plant your Bishop on C4 look how
powerful they are controlling the whole
board look at this black Bishop it's
just a whole it's just a big Pawn here
uh block of wood on B6 locked in doing
nothing and of course he plays that move
Outpost for the bishop and uh this one
feels like uh Serrano has almost got it
in the bag strategically black is busted
but uh he will be looking for counter
chances for Asia he's playing bullet
remember and uh after a couple of moves
he drops his Knight back this one is
dominated so he's at least trying to
reroute this piece I like that idea I
like the idea of trying to bring that
Knight to D6 an important defensive
resource uh we've been singing praises
of white double bishop and you want to
get rid of that you want to put pressure
on that once that Bishop from C4 moves
away you can actually push the seep on
yourself open up that dead Bishop on B6
which is really uh dying for some life
in this position so Ali Reza is still
holding on still fighting with just a
minute and 20 seconds on the clock yep
I've got Serana still with plenty of
time in the bank and uh again I'm
expecting him at this point to just play
a kind of smooth seamless game and
convert this everything perfect so far
Robert and I feel like for farooza you
need think you need to Envision a future
that seems best for your chances and
what that would be from my perspective
is taking away the pawns on the left
side of the board the Queen side pawns
if they evaporate that's two for black
one for white you go down a pawn but
with only pawns on one side of the board
that means that the Knight is a better
Defender so I do think that there are
some long-term chances here for fuja the
issue is he doesn't have that much time
so long term may not be that long for
someone who only is one minute and 20
seconds yeah and Serana here he has a
bunch of plans he can start trading off
all the Rooks if you imagine all the
Rooks disappearing from the board then
the Bishops only gain in power they gain
an influence uh also it might be time
soon to start advancing your majority in
terms of Pawn structure white does have
four versus three on the king side so uh
normally you should play on the side
you're stronger I wouldn't be surprised
if those white pawns over there do start
throwing themselves forward in the near
future and Serana he has fans out there
we saw Aditya cheering on the young
Russian in this first game of today do
share your thoughts your questions your
selfies using the hashtag chess Champs
on Twitter you can also reach us in the
twitch chat ask your question come with
your comments let us know who you're
rooting for and we will address uh
questions from the twitch chat as well
we love having you guys joining us for
another exciting day of Chess yeah and I
just looked across I saw Robert give a
nod of approval on this last move for
white not the first time in this game oh
it's unbelievable play he's just
restricting all of Black's forces his
Bishop was under attack instead of
sliding It Forward into the center he
goes to the rim just making sure those
pawns can't move bring his other Rook
into the game now all of White's pieces
are doing something useful this is just
such a great performance and yet there's
still so much work left the top players
they do not go down without a fight and
all they raise the further he's
remaining solid even if his position
does not look desirable he's not going
to make this easy for Serana I look at
that night maneuver he jumps back with
the Knight trying to trade out one pair
of Rooks and now the Knight is headed
towards another Direction it wants to
come to that C7 Square where it does hit
the bishop on A6 it will land in the
center of the board from E6 to D4 so
there are a lot of night jumps that
white needs to watch out for and alireza
is not going to make this technique easy
Serrano still has a lot of work to do
yeah if one of the Bishops disappears
then we can start talking about serious
drawing chances for black I don't think
we'll see far Asia win this game he's
definitely not thinking about the result
here he's just trying to survive live
and to put tany's idea on the board if
white does for example Advance the porn
I'm not sure which one then uh the
Knight will hit the bishop you don't
want to allow that trade but the Knight
will at least find a Central Square you
might have to trade it off if you want
to prevent it from landing on a nice
Outpost so farouza he's kind of
contorting himself he's wriggling away
trying to find some activity for his
pieces but Serana says no I'm just going
to step back with this bishop and uh
okay after Knight C7 is he going to
eliminate the Knight once it gets here
does he have a way to keep the bishop
pen intact
if you can he should win maybe he'll
just play around the night maybe he'll
just ignore it through now finally under
one minute what is the winning plan for
sirana in this game great question Kyle
if we had the answer we'd be playing and
winning these games but the key to this
position I think because of the clock
situation is you need to keep some of
the tension and then Serana says no not
at all I'm going to trade all the pieces
but that may look like we're liquidating
into an even end game just because the
materials even doesn't mean the position
is level look at the white king it's
about to run up the board if you see a
direct line diagonally up to A4 and it
can go up there and start harassing
Black's pawns so this is a an
advantageous end game for white the
bishop stare across to the king side
pressuring the black pawns over there so
it's white who can play on both sides of
the board that's the power of the bishop
pair
and this last move is six it might look
like it's got no idea but again it's
about those night jumps alirez are
relying on that Knight on C7 to get to
B5 to get to D4 trying to eliminate one
of the Bishops if he manages to trade
the Knight for a bishop he saves half a
point yep he will get the draw if that
happens but it's a big
if he needs to run away from this trade
and there we go again he's utilized this
pattern many times Robert touched upon
it yesterday nights can be dominated by
pawns but they can also be dominated by
Bishops and often when there's two
squares in between them so this bishop
controls a lot of squares that the Black
Knight wants to use and yes The Bishop's
been kicked back but he's kept the pair
intact and uh yeah there's a clear path
for the white king sooner or later
you'll start stepping forward on the
side you're stronger and the players are
really speeding up here especially for
Asia so let's just see whether serana's
technique is sufficient it's definitely
very favorable this end game but still a
lot of work to be done one of the ideas
that white skin has is to move closer to
the C5 pawn it is a big weakness in
Black's Camp so imagine those light
squared Bishop steps one square ahead
and then the king takes its spot then
you bring the bishop back to attack that
pawn on C5 and create and show that the
weaknesses are going to count meanwhile
it's hard to come up with a plan for
black
that's often the case when you're
playing against the bishop the bishop
and Knight for black don't really work
so well in tandem uh it's very hard to
find a productive plan for them the
Black Knight is stuck where it is
because that black A6 Pawn black has two
isolated pawns on the left side and uh
that A6 Pawn is an eternal weakness and
I'm not sure what he's doing other than
just trying to hold the fort here for
Asia and sooner or later he'll be
completely tied up on one side and
Serana will switch his focus and he's
already switched Focus he's going for
that isolated Pawn that we mentioned and
the only way to defend it is David is to
fall back with the Knight to C7 and it
might be tempting to actually trade that
Bishop but that would result in an
opposite color bishop and look at this
he sacrifices a pawn but this I don't
understand just grab the A6 spawn thank
you very much yeah finally the kind of
strategic Advantage we've been talking
about is going to become a material
advantage it's going to become something
more tangible but uh yeah I guess if you
can get one set of Bishops off the board
while the white king is stranded on the
side he will have some hope
oh I say that reluctantly because I
think this is hopeless for black now but
Robert it is something I was attempting
to foreshadow earlier though if white
takes the A6 and the C5 pawns but has to
give the B2 pawn and the bishops get
traded we may get a situation where it's
an extra Pawn for white but all pawns on
the same side of the board those may be
easier to blockade that is what alireza
is hoping for he's praying at this point
he's 20 seconds and Alexis Serrano has
nearly five minutes on the clock so he
is trying everything he can he sees
certain positions they give him the best
chances but they're just chances at this
point as the advantage grows for Serrano
yeah and this is textbook in terms of
clock handling for white zarana he's
spent a lot of time but he's used it at
uh the wise moments and he's still got
five minutes 20 seconds to defend this
position you will get a position later
when you have to answer very difficult
questions there might be a race between
pawns for example and to calculate that
with 20 seconds he might be uh bullet
Champion but now this one
it's going to be an uphill struggle and
uh yeah Tanya I agree you should just
grab that pawn first what's wrong with
that one it's very admirable the way
Oliver's husband defending this game so
far he's been playing majority of the
moves in about a minute on the clock and
he's managed to survive it create his
chances look at that he trades the H2
Pawn for the C5 pawn and the material
balance still black has got all the
pawns intact
yeah I'm not sure I like that too much I
really kind of enjoyed the fact that
white had a majority on the king side
just saving it for later you could start
pushing on that flank when you're ready
he's kind of banking everything now
Serana on the white B Pawn running up
and promoting long term yes he might
pick off that straggler on A6 it's going
to fall in the next few moves but
Black's Knight is active Black's Knight
can go towards those King side pawns
maybe some hints of counter play and you
were mentioning it might be a race it
might very well be because look at that
night it's threatening the bishop on C5
it has to fall back a nice Square there
making sure that the bishop dominates
the Knight not allowing the Knight to
jump forward but it can because if you
trade it will be a draw on the spot with
the opposite color Bishops so Serana
making his intentions clear he's never
going to trade that Bishop for the night
yeah it feels like he's a bit nervous
though Serana again just changing
posture slightly on camera his last few
moves I don't want to say ugly but
pushing the white pawns now on the king
side whoa now all of the queen side
pawns have disappeared but the Knight is
trapped that is what Alexis surround has
been and he brings his Bishop back the
Knight is stuck so if the white king
slides back which is about to do then
the dark Square Bishop can join in and
attacking the Knight I think he's
winning that piece
went down to his last few seconds that
for Asia and now Robert it's a simple
plan straight path towards that black
knight for the white king I think this
was a really cunning trap he said yes
you can get your ideal Pawn structure in
terms of just on one flank but uh you've
had to plant your knight on this
horrible uh Square you've had to
misplace it and I don't see any way out
there's no Escape Route for that black
knight the only chance for furition now
is to create a past Pawn this is the
reason for his last move he wants to
start pushing the black H Pawn forward
and uh hope it will be enough of a
distraction
it's a race and uh does white lock it
down now on the king size maybe G5
stopping Black from creating a past Pawn
will that provoke resignation wow
suddenly has no plan the Black Knight is
stranded and lost
uh looks like no he still has some time
at this
he gets the king opposition but what he
wants to do is give up this Knight and
dart his King in to the enemy territory
I don't quite think it's sufficient but
if the black king runs all the way in
and then back to take this Pawn on G5 in
the dark Square maybe there are some
chances to start trading off the pawns
create a passer it looks completely
hopeless but that's what he's hoping for
that maybe surround will make a mistake
I don't think so given how perfectly
he's played this game yeah he's played
so well and I'm expecting the king to
drop back and just to show Robert's uh
idea that the only chance to try and
save this game is to jump in with the
black king to kind of go in but it takes
so long you can pick off this Knight at
will and uh it feels like this bishop
should be able to kind of get its way
around at some point to go for the black
pawns I'm not sure exactly how to finish
this one off for white you do have a
whole extra Bishop now but you have to
at least keep one Pawn you need to
promote later to win this game so Serana
he's doing the right thing again sitting
on his hands just not committing yet
he's going to pick off this Black Knight
there's no way and it's going to come
out anyway so he's just trying to find
the way he can win it on his own terms
maybe without allowing any counter play
for the black king
looking for good for white two minutes
it should be enough
and one technique can be once black skin
enters you bring your own King to defend
that bishop or need to defend those
pawns and eventually the bishop will go
on to attack Black's King Side Pawn
we're going to see this being played out
white will pick up the Knight black will
move with the King forward and I'm just
wondering if Serana wants to bring his
own King to defend that Bishop to keep
the F3 Pawn defended
that looks like a very uh clever
strategy Tanya although yes still some
little ideas to work out a bit later on
the fact that saran is thinking leaves
been really something devious up his
sleeve he has not catch the knife he
might make him a pawn F4 wow giving up
his Pawn for free but establishing a
past Pawn that he can defend with his
bishop and that should land a winning
end game so uh he could take the Knight
of course or get pushed upon it there we
go yeah but I only figured that out
because he was thinking like he was
spending time what else is he
calculating besides King takes Knight
Alexis serrana is a brilliant player
this game has been magnificent what a
performance by him whoa and okay we have
to go back to life boards everything
just happened there in the blink of an
eye and uh wow White made a new queen
with the eporn we'll go back and maybe
uh show that an action replay but uh
there we go is about to resign White's
Pawn Central Pawn did run through
promote and uh just in time to stop
Black sport and there it is he starts
off with a win Alexa is Serana ranked as
number 17 in the world a crushing win
over alireza ranked at number four in
the world taking the lead here Alexis
Rona you seem so impressed with this
game Robert that was one of the cleanest
games I think I've ever seen wow I mean
it was that dominant from start to
finish great opening preparation forcing
Olive Rays on his back foot in time
trouble and then thinking of the
critical moments and finding
breakthroughs like a pawn sacrifice in
the end game from the opening to the
middle game all the way through to the
very last Pond perfect game incredible
take us through the highlights David
yeah I just want to show you how Serana
finished it off as Robert said perfect
game this is going to end up in some
strategy books that's guaranteed at some
point and uh here we were mentioning
that white could simply pick up the
Black Knight some calculations would be
done but it should be winning you only
have to work out an answer to Black's
King running in instead Serana came up
with an ingenious solution he realized
that black knight is trapped anyway he
first pushed a pawn forward before the
black king can run in and after a
capture he simply took the Knight now
and this blockade ensures Victory
Black's King now if it wants to come in
which it did does allow the black the
white porn sorry to run forward we'll
see what happened there but if you just
stay then White's King will slowly but
surely creep in to support its past Pawn
so just to show how the game finished
the black king came in Serana calculated
this so quickly now we saw everything
happen in the blink of an eye white
promoted first just in time to come back
and stop the black porn you just sit in
front of it blockade it and uh the white
king will come over to assist its
capture in the near future perfect game
by Serana
this whole concept of just bulldozing
the black king jumping in there with the
queen and making sure the Rook comes in
with a ladder mate is everything this
chapter is about everything this chapter
is about
the point is I don't want you to get a
move that's not in the course and go I
don't know what to do
percent of games
percent of the time and I think if you
learn these lines that very easily could
be 75 or 80 for you
[Music]
we're going to take a break now for
anyone who are not subscribers on Twitch
for everyone else we're gonna dig into
both of the games in the first round of
round one on the losers bracket
foreign
[Music]
calling it one of the cleanest games
he's ever seen Alexa is Serrano with a
magnificent win in the first game here I
have to say it was a very impressive
game you do not underestimate Alex
Alexis Arana he might be ranked number
70 in the world but boy is he dangerous
with the white pieces and now it's all
about farrugia whether he can compose
himself he does have the white pieces
next so he's just gonna have to go
forget what happened and just keep
playing just never let that tension die
and the other match up on the losers
bracket you cash against marmadon we had
a win for the young 16 year old what
happened yeah and I have to say it was a
very impressive win from the young
Indian you know he just came very well
prepared it was mamadov who was under
pressure on the clock the whole time and
he just seemed to be struggling not just
on the board but also mentally as well
it just looked like he hadn't shaken off
those demons from yesterday and in the
end you know it was a big fights but it
all fell down to a one move blunder by
namadov and after that you know this
this teenager he's a tactical genius
yeah and he doesn't let those chances
slip yeah and we do have a puzzle a
study a challenge for all our viewers
today from a study composed by Gucci she
composed it when he was only 15 years
old yeah and what what are we looking at
here yeah I mean this is the end line of
a study that composed and the one thing
I want to say is we've seen a lot of
answers on Twitter not many people I've
got it right don't be seduced by
material is All I'm gonna say but uh
just think about the opportunities that
white gets because this Knight is
stranded it can't join the action very
quickly and you have to remember some of
the golden rules and end games
okay okay that's a big big hint I don't
want to spell it out for everyone but
it's white to play try and find the plan
and once you get it you can appreciate
the genius of good cash yeah we're
looking for the next move for white you
can tweet your answer using the hashtag
chess champ maybe you want to tweet us a
picture of how you are solving this very
sophisticated uh study maybe you're
solving it with your friends family
co-workers what do I know tweet us using
hashtag chess Champs one lucky winner
will get an air things device signed by
Magnus Carlsen and composing a study
like this at only 15 years old first of
all will all Grandmasters do this
compose studies is this normal
um quite frankly no I mean it's very
rare to see someone study a composed
studies and it's also very rare to see
someone who's so young actually have
that interest so I mean no this is the
short answer to that question he is
genius gukesh and he is in the lead in
his match on the losers bracket second
game is coming up very shortly
too your things monsters more than five
minutes can you actually allow yourself
of that in this time control I don't
think so whoa now all the queen side
pawns have disappeared but the name is
trapped there we go first is about to
resign
all right you guys some more action is
coming up have you guys composed Studies
by the way I try to solve them more
often fail than succeeded but uh
composing that's another level yeah I
love solving them and while Ivanka was
showing us the study I was trying in my
head to understand what really stood out
to me was that kukesh at just 15
composed the study absolute genius but
more than that shows the maturity that
he studied was an end game study not
with a lot of pieces it's all and that
is just a reflection of his majority and
his creativity
what uh what a chess genius yeah what a
guy and he is in the lead in his match
remember on the losers bracket they play
best out of two games so this is must
win for alireza verusa and for mamadol
and here we go game two has started and
we gotta remember fruition now in a must
win situation well it's an open Sicilian
it's a night of Kaya your favorite
opening so we should remember version
now he's lost four games in a row wow
has he ever been in a situation like
this I doubt ever in his career to be
honest and uh okay it's a revelation of
the night off white Bishop coming out to
D3 and a nice little trick here nice
little tactic uh that uh we have a
little chuckle about here in the studio
but we have to show the idea on the
board because white is giving up a piece
but uh he it's just a piece of bait here
it's poisoned this night on default you
cannot of course take it because your
queen will be lost he's pausing I don't
think he's trying to uh work out if he
can take this Knight because there will
be a bishop check discovered attack and
next move the black queen drops so uh
we're going to head back towards more
standard conventional ideas now the
White Knight is hit it will Retreat I'm
not sure in which direction and uh the
game will go on and once again we see
always as the first one to go into the
think tank not a positive sign I think
in this this game which he has to win on
demand to force the playoff alireza is
not only fighting against Serana but his
own mind David as you pointed out that
was his fourth loss in a row and that is
going to be super hard to block uh I
think this is big disadvantage to
alireza yeah and he has to avoid going
into the tank for too long this time we
know the clock cost him in the last game
and uh okay still early days he's
thinking a little bit now
uh but Robert who do you think this
opening is going to favor I just think
that sometimes your strength can be your
weakness because one of Alvarez's
biggest strengths he can play any type
of position uh he is feeling at home
totally comfortable no matter what the
Dynamics are but Alexis surround on the
other hand he studies very deeply we saw
in that first game there he knew the
opening better here in game two uh it's
been an offbeat opening the queen out
early for black but he is the one who
has not spent any time whereas farouza
he continues to think here and part of
the reason why is that black queen
slices across the board the white king
will not be able to easily Castle so
he's not just thinking about where to
move his Knight is alireza fuja that's
under attack in the center he should
figure out what is his five move plan
where is his King eventually going to go
those are the big questions that he
needs to answer right now before he
makes this turn five move plan wow he
ignores anything he just goes straight
on the attack
what is with these players just never
defending the attack piece but it's
always as if they seem to epitomize the
concept of offense is the best defense
the Knight is attacked he says I don't
care about it I'm gonna go for your own
night and that's absolutely crazy
because if you do take the night the
centralized Knight on D4 white picks up
the Knight on F6 and there's another
Knight hanging but also Black's Rook is
hanging on h8 tactics everywhere yeah
yeah it's total chaos a big mess but it
feels like a mess that will favor white
uh simply black isn't developed and
Black's King potentially weaker in the
center here so I don't think he can
stomach this I think this Knight will be
defended uh you can defend this with its
fellow Knight maybe maybe with a bishop
but uh it's very complicated I'm happy
that I'm not playing this position as
black against veruga I've got to say uh
but Serana he will find a way to keep
some measure of control at least and uh
Robert in terms of a five-year plan or A
Five-Year Plan what do you think Serana
is gonna go for here well The Five-Year
Plan is across 20 no I'm in this
position I think that Serana he is
looking at the Knight he does not want
to give it up without a fight and what
is concerning from his perspective is
he's spending time it was just talking
about how well prepared he is he's
clearly out of his preparation he's on
his own which either means that alireza
did not make the most principled reply
in the position and maybe there's a
slight inaccuracy or it just can't study
every single line Under the Sun and now
he has to figure it out I do think
sliding the Dark Sword Bishop up makes
the most sense let's just defend our
Knight with our Bishop we don't want to
block our other Bishop because Knight B8
to D7 keeps our Bishop and see it at
home so I think that after the Knight
develops the White Knight moves out the
way and then you kind of regret putting
your knight in your Bishop's path you
would love to jump over that Knight to
E6 with your Bishop that's not legal
unfortunately so he has in fact
developed his dark Square Bishop instead
of bringing his Knight out well the
reason he took a little bit of a think
there was because once again we have a
position that we haven't seen before it
is brand new territory for both these
players and the one point that alireza
needs to keep in mind or at least show
what the point was with moving that
Bishop from C1 to G5 in the previous
movies that the B2 Pawn is also
undefended in certain positions you have
to be careful with that because you can
end up losing the queen but now for
example David if you were to fall back
with the Knight to B3 to defend that
Central Knight there are so many tactics
that you have to keep in mind is light
takes the Central Pawn a possibility and
we need to take a look at that because
wow white might be losing upon here and
let's just show the tactics now your
Bishop on G5 is hanging if you trade the
bishop on E7 black can't pick up the
Knight on C3 into meso time hit that
Queen on D1 or even stronger oh yeah
they say when you see Checkmate look for
better so you did a good job there but
also Knight takes C3 very strong there
Tanya but I'm not going to argue with
Queen after you Checkmate and so Bishop
B7 is not the possibility and Knight E4
is what white is relying on but it
doesn't stop that because you pick up
the bishop on G5 white has to recapture
the bishop and now we're talking about
that Queen on B6 it slides in gives a
check and it's a double attack white
ends up losing that Knight on G5 and
this is huge trouble and I'm just
wondering if this move Bishop G5 was in
fact a bad move wow and uh play
transitions into a totally type of a
totally different type of position I
think he was afraid of this he might
have spotted this Tanya perhaps too late
for user there and he was forced to give
up his dark Square bishop and jump in
with the white knight a double attack of
course but uh black can hold both pieces
by retreating and just to catch up with
the game the night drops back and the
bishop It's All About Now a fight for
this outpost on D5 this is a beautiful
Square for the White Knight supported by
the bishop queen porn uh but black has
the bishop pair and can play around the
square this is very typical for a
sicilian I've always slightly preferred
white in these positions but uh it's
very much a matter of taste it's uh
going to at least enter a maneuvering
stage now both sides eventually will try
to get their kings to safety and maybe
Advance pawns on opposite flanks uh very
tense what do you guys think what are
the chances of this match actually going
into an Armageddon right now with prusa
having lost four games in a row and he
has to win on demand chants are much
higher for Alexi Serrano holding this
game I think he just has such a solid
base to his position in any night or
this is the opening that we saw in this
game the D5 square is so important the
Knight sits there but look at black
fighting for that square and not to
mention that only black has a dark
Square Bishop so if that Knight does not
capture the bishop on the dark squares
watch out in the long term you have your
pawns on lights it means the dark
squares are exposed in White's Camp so I
just don't see what white goes after
here I like Alexi's position I like his
clock management and I just feel like
all there is has not found his footing
in this two-game match this is his only
chance and he's doing everything he can
but I think that Alexa has been very
solid yeah again he hasn't put a foot
wrong the whole day just the perfect
game with white and now solid with black
that's all you need to do at the top
level just survive the opening equalize
and try to turn things in your favor a
bit later on but as Robert says solid
base a solid start to this one is black
at least he's done something the
fruition didn't in the previous game
he's just uh consolidated keeping things
under control and for threats keep
coming he's hitting that undefended
white Bishop at some point I'm expecting
surrender to Castle and he's out of the
woods in terms of the opening no
problems at all it is a must win for
alireza Russia to have any chances of
taking this to armaged on the situation
it's the same for Mama Dom he lost the
first game to get cash he has to end the
second game should we take a look at
what's happening I can see the bar is
liking the situation for gukesh with a
draw or a win he will be through to the
losers quarterfinals
and with a loss that one will go to
Armageddon but I do suggest we jump over
to take a look at what's happening
between gukesh and mohammadov
and okay still early days in this one
only one set of Pawns have been
exchanged it does look like a filler
door defense let me check yes it was and
uh here I've always been very biased
towards White you have a nice Pawn in
the center on e4 you have great
attacking chances where it's Rooks are
already centralized connected in the
center it definitely feels like mamadolf
look at the camera actually he's
suffering but uh he's taking big big
risks with black it's not objectively
correct this type of opening but uh at
least it keeps a lot of tension it keeps
a lot of pieces on the board and white
has got this huge plan of going F4 of
pushing these spawns and you hit that
Knight on E5 the Knight on F6 is soft
imagine a trade there where black skin
side Bond structure gets destroyed and
gokish needs just a draw to win this
match I'm loving everything that he's
done he's developed all his pieces he's
taken out the time to bring the Rooks to
the central file the bishop on D4
looking strong the Knight on H4 eyeing
that F5 Square F4 a huge threat on the
board big questions to Ralph what is he
going to play to counter all these ideas
now we've had like a million good things
for white we need to find some positives
for black now
um yeah I'm out of ideas but I will say
that he's giving it his all because uh
what the words David used objectively
the position is better for white and
that is true but if you are objectively
very solid for black then you just might
allow your opponent to make a quick draw
he it's it draws the equivalent to a
loss for Ralph momentov he's just trying
to keep some sort of imbalance so we
don't have a symmetrical Pawn structure
that's the good news there's a rook on
E8 for black staring towards that white
Pawn in the center it's a very strong
Pawn but maybe if you're not careful it
could come under Fire and there's this
Knight on H4 for white it is aiming
towards the F5 square that will lead to
an attack but maybe it's also offside
and there could be a way to take
advantage of that fact I love White's
position I think that Ralph also is
enjoying good Cash's position but he at
least is creating a position where it's
not just relying and opening preparation
both players are on their own yeah both
players are on their own and uh I'm
wondering you mentioned that there's a
big threat here Tanya and wow he's
prevented that that threat in a really
committal way we've got to say this one
looked too strong you cannot allow white
the time to kick away the central Knight
but he's uh we can do some King in the
process that is such a drastic
commitment on the king side and I am not
loving it it might have been the only
way to start by four but does it really
stop therefore because now that you've
gone G5 I'm actually super tempted to
push that pawn even further you know you
were trying to stop my idea but why
should I you're hitting my knight I'm
hitting your knight and in the entire
bargain your king gets super weak on G8
yeah it's going to be an open King for
the rest of the game for Ralph uh very
complicated uh decision there I guess
the only alternative for white would be
to land a knight in F5 if the Knight
could sit there forever you're gonna
launch an attack you're gonna win this
game for white but it can be eliminated
so at least uh Ralph here has some
measure of stability at least he
controls the dark squares but uh what do
you think of this one Robert it looks uh
yeah very committal if we both said but
maybe it was necessary he needs to take
his chances and while we acknowledge
that white has the better position from
an objective lens it does give the
opportunity for him to create an
imbalance and that's where these top
players go wrong most often if you just
give them a solid static position
they'll maneuver around improve and they
will not lose that edge here with the
move G5 happening your Knights under
attack so F4 is a brave decision that
Tanya is calling for it's not our pieces
it's easy to make that move but for a
gooket she's like wait a second he does
it all right he does it he listens to
Tanya here uh maybe you you know you
know gookesh better than we do but that
is a big moment because if like takes
this Knight on HR I think he should do
that and white takes the Knight on E5
and pawn takes back black is temporarily
up a pawn the dark squares are under
Black's control the Knight on F6 can hop
over to H5 use those dark squares to his
Advantage so this is what you dream of
when you need to play for a win you may
lose the game but you do have winning
chances yeah for example haircut would
most likely drop his Bishop back I'm
hesitant to kind of choose a square you
can make an argument for both hitting
either this Pawn or hitting this pawn
and uh okay he chooses immediately of
course go cash and yeah he's doing the
right thing when you only need a draw
just play your normal game don't play
don't make passive decisions don't make
negative decisions just forget the
resultant and that's when the best
results come yeah he's playing the board
not the math situation currently and I
love this idea Robert you were talking
about that extra Pawn but who cares
about the extra Pawn look at Black's
horrible structure on the king side and
that pawn is not going to survive for
too long one of the moves that comes to
mind is King moving forward to defend
that pawn on 86 and we've been talking
about about this F2 Square David inside
of the bishop Landing there the queen
can land there putting a huge double
attack you hit that night you hit that
pawn uh you win that extra pawn and in
the bargain what has happened is that
Black's King is super weak I'm loving
this approach by gokish he needs a drop
but he's not playing for one and often
that's the best way to get it yeah
a great game from kakash so far we were
talking about creating endgame studies
this is just a really mature performance
and it just looks tough for Ralph this
game we can't look at on its own it's
because of the previous game that he's
taking all these big risks but it looks
like those risks are not paying off
right now and yeah it's tough to offer
advice I'm looking for ways to kind of
defend everything but I don't think
those ways exist right now
um what would you be thinking here
Robert in terms of just trying to cling
and together kind of survive for the
next few moves I think he might have to
advance his Knight right the Knight on
F6 needs to jump forward up to H5 maybe
into G3 F4 but I do see the problems he
is going Knight H5 and this may be why
he loses the game as he's playing all
the moves that I've been talking about
uh but if he could plant his Knight in
the dark squares that does give him hope
his Pawn on H6 can be captured likely
will be captured but he's immediately
going to cement that night on the dark
Square so if black can completely
control that color complex note that
there are light Square Bishops on the
board that's good news for black who has
great control over scores like F4 and G3
a thanks to the pawn structure we
complimented Serana for his clock
handling
so so convincing here 10 minutes on the
clock and he's already made some very
difficult decisions aggressive decisions
uh it just feels like he's in the flow
he's trusting his instincts and that
really pays off maybe due to the
confidence he gained in the players a
few days ago we have a question for you
Mr David Howell on the twitch chat what
chess book would you suggest for an 1800
player okay uh interesting question
there's a lot of Chess books out there
these days
um it depends what you're looking for if
you're looking for a kind of general
advice then
I think it's a fantastic book uh it you
know shows some positions and you they
look like very normal positions from an
everyday game because they are in fact
from games and you can work through them
and they have uh analysis throughout the
chapters that can help you improve just
it's an old book but hey and for
basically any level could enjoy that
book I think so I think it is geared
towards the 1800 level player so that's
the perfect answer for this person in
the chat so I think it is geared a
little bit for a more advanced player
but it's very helpful for players of all
ratings fantastic what the book is
currently on your nightstand
uh chess book yeah I don't know is it a
chess book or is it definitely no chess
books right I'm in a book club so a new
book is always there really yeah what
are you reading now then you said you'd
uh only read about five chess books in
your life so I mentioned one out of five
don't download my spot I didn't know
whether that was a big secret as I was
asking I was like wait was I supposed to
say this but yeah is that so yeah I have
not read many chess books so that is the
one I have red
because I'm a bad student when I was
younger my coach would say read these
books and I'd be like yeah yeah you know
ah so you've been more working with
analysis computers stuff like that no I
just there are a lot of give me a lot of
puzzles so I was always working on
puzzles and studies and things like that
but never reading a book from uh front
cover to back I just wasn't really my
thing I love to read now but back then I
wasn't a big reader how interesting well
how about you Tanya favorite the chess
book do you have a chess book that
you're reading currently I do love books
I'm pretty old school like that and I
have read more than five books but yeah
I would
close but I would really recommend the
girlfriend series I think they're really
brilliant the positional decision making
especially I really like that and one of
the recent courses that I finished not a
book is accessible course and that is
the check meeting manual okay it's got
these different patterns and great for
tactics it's actually one of the courses
that I finished before the Olympiad but
it didn't help
[Laughter]
that is one that I would really
recommend and ramesh's new book a funny
story around that it's a great book by
the way it's on calculation and
improving your calculation technique it
was at the finals of the tour last year
this was
in Miami the one before the finals and I
remember that Prague I think had won his
match against Madness and then Ramesh
went and gifted this book to Magnus and
I was like that is not great timing
Ramesh but Magnus loved it and
immediately was solving exercises
tonight really it's a great book and
definitely one to check out Tanya do you
know where that book is right now
that book is right next to my bed and
it's
that exactly exact one I I opened it the
other day I was like wait why is Ramesh
signed this book to Magnus and I I
really know yeah I realized one time
Magnus uh like he was just like oh take
this book you know you'll learn
something from it I think he was trying
to mock me and I just did and uh I
haven't read it but
that exact book is by my bed it was
amazing to say because Magnus had just
won the tournament when Ramesh gifted
him that book and he didn't care about
what he had just won he immediately sat
down and started solving it
incredible why is the best okay and the
name of the book was
I I know that it's on calculation and
I'm gonna look up the exact name
calculation by Ramesh you sure you read
this book
[Laughter]
well uh well we talk about calculation
and uh actually I think that one book of
the year and many awards yes um yeah a
couple of moves on this board uh it's
just uh kokesh restoring the material
balance and Ralph trying to survive on
the dark Square it's a bishop trade
that's the queen is going to be lured
away from the King side it's called
improve your chess calculation that's
the one
yes Ramesh the coach of pragnananda
and some other young Indian yeah pretty
much all The Grandmaster from India
right now and the one thing that you'll
notice about them just how good they are
in calculation this is the book you need
to get fantastic tip for everyone out
there yeah go out and get that book all
right we have a few moves in this game
is gukesh getting closer
to the match win it feels that way I'm
not sure whether he's played the
strongest moves necessarily but he's
played very solid moves very good moves
and
um okay meanwhile Mama job is doing a
good job of Defending uh he seems to be
making moves while his hands are on his
head so I don't know if the pieces are
levitating in front of him or how he's
doing that with the mouse but uh Black's
Knight has at least found a nice solid
defensive Square holding everything
together plugging a lot of weaknesses
around the black king the white Bishop
not looking great I was going to say now
you really need to relocate your your
pieces that white knight needs to find a
better circuit there is a very weak Pawn
on the H4 square that uh go cash could
go for later but most of all he's still
taking no risks white is super solid he
hasn't burned his bridges in terms of
going for the attack yet the reason I
like mamado's position is I believe that
in certain end games if the Queens come
off the board for example that black
could be the side for choice this Pawn
on e4 is an isolated Pawn we've talked
about this a lot in other positions
where I said pawns they can be attacked
but not easily defended a Pawn's best
friend is another Pawn so we see that
moment of he's just finishing his
development he can slide his Rook over
to d8 that would be a huge question for
gokash and if he brings his Rook to D.A
right now we may see a queen sacrifice
for two Rooks two Rooks worth Five
Points each that's ten a queen worth
nine who does that favor here I actually
like the position for black at the very
least I like it for the side that needs
a win you want the imbalances yeah so
for example to follow that variation
through uh the queen could give itself
up for two Rooks technically white is
one point ahead if we do a bit of maths
but in terms of who's stronger here the
black queen or the white Rooks very much
yet to be seen if anything the queen is
the one creating the threats about to
dive in and uh go for an attack against
the white king I would be terrified here
especially in a situation where I just
need to draw to make a decision like
that one so I think Ralph should be
asking the question I'm not sure how
good cash would answer I don't think
Queen takes Rook is uh on the cards here
maybe okay he doesn't ask that question
I was gonna say maybe the queen just
moves away uh or maybe the white Bishop
blocks any attack instead Ralph just
makes a non-committal king move he's
getting ready if needs must to bring his
Rook across and defend this Pawn
Yeah the more I look at it the more I'm
starting to like it for black it's he's
done a great job of uh just yeah
surviving and uh asserting some level of
control
uh meanwhile White's Bishop is a problem
piece and he's using this to block the D
file that asks the question what's your
queen doing on D2 what's your Rook doing
on D1 the bishop gets in the way uh
starting to turn in Black's favor I
would say
I think one of the ideas of moving that
Bishop blocking the D file is also to
vacate the F1 Square for your Rook to
Lander you're always looking for open
files for your pieces especially the
major pieces the Rooks and the Queens so
Rook on F1 will give a director Target
for white you can start doubling up now
that black has committed F6 white can
look at doubling up what is Black's
resource against this is to try to block
that file by jumping that knight from G6
to F4 but then watch out for that age
for weakness yep that's a very weak pawn
and it will remain so for the near
future
um so let's see whether kokesh goes for
that plan maybe he'll start trying to
improve his Rooks they really need to uh
wow okay he finds it creative uh way of
doing that Tanya I love it that's
another square and making his intentions
very clear David he did not put that
Rook on F1 puts it on G1 looks like wait
a second I was just talking about open
files that's a file that's completely
blocked but his idea does he want to
push that jeep on open up that g file
Target the black king on G7 the Black
Knight on G6 it looks double-edged to
open up the white king as well as the
black king but it seems like that's what
he's going for unless it was a mouse
slip I don't think it was a master maybe
he meant to play Rook F1 you know he can
correct that now but uh now Ralph is
saying okay open up the G file please
because the black Works suddenly on h8
would have a direct line towards the
white king no chance in a game where you
just need a draw you're not pushing that
g Pawn I know we say play it like it's a
normal game it's too risky and something
that I'm noting is that time Advantage
for gokish it's shrinking Ralph making
great moves quickly Lucas she's
struggling for a plan and the side that
controls the pawn breaks is usually the
side with the advantage black has this
move B7 to B5 moving the pawn next to
the queen that tries to open up that
flank and create an outside pass Pawn
because if white is to take the pawn on
B5 and black takes back now all of a
sudden there are some runners in the
position and that's scary news for
Google cash who does not have a plan of
his own and uh I joked about the mouse
slip guys but it did happen he brought
his Rook that's just backtrack he
brought us to G1 I'm maybe about to
leave her open the king side but uh
after Ralph's reply of Rook to h8 saying
yes please open it up he said okay I'm
too scared I'm going back and he's lost
a move kokesh it's maybe not the most
useful move that he's given his opponent
but black has gained a tempo for free
and uh he's definitely showing some
indecisiveness and while talking of
weird mysterious Rook moves Rook to G8
for black what's this Rook doing blocked
by its own King definitely feels like
the players are showing some nerves and
they're just trying to get quick moves
down on the board and staying flexible
with their plans wow this is getting
wild and I think there are some actual
like tactics in the air white is never
going to take this Pawn on H4 so look at
Ralph he moves his Rook up so he can
slide his King away from his rook's path
the Black Knight going to LEAP into the
F4 Square this is really dangerous
territory for gukesh it's not the type
of position he wanted he played an
opening that was supposed to be very
solid comfortable now it's double-edged
it's sharp and I'm liking the position
for Ralph momentov he's a clear plan in
the position and for the young gukesh
his King is going to be the one that's
more danger yeah it feels like he needs
to pull the brake and somehow maybe get
the Queens off just find uh safety in an
end game then again Robert you mentioned
long term in terms of the Bishops in
terms of the color complexes that favors
black too
um yeah hard to offer advice it feels
like nothing's gone wrong yet but it is
certainly momentum black right now
these last few moves have been just
super impressive the way black has moved
around with the rook and then boxing is
King on h8 making sure that the Rook on
87 is ideally placed the Rook on G8 is
nicely targeting the G2 pawn and I have
to say that despite the pawn structure
it looks like it's a white skin that
might be in danger which is why the move
Queen to have to offering a queen trade
I like that idea David if black does
trade Queens White's other Rook can jump
over to the F5 can double up their
target that F6 weakness uh this could be
the way that gokish saves this yeah just
to show if the Queens come off at least
you have targets for white you have some
level of safety but uh let's go back to
the players at least in terms of body
language Ralph looked devastated about
15 moves ago suddenly he looks really
interested in the position suddenly he
looks much more optimistic about his
chances and
um yeah gakash looks like he's still
thinking now clocks are roughly level
roughly balanced it's anyone's game now
Rook F2 who feels really indecisive I've
got to say for good cash it feels like
he's just trying to hold the fort but
that's not a great way to play it's not
a comfortable way to play this type of
middle game and he shows his idea he
wants to fall back with the bishop to F1
and then defend that G2 Pawn but
absolutely agree with you that there
hasn't been that much Harmony in White's
moves the Rooks and the Queen the last
few moves that he's made have only put
them in worse spots and where are you
really headed with that D2 Rook the
after Rook you've got no squares to play
meanwhile black has managed to get all
his pieces on the very best quiz yeah
except for one the queen so if we can
bring the queen to G3 then White's King
is a world of hurt so I think the queen
is going to slide backwards to E7 then
over to G7 then try to go up to G3 you
need to bring that last piece the
biggest piece the best piece into the
attack and as David is showing you
that's where the queen belongs step one
complete he brought his Queen back to E7
this is getting more and more dangerous
for good cash and look at the clocks by
the way a rough moment of nearly three
minutes can kukash his time is getting
near three minutes as well when both
players are in time trouble you want to
be on the attack and that's what Ralph
momentum is starting to bring at
kukesh's King yeah positions like this
all you need to do is imagine you know
how am I going to deliver a Checkmate
which piece he needs to land where and
that's how Ralph very quickly came up
with this really scary plan I'm fearful
gakesh I think Armageddon is quite a
possibility here because what are you
doing with white you're just completely
tied up your Bishop your Rooks your
queen there's nowhere to go no way to
improve your position and uh three
minutes on the clock I think you need 30
here to work out a defensive plan for
white this is terrifying for white and
we were just talking about the opening
and how much Advantage it seemed that
gokish had and everything looked great
and now suddenly Ralph has the
initiative he's bringing all his pieces
every single one of them against White's
King kokesh is on the defense the only
hope I see in his position is that if
black was to slide over with the queen
to the G file maybe he can try to trade
off a pair of Rooks on the D file he
moves The Rook all the way down and the
reason he does that is he's vacating
that D2 Square for the other Rook to
jump in so that he can control and
defend that G3 check that Robert was
talking about and also potentially offer
a trade on the back rank in Black's
position once the Rooks double up yep
but he has wasted a bunch of time with
his Rooks this Rook was here what five
moves ago his other Rook has spent five
six moves getting to a very passive
square and he's gonna have to move it
again can Ralph take advantage of the
tempo here and uh find a threat I think
the most logical as you say Tanya is to
slide across with the black queen what
else could he be looking for there are
ideas of sacrifices at some point in the
near future Black's Bishop Black Knight
could capture one of the white pawns
around the king and just blow open the
position but it's about getting it in
the right order do you jump in with a
rook first do you jump in with the queen
first uh how do you land a punch with
black in akara Nakamura likes to give
the advice you need to play good moves
quickly around the perfect move slowly
and he made this move just now did
rather sliding his Rook over giving up
the H4 Pawn I love it open up files
against the white king here have a pawn
what happens when you lose pawns you
gain an open file so I think Ralph spent
a little bit too much time it's a bit of
a speck out of sacrifice but if he had
played that move in say 15 rather than
50 seconds he would continue to push in
trouble on the clock and now this is a
tough position as David said you need 30
minutes to figure it out rather than
three but go Kesh he picks up that pawn
he's showing no fear Ralph slides back
this is anyone's game at this point is
anyone's game boy's gone up a porn but
black has gone all in on the attack
against the white king there's bound to
be further sacrifices it's bound to be a
kind of long-term attack can't go cash
survive that's the big question either
you Retreat your knight right now or you
move your Rook out the way I guess to
defend it for example the night Retreat
though will allow the black queen to
slide over and look at this look at the
battery that black is lined up against
the white king this is just fearful uh I
mean I'm terrified if I'm defending this
one kukesh finds a different defense he
steps his Rook up defending the Knight
with his Queen but uh still Clinging On
to dear life Black's Queen has uh poised
herself ready
to give a check the bar is going
slightly up for gukesh yeah this last
move maybe Ralph missed it I've got to
say uh I paused for thought because
actually visually it looks like uh
something should be wrong for white but
it is all defending uh each other all
those pieces
actually perfectly placed to defend
that's a stunning resource that gokish
has found in just seconds he plays the
move Rook G3 visually does look like
something should be hanging but actually
the tactics all work out for white and
if you manage to trade off the Rooks the
attack is gone you're up upon and I
think you're absolutely right that this
was a resource that Ralph missed and we
see him slowing down after a little bit
you know he's played all these amazing
moves jumping with the Rook sacrificing
the pawn but now that attack comes to an
abrupt halt How do you even respond you
can't pick up the Knight on H4 the queen
is hanging you can trade pieces on G3
but after all the trades that will
happen on G3 it will be the king who
will be the star of White's position
defending that Knight on H4 we have a
result you guys and the first player is
knocked out of the air things monsters
division one alirez of Russia he loses
also game two to Alexa sarana that means
young for Russia he is out
Serana goes through to the losers
quarterfinals is this a big upset Robert
I don't think so of course alireza fuja
is the favorite in that matchup but in a
two-game match uh the side that is lower
rated has better chances and Serrano
played a great game one he played very
nicely in game two I saw that off to the
side of the screen so he deserved it he
moves on he fights another day and
kukesh he's looking to do the same in
this one and it's getting worse and
worse for Ralph mehmedov I mean the way
that gukash has handled the pressure has
been uh just really mature yep the last
three full moves have been disastrous
for black uh just trading off a set of
Rooks losing that pawn and now old
percussion needs is one or two accurate
moves to fully rebuff the attack and he
should be able to convert this and he
has an extra minute he has draw odds
those bonuses in his court as well
um yeah I'm starting to not see actually
any way forward for black I think white
can just push the pawn to G3 hold
everything there we go from good Cash
cover all the squares kick away the
Black Knight defend your own Knight and
uh there we go once the retreat begins
it might not stop and
for cash doing all the right things in
terms of defending this one and now once
White's pieces start moving forward
there's not going to be any stopping off
that G3 really nice move pushing that
Knight back and now the Bishop from the
first round can actually go to E2 also
hitting that Knight but another nice
move by location different approach he
moves the queen to the open file so
eyeing that F6 Pawn there Rook G7 big
threat on G3 so gokish still needs to
find an accurate way to defend it and
the clock under one minute now could
play a factor this was very much a
bullet game only a three second
increment these guys will never have
more than a minute I feel for the rest
of the game can't go cash conquer his
nerds he's not known as a online
specialist yet as a blitz specialist
whereas Ralph is very experienced in the
Blitz and bullet time formats so could
that maybe be a glimmer of hope for him
and go cash down to 35 seconds for
himself he plays his move G4 great move
but Ralph he has that experience he was
back in the ICC when it just started he
knows how to play in these formats and
you see his night hop into a great
square and white trying to do the same
but it can be eliminated and that gives
black an attack I actually love that his
Knight is planted on F4 it cannot be
kicked out by any of White's pieces yeah
whereas the White Knight can be
eliminated at any moment and suddenly
threats uh they're back on the board
Black's Queen could try and grab a pawn
at some point okay nice defensive move
kokesh holding everything together yet
again yes he's Advanced his pawns but
from a human point of view as long as
you cover them as long as you defend
them black is running out of uh
ammunition 20 seconds for a Ralph 25
seconds for good cash
what is gonna happen all bets are off
although objectively it does feel like
white should have some control
Queen effort he tries to get the queen
into the game from the other side you
can think about a position where the
queen lands on C5 or on 86 really
putting the attack but that Rook on the
open file D file gives gokish the
defensive resource I like to smooth
Queen E3 taking away a lot of squares
from Black's Queen yeah but uh then
again Ralph is also finding some good
squares first pieces the Black Knight
now sitting pretty in the center and
there is a past Pawn in the position
Black's E Pawn protector Plus Pawn will
start motoring down the board I'm
expecting now uh you might not get
another opportunity five seconds for
Ralph you have to move okay Black's Pawn
advancing white trying to kick away the
Black Knight it's just blow for blow
black trying to get his ideas on the
board and go cash every time trying to
shut the door and if you have to retreat
for black it's not going to be a good
sign and two seconds
he's getting the moves off if they're
coming in fast Rook goes you want to
stop that pass pawn and well look at
Ralph metal if he brings his Knight in
because the bishop captures all of a
sudden black has a very far Advanced
pass Pawn you see the eval bar dip as
well this is anyone's game unless kukesh
has a draw by repetition that's what he
needs to find he only needs a half point
to win the match yeah I don't think he
should be aiming to win this one anymore
Black's Pawn is too strong okay the
Rooks are off you need to give Eternal
checks otherwise the Blackboard is going
to become a new Queen suddenly the
stakes are extremely high for good cash
this is not an easy position to develop
to defend with only a few seconds left
wow that black pawn can start running
any moment maybe even now does white
have enough checks with the queen Ralph
is banking no on being the answer
wow you have to hope now you just have
to cross your fingers and pray uh for
good care she's giving some checks but
the black king is running towards the
queen side the checks are drying up oh
my gosh he's trying to run behind its
paws use him a shelter but maybe there's
only one or two paths towards the draw I
wouldn't be surprised if at any moment
only one white move makes the draw but
he doesn't have a check along the E file
the black queen takes control of it I
don't see it I don't see it either
fourth check and then King goes to A6
and there are no checks on the board
yeah oh my gosh oh there's a number of
checks there's no checks he's making a
new Queen there is a threat oh my God
yeah this one looks like it's winning
now for Ralph mamadov now just give a
check don't allow Checkmate White had
the sneaky threat of bring the queen to
the corner to A8 to mate but now all
tracks have dried up and uh this one is
Game Over Look at that celebration from
Ralph mamadol she wins it he wins it
right at him incredible play there so
resourceful it's the bullet experience
it's that speed chess experience that
Ralph has over the years
oh his young rival couldn't keep up wow
you can't replicate experience and that
one was going both players I mean just
making moves and they barely had time
and Ralph momentov he earned that
Victory from the start he played
exciting chess he went for he didn't
mind losing the game but he made sure
that he had chances from the start and
he won
we're gonna see Armageddon you guys
fantastic and that was uh some
explosions in the end there what
happened here David I'm trying to work
out what happened it's so complicated uh
we talked about this queen end game
where the game was eventually decided
already at this point the checks look
like they had dried up and it looked
like gokesh was crashing to defeat he
didn't find a way to stay in the game it
looks like he should have given a check
from the center but even here he has to
find some miraculous resources to
survive it looks like the checks are uh
disappeared now but you could throw your
Pawn forward trying to create a
checkmating net and after Pawn takes
porn you threw another Pawn forward
trying to deliver Checkmate but for a
human this is too difficult to find I
think most of us here we wouldn't find
it especially with a few seconds left on
our clock and just to show how the game
ended after a check the black king did
hide another threat now of Checkmate and
the killer blow was just a quiet move
the king steps back to defend and note
how after this queen move black can make
a new Queen very safely because this
Pawn is actually defended the White
Queen can only give one check but no
more two queens are better than one and
Ralph took the Victory and that means in
about nine minutes we will see
Armageddon tie breaks to decide the
match between gukesh and Mama Dove but
the other match on the losers bracket is
decided and Alexa is Serrano goes
through to the losers quarter finals
congratulations all I say
oh hello thank you
a crushing match against the Fantastic
Olive Russia how happy are you with your
performance today
yeah today I played the amazing chess uh
yesterday I lost much without any
chances and I wasn't quite happy with
spellings that they play against
uh I didn't think that I have a lot of
chances but
I was really happy that at least I
played George the game with white it's
gives me more opportunities like
and I was very lucky with opening I also
prepared it against Magnus and
in this game it happens and it worked
quite well I just got
a lot of advantage and a lot of time
and win game very confidently first just
because of opening
fantastic so you were actually able to
use some of the preparation you had for
Magnus yesterday to beat alireza today
yeah yeah a bit
the problems I didn't expect that the
Magnus will play it I just prepared it
maybe for the next game maybe it was
this matching and hopefully it works in
this match suddenly yeah and what does
it mean to you to now well first of all
you made it through to division one and
now you're through also to day three
here in the air things Masters what does
it mean to you
yes
it means a lot and it is really a cool
result that I
continue to show very good chess in
in Rapid online I'm very happy with it
and very satisfied
and and before of course even just to
qualify to division one is incredible
good result
so and now I managed to detail yeah just
amazing to talk fantastic Alexa
congratulations on a great match I just
have one question for you who would you
rather face in your next match Wesley so
or Hikaru Nakamura
so I will play with someone of them yes
oh I shot my mother for gookish no no so
you will uh play uh the loser from uh
the Winner's semi-final between Hikaru
Nakamura and Wesley so
it will be tough much
everybody
talker but you must be feeling quite
confident after your performance today
probably yeah I hope well like saying we
have to say big congratulations on a
huge performance today and best of luck
tomorrow as well
thank you thank you for joining us
all right that is a very happy Alexa
Serana making it through to the losers
quarterfinals to face either Wesley so
or Hikaru Nakamura who will meet each
other and the winner is semi-finals
later today but we're gonna see some
Armageddon chess for the first time in
the 2023 season go cash and marmadov
they have to decide their match in
Armageddon
how exciting is that uh Tanya super
pumped to see that one I think we all
love the Armageddon and this time with
the new bidding format it's going to be
that much more exciting but I have to
add that Alexi looked so happy and so
excited about his win until you
mentioned that he'd either be playing
wrestling record that's when you just
took all of that away yeah you know I've
commented so many Alexis matches on
chess.com throughout the years so many
successes you just have to be honest
with the guy your next opponent your
tournament's not over your next opponent
will be one of those two so good luck to
him it was great to see him happy and he
played a fantastic matches he said so
himself yeah what a day for Alexa Serana
and the chess continues you guys
Armageddon is coming up very shortly
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki andras
Toth everyone's favorite social media
troll known as anishikiri and so many
more chessable can help you raise your
game to the next level you're getting
started on the fundamentals you should
check out everyone's first chess
workbook maybe you want to stop letting
all those points slip away in the end
game 100 end games you must know is the
course for you
did you not notice your king was in
check and still can't figure out why the
pieces won't move
actually uh chessable can't help you
with that maybe try refreshing your tab
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
we're going to send you to a twitch
break now if you are a subscriber well
we're gonna dig into all the action
happening today
foreign
[Music]
I can't imagine how the players are
feeling actually right now I mean it's
also a kind of different mindset that
each has
um mamadov of course he will be riding
high he just come off a victory you know
in a clutch win with the black pieces
you know here's that proverbial man in
the dark and he's found treasure and
then we have good cash of course who is
just thinking he had it in the bag he
just threw it all away but I have to say
kukash he did say that he's been
training for these kind of moments
really yeah you know during the pandemic
while other players were kind of
improving their chest he especially
focused on playing under pressure and
actually adopting the right mindset to
him you know he says okay there's nerves
there's going to be disappointment let
me just Embrace that and let me get on
with the job in hand so it's going to be
very very interesting and that must be
so important now only having 10 minutes
to get over the stating loss get ready
for Something Completely new with
Armageddon where there's also no
increment yeah and he actually did say
you know what he would be doing what he
will be doing during that break he will
be meditating
he uses that just to calm the nerves and
just to get ready and focused for what
has to be done next and it's going to be
very interesting because we don't know
if he will be playing with black visas
who will be playing with a white piece
is the time control oh yeah
I'm like literally working myself up
into a state of excitement I mean I
really can't wait yep
the action continues uh everyone these
are the results from losers round one
Alex say Serana is true to the losers 40
quart finals knocking out alireza for
Russia and you catch they will play
Armageddon tie breaks to the side who
has knocked out and who goes through
and one thing is for sure they're gonna
need great air quality to play in
Armageddon and someone who has an air
things device at home is Grandmaster
David Howell
[Applause]
[Music]
yo what's up this is your boy Big D
welcome to CCT Crips come on in
the hallway I call it the tunnel of love
this is where a true professional chess
player gets ready for the day this is
where I take my two hour baths every day
this is where I make myself look
oh Jesus Christ come into the bedroom
this is where whoa sorry about this this
is where the magic happens
it's where I get my eight hours every
night so this is going to be the office
this is where the streaming setup is
going to be it's going to be a desk the
whole way across the wall the living
room this is where I get my zen time and
my chill time you got the sofa you got
the fireplace in the corner and this is
where I spend most of my time I make my
trademark noodles my girlfriend insisted
this is here I hate it but she said we
couldn't get rid of it she's gonna kill
me these are my most prized possessions
my dad's robots and here you got mugs
shout out to princess dye but my
favorite of course this one
now we're done with the house tour it's
time to check out the latest addition to
the apartment air things have sent me
their latest model the B plus and it's
time to check out how the air quality is
here
[Music]
now it's time to configure this bad boy
connected what I love about the air
things device is that I always know the
air quality I do work a lot from home as
a chess player so I need to ensure that
the office the living conditions are
perfect and I think's helped me to do
that
what a cool apartment David thank you
I'm crunching inside now everyone's seen
me uh you know you know my glory but I
hope they enjoyed it and I recommend the
Athens device yeah and what a nice
Olympian uh gold medal you have there
all right you guys we have to get ready
for Armageddon for the first time the
season Robert what are the regulations
in Armageddon okay well the base time is
15 minutes so the side that bids the
lower amount of time gets to choose
their color most often they'll choose
the black pieces and if the game ends in
a draw the player with the black pieces
moves on so 15 minutes for the side with
the white pieces and then for the side
that gets black well depends on what
they bid yeah and the player with the
white pieces has to win the game and I'm
curious do we have the bids in from
gukesh and mama don't we do ghukesh has
been 15 minutes Ralph mamadov has been
11 minutes with the lowest bid he could
choose colors he has a of course chosen
to play with the black pieces he will
have 11 minutes against gukesh with the
white pieces with 15 minutes no
increments in the Armageddon gukesh has
to win this game all right Tana what do
you think about the bidding here I think
gokish wanted the white pieces and he's
happy with it the game that he just lost
to Ralph the position was great and he
just did not have enough time that will
play a very crucial role so he did not
want to compromise too much on the clock
it's very important for gokish to just
forget what has happened the momentum of
the match has shifted slightly Mukesh
took the lead in the first game went on
to lose the second one super important
to forget that just get it out of your
mind there's no increment here and uh
big momentail yep and we have updated so
he didn't bid 15 minutes I actually
don't think you're going to be allowed
to been 15 minutes he beat 11 minutes
and 45 seconds so that's actually quite
close very close and we see Ralph went
for 11 minutes it's a good case actually
just won by 45 seconds I call that a
loss it depends on you know your Vantage
Point I think Ralph really wanted the
black pieces so it's sort of a small
victory for him and I think that makes
sense because kukesh is not as
experienced in these online Blitz and
Rapid time patrols so Ralph he doesn't
mind having the deficit on the clock
yeah so to be clear Ralph Mama though
bidding 11 minutes sort of one the bed
could choose colors chose now to play
with the black pieces and we'll have
these 11 minutes do cash we'll have 15
minutes with the white pieces and he has
to win the game
so bidding 11 minutes and 45 seconds go
cash do you think he also kind of wanted
the black pieces here it shows that
probably he was would
having whites he
when it's 45 is still quite high and uh
yeah it's interesting the dynamic now
because remember it's 1-1 but both one
with the black pieces so he has to turn
it around he's the one with the weights
on his shoulders now in terms of getting
a playable position and it's very very
different from his previous white game
in that one we saw Philadelphia fence
White had the space Advantage White had
the attack very active pieces early on
but now we see kokesh switch away it's
one D4 this time and a slower slav uh
this variation of the slav uh when I was
commentating on Vikings day with Peter
smithler we were joking this came up
every round in the Masters or challenges
it's so topical so popular right now
black is Rock Solid but uh White often
gets the bishop pair and that makes a
lot of sense when all you need is a draw
to go through and moment of choosing an
extremely solid approach of the slav
here I think for gokish it's going to be
very important to just try and keep as
many pieces as possible and try and get
Ralph in a Time scramble get his clock
as low as you can before you create
Dynamic possibilities in the position
yeah no increments so you can hustle on
the clock for sure and there's no safety
there once Ralph ticks down below a few
minutes and uh a queen trade what do we
think it looks inevitable now but who's
this gonna favor and paper it should be
black I think that Ralph is showing his
experience in these formats in the
global Championship he lost a Neil Saron
in an arm again where Ralph actually had
the white pieces so he knows from his
past what he must do he's offering a
queen trade and as David just said this
should favor Black the position becomes
easier to play the time deficit doesn't
seem to be that instrumental in White's
Advantage here because black has so much
time remaining and the pieces are coming
off the board I like what Ralph has done
but still so much life left in this game
yep a lot of life left but the reason
here we are maybe favoring Ralph's
chances slightly is because the pawn
structure is completely symmetrical and
uh it's very locked up in the center
white even if he establishes that kind
of symbolic advantage of the bishop hair
that we see the first imbalance of the
game black as double pawns white has the
bishop pair
um it's still very hard to find anything
concrete to do with those Bishops
especially White's Dart squared Bishop
not an impressive piece right now very
much locked in and uh black despite the
double pawns does have a semi-open h
file yeah it's hard to pinpoint any
weaknesses in the black Camp it's going
to be a long grind if kakash wants to
win this game I like this approach by
white of putting the king in the center
It's The End Game the Queens are off the
board you want to make sure that your
king is an active Beast connecting those
Rooks but watch out for that H2 Pawn you
don't have the time to move that King
side Rook The Rook on the right side all
the way across the H2 Pawn hangs and
right now Ralph with another big threat
he moves the Knight forward to C4
attacking that B2 Pawn but does this
allow white the opportunity to grab the
Knight yeah he's allowing a small
imbalance and uh as white we've
mentioned it before if you want to win
if you're in a must win situation you
have to add up the imbalances and hope
that they total up in your favor later
and uh rather than allow this Knight to
live he did eliminate it so it has come
at the cost of his Bishop pair but after
this last move especially he's banking
on the fact that this Pawn is going to
be caught in no man's land caught in
White's half of the board and maybe a
Target long term not just that David
look at the center now it's all white
hair white can't start advancing that
e-pawn at the right moment the C4 Pawn
is a weakness I like that last move A4
by gokish really taking control and
space off the queen side making sure
that the black pawns can't Advance easy
the Knight can potentially jump to B5
threatening of fork I think Rakesh can
be pleased with the outcome of the
opening yeah this last move I've got to
say jumping in with the Black Knight to
C4 allowing this exchange it shocked me
I know he has to make quick decisions
Ralph because it's Armageddon but did he
need to rush with that it looked like he
had the perfect structure when only
needing a draw yeah it was not a big fan
of the move Knight to C4 I think it just
gives everything he could possibly dream
of and imbalance a pawn to Target and
now all of a sudden it's Ralph who needs
to come up with defensive ideas he plays
this move F5 wow he wants to control the
light squares his Knight can hop in
behind rather than in front of the pawn
and continue to control the squares but
that pawn on C4 it's a long-term
weakness and look at gukesh's move here
A5 he wants to slide his Rook up his H1
Rook eventually can come over the C file
to put more pressure sure on this Pawn
C4 I did not like the sequence events
that led to this Pawn being overextended
and I think Ralph is in some trouble
here yeah just one rash decision and it
looks like he's suffering the
consequences he's had to take a time out
to block the further advance of this uh
Intruder this white ape one but now it
feels like the time to go for that plan
that Robert mentioned go for this Pawn
uh it's definitely a weakness and once
you've freed up your Rook once you've
for example moved this Pawn to a safer
Square out of the eye line of the black
Rook then this guy as well is freed up
to start attacking and yeah it looks
like gokash he's got what he wanted very
stable position with a couple of small
imbalances and enough wiggle room to try
and work things in his favor there we go
H4 putting that pawn on the safe Square
freeing up that white rook in the corner
Advantage white we've got to say on the
board and clock right now
I like that Google has kept a
four-minute advantage on the clock very
important in the Armageddon and the
whole idea is to try to get your
opponent really down on the time with no
increment H4 a nice move as you were
mentioning the C4 Pawn is the long-term
weakness and yes Ralph only needs a job
but I don't see a direct path to it
especially with the Queens off the board
I'm really liking the way kokesh is
handling this end game yeah if you could
take all the Rooks off the board then I
would say yeah drawers the most likely
result but now there's no fully open
files to achieve that for black
um yeah the more I think about it the
more I really just like that decision he
made earlier off but he stuck with it
now he's committed to it and wow nice
move by go cash yeah mistakes often come
in pairs and first it was the pawn on C4
and then also after A6 by black it's the
pawn on B7 so go cash he is not being
subtle he is not hiding his intentions
he slides his Rook over to the queen
side so he can push the pawn in front of
it open that Rooks file at the end of
the line This is Pawn on B7 there's
going to remain an eyesore black is
going to use his heavy pieces to defend
it whereas white can slide a second Rook
behind the first one and continue to
pile up pressure it's going to be a
defensive task for Rapha Madoff he is
down under eight minutes no increment
I'm liking this more and more for good
cash yep one target is enough to tie
down Black's pieces and then go cash
will initiate step two of the plan he'll
be looking for other targets maybe ways
to step forward on the other side of the
board where he has this nice v formation
with the white pawns but he also has a
poor majority five versus four on the
rest of the board so it's still looking
good for white but he'll be looking for
the most accurate way to try and press
this Edge that he's got and Ralph has
also moved his Rook into the defense I
think what he wants is that once you try
to open up the B file this B7 glaring
weakness that you're talking about after
a move like B3 black will have the
option to also push his own beep on
because notice that Knight on D7 after
an on-person you can pick it up with the
Knight you can defend the C4 uh Pawn as
well I do not believe that black will
allow the B7 weakness to remain B5 will
be coming up David at some point that's
very clever Tanya just before it's too
late before this Pawn becomes fully
backward and becomes an eternal weakness
tied down on B7 to step forward I must
admit sometimes I do forget about these
uh types of moves when it does allow one
person we're just taught don't allow one
person and uh here however it does
activate the Black Knight and uh if
there is a trade of Pawns yes white has
opened up a line from the whoops sorry
my arrows uh White has uh
I'm getting better with the mouse but
these Rooks don't really do too much
right now it's more important that the
Black Knight has found an active Square
um so nice defensive resource and that
is cut out uh by white I was going to
say and black prepares it by playing
Rook B8 uh getting ready again to
initiate all of those exchanges by uh
trying to bypass that white Pawn on A5
Ralph really creative there he's made up
some time on the clock he's only down
less than three minutes now but uh an
uphill struggle still ahead and I love
this move B4 that just was played by
gookash because if you don't take
ampersant ctxp3 now you can never do it
and White's next move is to plant his
Knight into C5 it's very well defended
by those pawns on B4 and D4 and if you
can capture and open up the B file on
the C5 Square oh that's really bad news
both for the B7 pawn and the C4 Pawn
that's the first one that we said we
were not a fan of so this is a big
moment for Ralph he has to take on Busan
and he I believe at least and he's
making this move quite slowly so that's
good news for good cash who can continue
to use his advantage on the clock yeah
really clever most of us would be
inclined to just push pulling forward
one square but he spotted that actually
he wants to force black to take this
Pawn anyway and uh why not force his
hand by pushing two squares forward
again not on my radar because I was so
inclined to avoid him pass on but a very
sneaky plan by gokesh and yeah as uh as
we mentioned one person here does favor
white backward Pawn clear Target on B7 I
think the big question is can black
still go B5 and stop your Pawn from
advancing one square further where you
will break it and uh Ralph answers yes
he can he goes for it now the idea of
jumping with the Knight would just
result in trades make it more difficult
to get that win for gokish so he wants
to keep as many minor pieces as possible
trades on B6 does the on person
does the uh it does go for that and now
I think the question is whether white
can go for the idea Robert mentioned
still Yes it won't necessarily result in
backward points but there are targets
immediately how does black hold
everything together white does land the
night there the Knight can be eliminated
of course and it looks like black has a
very good night against the white bad
Bishop but it's more about uh the number
of Pawns and here it looks like white
can very happily just uh start grabbing
I'm not sure which one I should go for I
can go for this one perhaps or I can
trade Rooks and then go for this one but
uh this looks like the acid test and
okay we get no answer to that one yet
but we could well see the solution soon
first the Knight did land on D5 and
white is indeed going for this Intruder
in his Camp it's not just the A6 Pawn or
the C4 Pawn there's also Knight hopping
up to D7 hitting the Rook on B8 and
going to E5 going to the center giving
the king a check the G6 Pawn is actually
an easy target I feel like black is just
going to lose at least one Pawn here it
might even be worse so Ralph he steals
the First Pawn but taking on B4 and
Gucci quickly responds with Rook takes
C4 I feel like the problems will persist
here for Ralph momentov and the clock
it's at five plus minutes it's going to
dwindle as the solution so this position
become harder and harder to find yeah so
many weaknesses in the black Camp level
material right now but it might not stay
that way for too much longer can Ralph
Klingon and survive gokesh since he's
been given that opportunity been very
impressive I've got to say I don't see a
wave for black actually holding on to
that pawn for another move your knight
on B4 is attacked right now why the by
the bishop and The Rook it's the one
defending the A6 spawn you can't push
that pawn ahead you can't go A5 because
it just hangs The Rook can pick it up
it's just going to be an end game that
you're going to try and hold upon down
yeah
yeah I think it's inevitable
Nelson Leo would be inclined to get rid
of that white knight it looks too strong
just traded off for Black start Square
bishop and okay he hasn't gone for that
yet but he does have the opportunity now
if you have the Black Knight which is
very strong at least you can fight well
against the white Bishop in some
circumstances yes you're reporting down
forever but you just got to do it I
think here it's a choice between a bunch
of different evils so you have to uh you
have to try and wow the black Rooks jump
in jumps in sorry
that looks surprising to me it feels
like something is loose look at the bar
yeah something feels loose I don't see
what to be honest right now it looks
like Black's hunting for counter chances
but
um does white have a way to take
advantage I think it's just a fake pin
because the 195 looks like it can't move
because the Rook on C4 is loose but if
the Knight drops back and we see the
stockist suggests Knight D3 or D7 same
exact plan the only moves that led to a
huge Advantage glucose of course finds
it the point is that if the Rook takes
Rook on C4 the Knight can hop forward to
E5 with check for King The King and this
Rook on C4 you're going to win that Rook
on C4 then E6 and G6 are just sitting
ducks they're going to be targeted and
likely won by the white pieces yeah
suddenly big trouble for black this Rook
is attacked and no matter no matter
where you place it I think there will be
consequences for example if you step
back one square actually the black king
is caught in a mating net I'm trying to
find ways to hunt it down the White
Knight can step back into the center
there will be ideas of for example
stepping your Pawn forward bringing your
Bishop in going for check mate this
black king is actually really stuck
right now and not many ways I see to get
it out break it out find some Escape
squares uh suddenly big trouble maybe
there are more convincing moves in this
position than planting the Knight back
but uh either way you're a pawn up and
you have full control for good cash
extra four minutes to boot so looking
good for weight all right and he has to
win this game and if he does he will
make it through marmadov with a draw or
a win
will win this match but it's not looking
good for him right now and he is
definitely down on the clock as well
well I like that gaucasia slowed down
finally because this is such a critical
moment he knows that he's done
everything right so far he just needs to
find that winning plan that good
technique and he's got the match in his
hands we were singing praises of Ralph's
play in the last game that he won to
equalize the match and I think this one
has been equally Flawless by gokish so
far
yeah and I wonder how many strong moves
does he have maybe we can our stockfish
again uh how big is the margin for error
right now to me it looks like he can
play a bunch of different moves and now
we see at least three strong moves uh
killer moves giving plus five advantage
that is decisive he does plan his night
back on that very strong Central Square
trapping the black king black at least
tries to tie down the white Bishop by
creating that pin again but stockfish
says move the king out the way again you
can give a check with the Knight that
doesn't change anything but you can move
the white king out of the second Rank
and
now I think the threats will just build
up they'll be insurmountable soon and
the idea that you were talking about
once you're out of that bin the spawn
advances to E4 you open up the bishop
and do not forget the bishop on G5
Landing would be Checkmate it would be
game over now the reason we want to fall
back with the King and not forward is to
avoid the Knight jumping into B4 and any
such trades uh moves like Bishop B Forum
night before come to mind but we do have
a few moves now the players did repeat
yeah they just repeated once they're not
getting gaining any time because there's
no increment but uh that's often what
they say just show your opponent who's
in control of course go cash won't
repeat for a third time he does instead
put his Rook on the seventh rank very
nice as well and uh this does hint at a
checkmating pattern if uh for example
the bishop moves then The Rook will join
in the fun and trap the black king
itself so very nice there from gokish
but a psychological battle just showing
I'll repeat twice I'm the boss I'm in
control I don't want to draw and play on
still in trouble for black and it forced
to Ralph to think a little bit and if
both sides are going to waste 30 seconds
go cash is the happier one and you see
that Ralph's clock is now ticking
towards three minutes 30 seconds he
hardly has a move as David was just
showing the Knight hopping into E5 for
white there might be a Checkmate in
short order against that black king
black has no threats White's up a pawn
has a very healthy Pawn structure no
targets to speak of this is a completely
lost position for moment of on the clock
on the board an excellently played game
by gukesh when he slid his Rooks over
the queen Side open the position up on
his terms and wow we might just see uh
this move 95 it's not very pleasant for
black there really are no good choices
yeah I accidentally predicted the future
there you can also maybe just Advance
white Central Pawn forward open up that
white Bishop it looks like some deadly
checks there as well it looks like
everything wins well it's only one Pawn
up but the evaluation Bar says it's uh
plus infinity at this point it's just
completely winning for white there we go
for your idea David on the board
G5 a big threat yeah uh E5 Checkmate a
big threat you're attacking the Black
Knight I think Ralph here might just
resign he's guaranteed to lose a minimum
a piece uh I think you just have to take
this Pawn allow the white Bishop to jump
in with a check maybe no checkmates
immediately but uh yeah the black Bishop
on d8 will drop off will we see him
fight on or will we see him admit defeat
and leave the tournament shaking his
head Ralph marmadov losing all hope I
guess yeah he knows this one uh is just
over in gukash's favor but he's played
some marvelous chess to win on Demand
with the black pieces in that previous
game how he played against Wesley so
that was neck and neck Wesley did not
seem like the heavy favorite as his
rating would imply so Rafal Meadow this
is he's the type of player this
tournament is four it's a democratic
meritocratic process he showed that
throughout the uh Swiss and the plan he
was just as good as the best players in
the world he's demonstrated that
yesterday and today and he is going to
lose this game but it's been a great
fight and guys I love what cookies has
done instead of going to pick up that
material going to pick up that Bishop he
could have won it in one move with the
check okay is going for bloody or he's
going for checkmate you were talking
about resignation I think it's going to
happen now Knight E5 it doesn't only
Rook F7 made but also Bishop G5 will be
super powerful as well once the G4 Pawn
comes in when you step up with the King
that will be game over as well so that's
two threats you can't fight two
checkmates in a position yeah you can't
fight two checkmates if you stop this
Rook Checkmate move the bishop then to
show Tanya's idea uh you end up with a
pawn Checkmate really nice pretty
pattern here the black king trapped
Queen it's like a sandwich here between
the White Knight and the white Bishop
this one's going to be game over I think
Ralph he might just let his clock run
down but he's not going to find
Salvation anywhere it's game over
Checkmate is coming
what an amazing Armageddon here by
gokish we were talking about his lack of
experience he's been very vocal about
his Focus being on classical play the
reason why he also missed the world
rapid and Blitz he wanted to prepare for
the Tata steel Masters but here he is
just showing world-class performance
starting from the planes up until this
Armageddon an all-rounder would be
coming in
yeah all the youngsters they're just
slowly but surely improving uh every
facet of their game every time control
in the past he used to see these young
players they were very much specialists
in either classical or Blitz chess but
now everyone's good at everything it's
unfair yeah and he's gonna face uh when
he wins this match because it's looking
very good for your cash he's gonna Face
Tomorrow the winner of uh sorry the
loser of the match between Magnus
Carlsen and Arjun eragisi they play the
winner is semi-finals starting 10
minutes after this game finishes so we
have a lot of Chess still to go today
you guys because in the winners bracket
it is best of four rapid games and that
as well can be decided in Armageddon if
players are tied so uh the the well
today is still young the day is young
but the day has ended for Ralph momentov
he has resigned there we go the
tournament is over for Mama
he is knocked out of the air things
Masters 16 year old gukesh makes it
through to the losers quarterfinals and
there was a little bit of a blunder I
guess in this game David what happened
yeah and uh I wouldn't necessarily say
blunder Kaya but just a strategic
mistake which cost him long term and he
will be regretting just one move Ralph
moment off and uh it was actually a
successful opening for black black has
got the Queen's off black has a solid
structure symmetrical structure White's
Bishop pair are not that effective right
now but uh this move allowing the change
of structure was uh one that Ralph
mamidov will regret suddenly white was
able to break the black pawn chain and
this move really uh rubbing it in
pushing the pawn forward Saint to Black
this Pawn will never get connected to
the other black pawns and by stepping
forward once again he's opened up his
Brook and just to show one or two more
moves this one was really really classy
from gokesh bringing the white Rook over
to B1 opening up the B file for this
rook and long term he won a pawn never
lost control and used his pieces on
really nice outposts to clinch the
victory
and there we have it gukesh makes it uh
through and being from India Tanya you
must be happy about that it's a big
moment and he never got his chance
yesterday I think Hikaru just asserted
his domination in that match when you're
playing against a player like Hikaru you
can't take it too much to heart you know
you're playing against one of the
biggest the best online players uh well
just one of the best chess players
really in the world but I think ukesh
really showed today that he kept that
behind him he took an early lead in this
match went on to win an Armageddon which
is very hard to do when the momentum has
shifted so definitely all credits to him
and he's got 1.3 billion people rooting
for him right now yeah that is a nice
fan base for young cash and for the
first time seeing Armageddon with the
bidding process and everything what did
you think of it Robert I always enjoy it
because we see how the clock has used
the weapon from the start of the game
Ralph had to make some quick choices I
believe that if he had even time it was
just any other game he would not have
brought his Knight forward as David
showing that was a critical strategic
mistake so you use the clock against
your opponent and did just that he did
it effectively he deserved to move on
yeah and it must be be hard David to win
on the man you have to win with the
white pieces yeah such fine margins
sometimes you get out of the opening you
realize wait there are no winning
chances at all yes I might have four or
five minutes extra on the clock but
um yeah that you can't take that clock
you can't take that time forward with
you so it's all about the position all
about those little nuances in the gokish
there very impressively navigated
Fountain winning chances put the
pressure on and yeah as Robert says
deservedly in the semi-finals yeah and
we're joined bike congratulations on
winning the match
hi thank
you thank you can I ask you guys first
of all what was your thinking behind the
bidding process bidding 11 minutes and
45 seconds uh against my Med of India
Armageddon
um actually I I wanted white but I also
wanted him to
get get below 12 minutes so I thought 12
minutes was a decent bid at first but it
turned out he also bit 12 minutes so I
had to go a bit less
so I chose level 45. okay so you were
happy that you ended up playing with the
white pieces then
yes fantastic and how happy are you with
the way you performed today and the
first game was fantastic
yes really happy with the first game it
was very clean game with the black faces
and uh
uh yeah he he didn't really play that
well but uh anyway anyways I think it
was a good game from myself and second
game yeah I
it's always hard to play play this must
win I mean must uh draw games with white
because sure trying to play uh be
careful but it should be
um
like uh more optimistic uh I I tried to
play some normal chess but at some point
I just uh
I just panicked in the tank trouble and
yeah I think I had a Perpetual in the
end instead of Queen and six I could
have gone uh queen bed but okay
it was he he kept on
posing problems so he deserved
and um
I think again a very good games
absolutely
congratulations on that when you took
the early lead in the match but then
Ralph came back in game two and I want
to ask you what did you do between game
two and the Armageddon to switch it up
um
nothing actually I just uh
I just checked the game check the second
game and I was a bit upset but then I
uh
yeah I didn't really do anything
but then you still decided to change up
the openings you didn't go for the ideas
that you had in the second game even
though you had a pleasant position so
the inspiration to play something
different how did that come to your mind
um
actually I
have for in both games and uh
uh in the second game I wanted to do
something solidly
I was expecting your bookings Indian
so after United States Jesus has
planning 9335 Bishop F4 and this is a
very solid line but uh yeah and the
Armageddon I thought
I had to
play some normal stuff or not not be too
solids
yes lab was quite a surprising
I I didn't really remember this bishop
g69 also I just did something over the
board and
I got a playable position
all right and now cash tomorrow you're
gonna play the loser of the match
between Magnus Carlsen and your fellow
Indian Arjun Eric icy will you now be
following that match to see you're gonna
face
uh probably yeah elevation
very interesting layers so I'll anyways
follow them
yeah it'll also be a
I will also be curious about whom I'll
be facing tomorrow yeah oh it's gonna be
a lot of fun big congratulations on your
match win today go cash
yeah thank you thank you for joining us
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
for chess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
it's time for another twitch break if
you're not a subscriber if you are a
subscriber well we're gonna look into
the winner semi-finals coming up shortly
[Music]
thank you
I think I have to take a look at the
bracket now because we have not finished
the first few matches on the losers
bracket two players are knocked out and
two players have not made it through to
the losers quarterfinals and uh what did
you think of the matches here oh they
were very very thrilling very exciting
and it did seem at one point very
one-sided I didn't expect alexio Serrano
just to overhaul faroogia and farooja
suffering his fifth loss in a row and he
looks absolutely devastated on camera
and then Mama door from the cash what a
roller coaster look at cash so calm so
collected and you he didn't seem phase
at all by the fact that he lost the
second game and he just went to business
and absolutely demolished her mamadolf
in the play the Armageddon yeah and now
these four players can lean back and
enjoy the winners bracket winner
semi-finals is coming up which of those
two matches Magnus Carlson against Eric
icy or Wesley so against Hikaru Nakamura
are you most excited to follow I miss
fans I'm very very sorry but it has to
be the match of between the two
juggernauts that are Wesley Wesley so
and Hikaru Nakamura and I really
intrigued actually how things are going
to develop because Wesley has been
playing titled Tuesday and as of now he
has like nine and a half out of ten he
has an insane score so yeah I mean
whether this is gonna work out well for
him I don't know but it's risky business
because traditionally you should be like
preparing yeah okay well is he finished
is he ready to start the other things
monsters now just finished his last
round was a joke
wow all right well so that's how Wesley
sauce been warming up to face a car
today I I know we haven't seen anything
from Hikaru but uh we'll find out
whether that was a good strategy or not
when it comes to the other matchup
between Magnus Carlson and Eric icy it's
traditionally been very one-sided in the
world champions favor guys yes he scored
one point of him but
the other the other matches really
hasn't gone his way so it will be
looking up on this as a learning
experience perhaps uh just use all the
knowledge that he's gained previously
yeah two cool matches is uh coming up
you guys we're gonna follow the first
game between Wesley saw Andy
coronakamura and Wesley so he has some
big goals coming up in 2023
your top three goals that you hope to
achieve in 2023 let's see the first one
would be to qualify to the candidates
I've only played in the candidates once
and it didn't go very well in 2018.
so I'm very excited to see what 2023
holds uh there will be some over the
board tournaments here and there but
almost half of the tournaments are held
online and they're very important they
got a lot of stakes I'm very pleased to
win last year's the global chess
tournament I'm excited to be part of the
new Championship during chess.com it's
interesting to see what this new
partnership will will hold for them win
some big online tournaments that would
be very nice for me as a player I'm
trying to balance myself between being
very good at classical while also doing
that bad online and speeches because
they're they're very different things
and so this year is going to be exciting
as well as a challenge and my calendar
is actually getting very full at the
moment I also need time to spend between
resting or covering and also preparing
and number three would be
too ambitious but no it's a
reach the top to the world
he has some big goals Wesley so one of
them is winning at least one online
event and uh this is day two of the air
things monsters he's playing the winner
is semi-finals against his fellow
American Hikaru Nakamura these are their
stats in Rapid chess oh yeah they played
a lot of games forward yeah I think I'm
surprising it's that man that might
include all different formats including
Blitz but recently Wesley so has had the
upper hand he took down hikaranakamura
on route to winning the global
Championship which earned him his spot
in division one here he beat him in Taza
still India when in the rapid game so
Wesley has done well against ikaro in
Rapid chess wow one of few players and
he's gonna start out with the white
pieces Wesley so been warming up playing
a lot of online chess today do you think
that's a good idea David uh I'm not sure
I could do it I don't have the same
energy levels as some of these top
players anymore but uh Wesley yeah he
had a bullet Marathon before you play
title Tuesday I think he must have been
playing online now for three four hours
he's got no excuses he's gonna be
feeling warmed up at least
um so as long as he's feeling confident
which he must do after winning title
Tuesday uh then it can't hurt that much
and Tanya what do you expect from this
matchup Wesley Sony car Nakamura and
just two Giants and chess a lot of fun
yeah that's what I expect now when these
two player in classical matches we've
often seen those games fizzle out into
draws but when they're added in speed
chess they go for it we see so many
decisive games I'm expecting Hikaru to
have the very Hikaru strategy of trying
to bring Wesley down on the clock flag
him really make him make those mistakes
when he's low on the clock because
Wesley is such a difficult opponent to
beat otherwise with his 15 minute and a
three second increment time format speed
and intuition are the two very important
factors and that's what it looks like
Wesley's been working on with all the
bullet and the title Tuesday uh the
practice that he's been getting in
before this big one yeah
what is that about uh I guess uh the
game should have started maybe some
technical issues uh he's impatient to
get going maybe he's hoping to strike
Hikaru while Wesley is still recovering
from title Tuesday Meanwhile we're off
it's a Kingsport opening we often see
the Italian or the Spanish when these
two play the Italian is a good sign it
means there's not going to be any quick
draws it's not going to fizzle out
anytime soon which has occasionally
happened between these two in Rapid
chess but the Italian guarantees all the
pieces on the board for a long long time
and maybe a theoretical battle to start
this one off David I'm just glad we're
not going to see the position that
you've set up for us on the chessboard
on our screens and that's already happy
moments for the fans yeah I wonder if
any of the fans have caught that on the
chessboard in front of us later on you
can try and figure out which position we
put on the board for you guys but uh
meanwhile this one we've seen it a
hundred times before uh Hikaru is maybe
the biggest specialist on the black side
of the Italian game uh he sets up with a
bunch of uh difference in a bunch of
different ways and often he loves to
drop back his Bishop his Dart score
Bishop to A7 and as we mentioned
yesterday white has a variety of plans
to choose from you can start bringing
one of the white knights around to the
uh to the king side you can start
gaining space on the queen side
eventually it's about who can push
forward in the center first but just a
very tense position Robert yeah and it
was a big decision by Hikaru to put a
ship on one square rather than two on
the a file because instead of fighting
for space he says I am just going to be
safe and sound Retreat my Bishop on the
dark squares and it allows White to push
forward on the queen side you can go B2
to B4 just continue to push those pawns
forward at the right moment and the
Knight that just jumped in front of the
Dark Sword Bishop it is going to go next
the King on F1 at some moment and then
jump forward either to G3 or E3 it is
standard fare in the Italian yep still
very well known uh well-known stuff
well-trodden Parts here first black
because you're slightly cramped white
has more space especially on the queen
side therefore uh Hikaru goes for traits
and a set of Bishops off the board
I at some point here Hikaru okay he's
looking off to the side he's uh looking
confused but that's because he's trying
to recall he's uh trying to remember
what his opening notes say for sure he's
seen this type of position before and uh
smiling there Hikaru maybe this last
Rook move I think maybe not the most
popular option has thrown him off
slightly so he'll take us a few seconds
to recompose himself and then make a
decision but Black's position is very
healthy uh despite the lack of space The
Rook from B1 really is making the
intentions clear at some point you want
to try to advance this B Pawn to B5 and
open up the B line now also notice that
how after the trade of the light Square
Bishops there have been some weaknesses
that are created and White's Knight can
find itself Landing up on the F5 square
one of the plans that white has is to
jump back with the Knight to F1 go to G3
go to F5 and try and Target the king
side and look at the decisions that the
players have taken I was talking about
White's intention of going B5 Hikaru
says None of that's happening not
allowing it goes B5 himself blocks the
pawn structure on the queen side and a
very interesting decision here Robert by
Wesley the rook's done its job on B on
the B-Line he slides back on the A-line
just anticipating and opening up of the
a file yeah it's a little Shuffle and
now we see that hikaru's Rook has left
the a file and scoot over to the B file
so there's a game of cat and mouse going
on and the point is that you leave the
tension but at some moment there will be
a pawn capture on B5 now that's
available black never wants to take that
pawn on A4 because as soon as you do
that then you're left with this A6
weakness it's going to be lost in many
of these positions white can just pile
up the pressure that would not be a good
choice and that's why black decide just
to move the Rook out the way
preemptively now if the capture on B5
happens the pawn caps spec the Knight
protects the bishop over there on A7 and
there's just no issues to deal with on
that side of the board so this is a
tense Affair thus far not a single Pawn
has been traded we'll see when that
first happens
yeah it's extremely tense this little
dance between the Rooks it's very
sophisticated stuff it's beyond most of
us we've got to say that it shows that
actually both sides just want to stay
flexible they want to only later decide
where they want to put their minor
pieces and only later decide when to go
for those Pawn breaks which will signify
the beginning of the real fireworks and
uh yeah it's I think both players will
be very happy with the type of opening
that they've received it's just very
tense and uh at least to start this this
semi-final it's uh promising science
that white has in these positions we've
been discussing about it where do you
put that Knight on D2 we see that it's
coming in the way of its own bishop and
Wesley shows the part he goes for the
idea that we were discussing falls back
a little bit but only to go forward in
the next move the Knight comes back to
F1 it is heading towards that F5 Square
he also opens up his own Bishop so
continuing to develop but also keeping
the tension on the board not trading any
bonds yeah the last sorry I was gonna
say the last time I looked at this type
of position was an Anish giri's one E4
chessboard course oh really uh it always
seemed to say it always seemed to fizzle
out to a small wise Advantage but not
enough to win uh let's see if that's uh
if this game proceeds along those parts
well speaking of chessable courses that
is one way to study chess we know books
is another way Robert revealing to us
that he's not a huge fan of Chess books
earlier today and we actually have a
question on Twitch from powered by
glucosis and I'll ask you this one bird
so as a 1500 player is it more important
to play to improve or to read and look
into strategies
both all the above yeah I think that
sometimes we do puzzles for example and
we need to work on a pattern recognition
that sort of muscle memory and that's
useful for a growing player the issue is
when you do puzzles you're getting the
tap on the shoulder that there is a
solution there whereas we've just seen
in the games from the air things Masters
that there may be one solution but you
don't know that it exists you have to
find it on your own so I think that you
have to read but you also have to play
to you can't just get that experience
anywhere in the middle of a game a
training session and you're finding
those best moves with the clock
pressuring you as well I think you have
to do all the above so yep so as a 1500
player do everything
if you oh if you have limited time
though if you're working or going to
school you only maybe have half an hour
or an hour every day to work on chess
what should you prioritize David
uh My Philosophy has always been 50
playing and 50 other stuff so that other
stuff could include analyzing the games
that you have played you could include
reading books following broadcasts
commentary watching videos
um but I think playing is at least 50
that has to be it um just to kind of get
that muscle memory to get in the flow to
get in the mindset because it is a sport
after all it's a competitive uh field
chest and you have to kind of put
yourself under pressure in order to
improve yeah I think the most important
thing and not to forget is to actually
just enjoy chess a lot so if you've got
limited amount of time do what makes you
enjoy the game if it's solving puzzles
do that if it's playing bullet do that
the more you'll do it the more you'll
enjoy it the more you'll improve just
make sure it's not 100 time spent on
bullet
that can be tricky I remember this is a
I'll call it a blunder by Magnus Carlsen
uh he posted some videos with tips for
beginners and he also uh posted later uh
sort of the what do you call it not
blunders but uh the bloopers bloopers is
the word I'm looking for where he said
sit by the board and play with yourself
[Laughter]
but keep sharing your questions and
comments on Twitch as well we'll bring
up as many as we can to our experts in
the studio here we do have some moves on
the board uh what do you think so far in
this game yeah so far it's just
maneuvering moves uh neither side is
really kind of setting out their battle
strategy saying I'm coming for you on
this side of the board whitesnites have
just uh hinted at some jumps later on
they parked themselves nicely in front
of the white king defending the white
king but also ready to spring forward if
given the opportunity but this last
queen move does show a bit of hesitation
from Wesley he's just saying to Hikaru
you can't really break out either so I'm
gonna wait and wait and slight space
Advantage for white on the queen side
one very classical plan in these
positions for black is to open up the
center you want to try and get a
successful D5 break in but it also needs
to be timed really well we see this last
move by Hikaru bringing the queen up now
he can also double up the rook and the
Queen on the D file which is
anticipating that D5 break because a
threat is stronger than an execution so
he's really just preparing it at some
point I'm expecting Hikaru to come in
with the central break
and there will be various ways for
example if he does land it now of course
you can prepare it as Tanya Advocates
there but uh if you do land it then
white has a few possible answers firstly
you could just maintain the tension it's
not clear whether black is really
threatening to take your Pawn or to push
forward uh if you are scared of that
however you could capture it for white
and uh here the question would be
whether Black's Central Pawn is weak or
not here it's a Target but it's
sufficiently defended so I would say
that this actually favors black this
small transition but yeah it's
definitely revolving around whether
Hikaru can land this type of idea
pushing the pawn forward in the center
at a favorable moment if he can he
solved all his issues if he can't then
it's really hard from a human point of
view to find a plan to find anything
productive to do and I think it's
important for Wesley so not to push his
Pawn from A4 to A5 that would be so
tempting for many of us let's attack
this bishop on B6 when given the
opportunity but that closes down the
queen side permanently you want to keep
the tension because at some point your
Rook on A1 may be activated on its
starting Square so you want to take on
B5 when the moment is right you just do
not want to eliminate that as an option
so much more likely from Wesley's
perspective is to hop that Knight on G3
up towards the enemy King with Knight to
F5 and watch out for sacrifices on the
H6 Square it'll give up a minor piece
for two pawns but the black king will
lack shelter that could be very
dangerous but I think that's when your
time King that you've got a rook on E6
because those plans are super risky for
black you can't end up getting
checkmated but that Rook on E6 will be
eyeing key defensive squares if that
sacrifice was to appear on the board so
that's a happy Rook there yep uh Happy
Rook happy life that's the as the saying
goes but well that's the thing doesn't
go but uh wow Robert guess what move has
just landed on the board Pawn takes Pawn
the only one we were saying would never
happen and I'm shocked I've got to say
Hikaru worsening his Pawn structure
maybe feeling the tension he's just
trying to say okay yes I'm gonna be in
uh kind of left with this isolated porn
but I'm going to try and swap it off I'm
going to try and eliminate it next move
and if I can trade these pawns then I'm
very happy Suddenly It's symmetrical
Pawn structure equal position but the
question is whether Wesley he's got one
move maybe two moves uh does he have to
take this Pawn immediately first
question and second one can he strand
black with a weakness long term
commit or decision I don't like it I
don't think black needed to go for this
I think there were plenty of other
things to do we mentioned going for the
central break but uh yeah he's playing
on the side where he's technically
weaker what do we think of this but if
he manages to swap all the queen side
bonds I think that would be a happy
decision and a happy outcome for Hikaru
starting this match now this is a four
game match it's a long day ahead for
these players you want to with the black
Pieces Just make sure you neutralize all
of White's Edge it's definitely a
committed decision but it looks like
it's got a very concrete idea ahead I
like this point that you make David of
going A5 and just swapping off all the
pawns off the board yeah and uh if you
can achieve it then he's solved his
issues this is what the top players
often often do they just work out they
can calculate they make exceptions from
the general rules we were saying never
take that pawn you make your own
weaknesses you isolate your pawns but
they spot those exceptions to those uh
rare instances that they can go for
these ideas and this is the
justification let's wait for Wesley to
figure out whether he can punish Hikaru
for at least temporarily breaking his
structure why is he taking this long to
capture the pawn is there an alternative
that we're missing out on well the
part's not going anywhere so perhaps
he'll leave the pawn on a form hop
forward with Knight to F5 so I think
Wesley he understands that this is a
critical moment that black is trying
just to liquidate completely on the
queen side and there's also the question
of if he does take on A4 which Pawn does
he capture oh which piece excuse me just
capture you take with the queen he can
take with the Rook so there are several
options here for Wesley so and he
doesn't want to rush this and allow
hikar to immediately equalize
question for you guys uh should we jump
over to my this Crossing against Arjun
arguise you to take a look at the first
game in those in that match up it looks
slightly more exciting still very tense
in that one as well only one set of
Trades uh in that one one set of pieces
off the board but yeah maybe we do it
yeah I think Hikaru is about to solve
his issues by trading off uh his a pawn
here so
um there we go A5 and if those pawns
disappear equality let's check out
what's happening in Magnus Carlson
against argenteric icy yeah big matchup
there as well Magnus Carlsen and Arjun
arrogacy they played each other a bunch
last season on the meltwater Champions
uh chess tour
and here they are in another match up
the bar in the middle
what are we seeing from the get-go in
this matchup yeah so it's it's very
tense but Aldrin has made a very
ambitious but committal decision over
the last couple of moves he's Advanced
the F Pawn down the board so he's
initiating a potential Pawn storm
against the white king if he gets Thai
margin here I don't think he'd hesitate
too much he would throw the black G Pawn
down try to dislodge the White Knight
and uh just all the pawns would head
towards that white king I don't like
what Magnus has done with this queen
I've got to say I'm not sure how it
ended up there and uh White pieces are a
bit locked up for uh for now
um still white or solid of course
shouldn't be too much wrong objectively
but uh yeah he's down on the clock too
practice calcium very ambitious play by
Black by Archer and here in this
position on the king side as we see but
I think this is exactly what he needs to
do in this match to come on top he
cannot fear Magnus Carlson this match is
so much about psychology for Arjun as
well he needs to believe that he can win
it he needs to make the most of the
smallest opportunity and chances he gets
and I think his best shot is to try to
create a mess on the board try and get
messy positions against Magnus because
if you try to play strategically he's
just going to outplay you uh Archer yes
committed stuff on the king side but I
like it it creates pressure and Madness
there going with his Bishop to B5
because watch out that pawn on E5 is
weak he wants to trade the Knight on C6
and then start attacking that Central
Pawn on E5 Yep this is the target as you
point out there Tanya and the one
downside behind advancing pawns is they
can't move backwards they do create
weaknesses and this Pawn can never be
defended by a fellow pawn it will tie
down at least one black piece and as you
mentioned there's a bit of a threat if
black does for example ask the question
of the bishop Magnus won't hesitate you
capture if the queen recaptures this
Pawn drops and of course you don't want
to saddle yourself with weak pawns on
this flank also the white Bishop on B2
suddenly comes back to life re-energized
and on this diagonal it looks perfectly
placed I don't think Arjun wants to
allow or entertain this possibility so
what can he do instead he's likely to
play the move C5 to C4 himself just
shutting down their Bishop on B2 it's
often worth giving up material to shut
down your opponent's pieces the E5 Pawn
feels a lot safer with the bishop out of
the equation and that actually leaves
Magnus with a tough choice do you really
want to take this Pawn on C4 have double
isolated pawns yourself I don't think
you do and we actually did just see
origen make a move he doesn't push the
pawn he plays Bishop F6 which does
immediately defend this Pawn E5 but
already I'm thinking about exchange
sacrifices we've seen so many a world
champion Champions over the years
including Magnus Carlson eventually try
to plant a rook on D5 I don't think it's
good right here and now but at some
moment look for that kind of exchange
sacrifice you know getting a strong
passport in return opening up a nice
Outpost for the White Queen uh the
problem here maybe is that black would
ignore the Rook at least for a move or
two longer and yeah a very thematic idea
there instead Magnus captures this Black
Knight and Arjun is hesitating I'm very
surprised here I've got to say if you
take with the pawn long term these are
extremely weak and easy targets for the
white dot Square Bishop for the White
Knight but if you take with the queen I
guess the reason he's translating is
because the pawn will step forward uh
reinstating this threat against the
e-pawn and if you defend it you lose
time with the black queen you've lost
two Tempe and watch out for Robert's
exchange sacrifice you could land at any
moment Rook to D5 yes it comes with the
custom material but you get so much in
return
and Arjun he's weighing up that up he
has captured will he drop his Queen back
and will Magnus go for this idea
the questions there and we see him
taking a little bit of of time here I do
not see another way to defend the E5
Pawn it's also interesting that white
has the possibility to build up more
pressure against the center Pawn he
drops back with the queen and one idea
Rook D5 again super combative with an
exchange sacrifice but this is the other
plan that Magnus has gone for he wants
to really double up the pressure on the
E5 he's looking at setting up that Queen
and Bishop battery along the diagonal
Arjun swipes up The Rook all the way to
E8 so that he can fall back with the
bishop to see it a retreating move by
the bishop just making sure the pawn on
E5 remains defended yep uh it's just a
battle of plans right now and the more
we look at the position the more it
feels like this is a real hole in the in
the black Camp if the white knight could
ever land there that would just be
glorious I'm not sure the path
unfortunately it does take a few moves
but if you imagine the White Knight on
this beautiful juicy Square then uh yeah
you can present this black you don't
even want to tolerate that but uh it
takes too long and a big decision there
by uh origen because he could have
brought his Bishop forward and said he
retreated backwards he's covering that
D5 Square If instead of retreating to F7
he brought his Bishop forward to G4 I
just want to show quickly how domination
happens you can wear Rook D2 and it's
like oh my king-site Pawn structure it's
in Shameless if Bishop takes Knight Pawn
takes wage is gonna double Rooks bring a
rook to D5 black dark Square Bishop is
very passive and White's King can
actually sneak towards the center of
King F1 King E2 very safe there while
Black's Pawn structure is actually the
worst one you don't want pawns on the
same color as your own Bishop Yep this
bishop is just terrible for the rest of
the game just uh resigned to being a
Defender he's going for your idea role
but he anyways goes Rook D3 to try and
double up the rook and bring that Rook
to the seventh Rank and it looks like
he's building a lot of pressure here
yeah it looks like Magnus is turning
this slightly in his favor at least
momentum wise but will aragaisy fight
back for example we mentioned a possible
Pawn storm at some point I don't think
you can go for it right now to loosening
to weakening but first he takes the time
out to defend uh the seventh rank Magnus
can heat up the pressure it looks like
all of these pieces are pretty much on
their perfect squares right now and uh
can he improve that's the question or
can I regret he just knuckle down
solidify and hope to cancel later this
is your worst nightmare against Magnus
where you've given him all the play and
Magnus we've seen him just convert these
positions flawlessly he just keeps
building the pressure move by move until
the opponent cracks it looks like the
kind of position that black has just got
to keep things together it's hard to
come up with an act active plan and
there we see the Rooks have been doubled
up currently the D7 square is defended
but it's going to be an uphill task to
keep the defense going and on the clock
as well Magnus ahead by almost two
minutes guys earlier I said the bishop
pair were my favorite thing in the world
can I retract that statement look at
that square Bishop but that's not a
bishop to be fair to you that's a big
Pawn sitting on F6 so it's not really a
bishop pair for black you can keep your
statement thank you very much
well how about you guys Tanya and Robert
what do you prefer I know there is
always like a big discussion do you
prefer the bishop pair the knights a
bishop and the Knight what do you prefer
you take it first I'm a bishop person I
have to say I love the Bishops but of
course it depends on the position when
you've got a bishop there you're really
looking for an open position so that
your Bishops can be on these diagonals
these are long range pieces they need
space to breathe and to really Thrive
and flourish but in this position as we
can see the Bishops are behind their own
pawns and there really isn't that much
to play for also Knights are super
tricky so be careful of them and I would
say In classical games I love myself a
bishop bear but if it was bullet Blitz
give me a night any day okay how about
you Robert I think I grew up preferring
my Knights over Bishops maybe because I
like viciana as a player he tends to
give away his Bishops for enemy Knights
but as I've matured I'm gonna put that
in quotes because really you actually
did yeah Sam is a big kid over here I do
prefer the bishop pair if I can just get
a neutral position with the pair of
Bishops I already feel like I have an
advantage and so yeah I would go with
the Bishops okay I saw Robert enjoying
that effort by Serana earlier with the
Bishops just maneuvering them just every
move Robert would give a stamp of
approval so I could tell his answer was
coming yeah and with AI we're sort of
getting you know even clearer answers to
the big questions in chess what will AI
say what what does AI prefer oh Alpha
zero in that famous match against
stockfish
a few years back now it would often give
up several pawns for the bishop pair but
it's only a very specific circumstances
when you can guarantee that the Bishops
have range that they can be like archers
just looking afar across the board and
Target everything in lock positions then
it's less clear so what you're saying is
the holiday I would not like the bishop
here we see on the screen in front of us
the Big Pawn there not helping white
pieces are just in perfect places the
Rooks are doubled uh they're defended
the pawn structure is preferable for
white and look at this the Knight F3 was
putting pressure on E5 but Magnus pushed
his H Pawn not to create left for his
King but to bring his Knight back just
to head forward to G4 and he induced the
weakness with origin playing H1 simply
to stop that night moving this is Magnus
at his best maneuvering chest and he is
the one with the upper hand here and
when Magnus beat Arjun in the final of
the was it Julius bear generation cup uh
last season he did mention in the
interview that he was playing Auntie
young player chess especially against
was playing openings where it wasn't
necessarily anything forcing he wasn't
going directly flip a kill but he just
gives Arjun a bunch of very difficult
strategic decisions and actually it's
very difficult to answer them especially
against someone like Magnus who will
punish you if you make the smallest
inaccuracy and it feels like arjun's
somewhere maybe around the moment we
joined it maybe missing Robert's uh Pawn
to C4 push there locking in the white
Bishop he's let it slip and uh ever
since it's been going steadily downhill
it's white fully in control black is
stuck Frozen I don't see any productive
moves and uh White has clear plans of
improving his pieces every step these
lasting moves have been so impressive by
Magnus absolute class there he fell back
with his Knight provoked a big weakness
in Black's camp with that moves then
just simply comes back the Knight has
done his job returns to this post where
it attacks E5 what is black done now
Arjun is left with another weakness on
H5 the ball is in his court every move
is difficult to answer he's burning the
clock he's down to wait what is that
three minutes on the clock and a really
passive position for black yeah really
passive and white can switch Focus white
can play on the king's side potentially
you could certainly imagine the white
king moving out the way the white Rooks
shifting across and then opening up some
lines on this side towards the black
king you can imagine white switching
towards the queen side hitting this Pawn
in the center and then uh flicking a
pawn push up here to open the position
at the right moment uh just to try and
gain some space Magnus is super flexible
and okay Arjun moves his Rook Magnus
says okay I'm clamping down I'm closing
the position even further now there's a
nice juicy Square later for the White
Knight I don't think you want to rush in
but uh definitely no Pawn pushes for
black on that flank Knights thrive in
these clear positions I think he closed
it to open it on his own terms Magnus
might bring his King up to H2 Rook over
to G1 and push his G pawn and I think
origen understands that he cannot sit
and do nothing because when that side of
the board opens up it's all fun for
white miserable for black so he plays B5
trying desperately to claw open the
queen side unfortunately all of White's
pieces and goods are placed there so he
does go forward with your knight G5 idea
David he gets that Dark Sword Bishop off
the board E5 becoming even bigger Target
C5 now cemented on a dark Square you
don't have a dark Square Bishop to
defend it uh I would not like this
position at all for black I just don't
see any plans then again white has
traded his beautiful Knight for that big
porn that big kind of stuck piece on F6
uh that dot Square Bishop so at least he
has the Solace of opposite color Bishops
here if it does go down to an end game
which is miles away unfortunately but if
it does get to an end game then he might
hope to hold this one Eric I see it's
just the clock it's just the position
right now in two minutes now suffering
on both
very difficult stuff and we often talk
about opposite color Bishops and how
that might end in a job not this one
because it's all about which Bishop has
targets and while the E4 Pawn for white
can be defended it comes back to that
decision that Arjun made with that F
Pawn the E5 Central Pawn is a weakness
forever he falls back on F7 I don't
believe that Magnus ever wants to
retreat with the Rook of course he could
but he doesn't really care about an
attack on that Rook because imagine and
visualize if that Rook was even picked
up by the bishop just how strong white
spawn there would be let's just put that
on the board for example if white
weights let's say I make a pawn move the
Rook drops back yes white can move the
Rook maybe just an active squares but
even if we leave it uh let's say for
example let's make a queen move then yep
super strong pawns now in the center
white still has ideas of attacking on
this side and uh great positional
compensation instead Magnus he doesn't
play the slow approach of course he goes
in with his Queen he's going to zigzag
her into the black cab and just increase
the pressure
slowly but steadily it's just getting
worse and worse for black better and
better for white but uh can Arden solve
his issues maybe with some tactics at
some point as he ticks down to one and a
half minutes on the clock
you don't want to be in this situation
against Magnus on the board but yeah
when Magnus is on the clock he also
hustles because he calculates so quickly
you need time to find tactics and origen
does not have time he is down under a
minute and about to be 20 seconds he
just doesn't have a move he can trade
pawns on C4 but chess is not a game
about one little trade it's about coming
up with a plan Arjun has no plan he is
just trying to fend off all of magnus's
threats his Rook on E6 blocks his own
Bishop but if he ever moves that Rook
away that gives white more control along
some squares in the Deep file so this is
so unpleasant to have he does swap off a
pair of Pawns we just saw that uh but
now what maybe he's best served as
moving his King side to side and saying
that perhaps Magnus has no way to make
progress yeah argue that black has a
fortress okay first he solidifies
another Pawn but look at that white dot
squared Bishop now if Black's Central
Pawn ever disappears that white dark
Square Bishop rakes across the board and
uh yeah this WOW Magnus just whitening
his eyes
I think shocked by this last decision by
air I see it did feel to me like Magnus
was trying to provoke this move I think
Magnus would have happily invested two
or three moves to provoke black to push
his Pawn to G6 that's uh Magnus now just
needs to find a killer blow and black is
just Holding On by a thread in this
position with those Rooks one of the
ideas that one can actually have is to
trade one pair he could also put the
queen and triple up on the D file and
then go in with the Rook go to D go to
d8 trade off make you know more use of
these dark Squad weaknesses that we're
talking about imagine if one pair of
Rook Rooks gets traded off the E5 Pawn
will be such a glaring weakness in this
position yeah I like that uh that idea
as well uh Tanya of creating the
alakyne's gun just moving The Rook for
example sliding the queen behind and
then just breaking in through the open
file uh towards the black king it takes
a while I'm not sure whether you have
that luxury but uh that will be on
magnus's radar or as you said just swap
off one set of Rooks looks very simple
you could also land on the seventh rank
I'm not sure where you're going from
there but very many tempting uh moves
and it's theory of two weaknesses black
has this huge huge problem on E5 of
course but if you can just create one
more weakness one more Target for the
white pieces that will overwhelm the
black defenses and I wouldn't be
surprised if Magnus pushes his Pawn to
G3 and then eventually the second Pawn
to F4 and opens up that Bishop on the
long diagonal because if that pawn E5 is
gone the full length of diagonals open
for that Bishop the queen would like to
join the party and deliver a Checkmate
this is looking very scary for our
generic guys if you could ever line up
the White Queen on the same diagonal as
a bishop
I like that new feature David I'm
learning I'm learning
very cool yeah it might take a while but
uh Magnus will be looking for those
types of ideas in the next few moves all
right in less than a minute for Arjun
erag icy what do you think right now
Robert will the Indian lose this first
game in this match yeah he's playing
Magnus Carlson he's down a ton on the
clock he has no real ideas in the
position so I feel like Magnus he's
spending his time here he knows that he
doesn't want to give Arjun a series of
easy moves because with Black's last
move it seems like he wants to move his
Rook out of the way open up his Bishop
things of that nature so I think mag's
just trying to be precise right now
because the next few moves will be
easier for him to play and more
difficult for Arjun aha
Magnus Carlsen is under three minutes on
the clock this is the first game in the
Winner's semi-final match between these
two the winner of this match goes
through to the winners
final and the loser of this match is
knocked down to the losers bracket to
play the losers quarter finals tomorrow
you do have two lives in the double
elimination format wow and a slight
surprise to me at least because we were
just highlighting some potential
checkmating ideas on the dark squares
but Magnus has offered a queen trade
first he dropped back his Bishop to A1
white Bishop in the corner nobody puts
it in the corner it still looks pretty
good there but uh yeah the queen trade
heads towards the end game but the
problem for Arjun is the Rooks are still
on with the Rooks off you could maybe
hold a draw if you're lucky but with the
Rooks on White's Rooks clearly Superior
to those passive uh to their passive
black counterparts what do we think of
this decision
surprise but I think positionally it
seems to work really well he knows he's
got a long-term Advantage with all these
Pawn weaknesses now what black can count
on is that B3 weakness that white has a
lot of weaknesses for black but White's
got one and that's the pawn on V3 he
offers one Trader Brooks the more the
Rooks get off the board the easier the
defensive task gets for Arjun but yes
Magnus will trade off one but not the
other
yeah with his remaining Rook Magnus is
going to go Pawn hunting there we go a
trade of porn a trade of Rook sorry and
uh we launch up the board with that work
white Rook going after the isolates uh
the what black A6 Pawn is the first
Target five seconds as well oh sorry uh
13 seconds for Argent but uh not much
time at all no and he finally takes the
pawn E5 we've been pointing at it for
um the last bunch of moves he takes it
in the F4 Pawn is next the A6 Pawn is
hanging The Rook just patrolling the
sixth rank here origin trying to find
any idea just to stay alive here but
with so little time and I think white
can just start scooping up the material
yeah one Pawn down and it's uh about to
increase magnus's lead first he gives a
check oh discover checks all over the
shop here if Magnus wants first he can
just step his Bishop out the way just uh
avoid any Rook taste Bishop ideas and
the threats continue There we go White's
Rook is going to jump out the way I
think we won't see Arjun fight this one
on much longer you're facing the best
endgame player of all time and you're up
one down with a bunch of weaknesses
yeah it's uh it's that it's just been a
master class for Magnus in terms of
strategy uh strategic play this was
super tough from start to finish for
Archer it was all about giving Magnus
the kind of position where Magnus is the
only one playing and putting that
pressure move after move it's just a
nightmare against him and we see now he
is a couple of Pawns up it's not even
about the the concept of two weaknesses
everything is a weakness in Blacks Camp
right now Arjun with F3 attacks the
Magnus would have to attacks the bishop
but also defends the E4 Pawn the bishop
will fall back the G6 Pawn will hang and
now he goes for Rook beer that's an
interesting move but what is the point
you can just pick up the bishop on G4
yeah it's desperation he's hinting at a
counter attack uh if the black Rook can
get active maybe start checking the
white king especially after a trade on
G4 black will have a couple of Pawns
next to each other but it's just uh yeah
it's just a bluff unfortunately I think
with a few seconds left on the clock
Arjun is just playing for tricks and
they don't quite work
has magnets calculated at all I think he
can just figure it out at this point oh
yes he has he gives his Bishop back just
to create a pass Pawn over here the G6
Pawn is still hanging he'll have two
Advanced pass pawns that cannot be
stopped and the material count is still
in magnus's favor after all of that so
uh Arjun he's just playing on just to
get these final moves in but that H Pawn
cannot be stopped anymore yep that white
porn will cost black as Rook if you want
to stop it uh actually you might not
even get given the opportunity a rook
trade and white will make a new Queen
Arjun is about to resign losing on time
as well and he logs off immediately oh
wow it's a win four Magnus crawls in the
in the first game in the winner is
semi-finals he's playing a match against
Arjun Eric icy this was only the first
game Arjun did play with the black
pieces and he still has three games uh
to win the match he can still turn it
around this one is still going on this
is game one between Hikaru Nakamura and
Wesley so the two huge Americans and
what's happening the bar is roughly to
the middle in this game it's roughly to
the middle but uh Wesley so has got a
bit of a problem that black a Pawn on
that very strong past black apron is
still alive and how does he pick it up
the white king isn't entirely safe if
you look at the black Rook The Black
Queen they're both aligned towards that
white Pawn on F2 which has just moved
forward one square and uh if Wesley can
safely pick up that pawn he's uh upper
clear Pawn he's in a very promising end
game but I was gonna say maybe it wasn't
possible but he's achieved it what do we
think serious winning chances here for
white definitely and look at the Clark
situation both players hovering around
20 seconds they do have three second
increment and both of them are super
Speedy whilst they sell one title
Tuesday earlier today and Magus Carlson
he won his game but the car Nakamura
beat Magnus Carlson for the speeches
championship title now Queen E3
threatens the white king I think you
have to push your pieces backwards and
look at this a rook sacrifice trying to
secure a draw and uh you saw Hikaru lean
back with pride I think at that last
Rook sacrifice it's almost guaranteed to
be a draw at this point there's no way
for the white king to hide that can give
checks forever and the player's Leaf it
is a draw wow the first battle between
them ends in a draw the second one will
start in five minutes any car Nakamura
will have the white pieces in that game
I think we should take a look at the
game between Magnus Carlsen and Arjun
aragaisy a big win for minus there David
a very big win and uh just to show how
he Consolidated his advantage in that
one Magnus we mentioned he had full
control we mentioned strategically he
was dominant but just this very nice com
Queen exchange and this confirmed his
Advantage removed all threats of counter
Play Once the Queens disappeared we saw
a bunch of weaknesses this Pawn
indefensible this black pawn also in a
dark square a clear Target long term and
uh this central point of course going to
drop off we saw one Rook trade but that
wasn't enough the remaining Rook came in
and this shows trading pieces doesn't
necessarily uh worsen your winning
chances here it's just an easier way to
pick up the weaknesses in Black's Camp
Arjun tried to cause some trouble but
was unsuccessful
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the botan
sisters come on look at this
chess.com is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
on chess.com on Twitch then we're going
to send you to a twitch break now right
now if not we're gonna dig into the
results so far in the winter semi-finals
[Music]
foreign
whatever he's doing in Canada is
certainly agrees with him and he made it
look very effortlessly and I have to say
the pressure is now on Arjun already to
actually recover from that to find a way
to unbalance the world champion and uh I
would recommend go outside Shake It Off
do something radical because so far it's
not really working and and according to
his track record he does need to make
some drastic changes yeah and minus goes
and he won two games yesterday he
basically could have won three games
yesterday starting off with another win
here what's up with him well he's having
a good time yes hi Tanya alluded to you
know he's enjoying himself and he's
always said he plays fantastic chess
when he's feeling good he's in a good
mood yeah do you think it is maybe a
little bit to do with hanging out with
the chess Bros having a little bit of a
good time together with friends it's all
those Good Vibes and yeah let's face it
you know if you're feeling happy you
play guitar I mean it's that simple yeah
and then Hikaru Nakamura Wesley Seoul
the draw a safe solid draw in the first
game there
you know I have to say Wesley was just
prodding and probing Hikaru just looking
for those weaknesses you know he just
kept on pushing you know on the king
side on the on the green side I mean he
just kept on going and I have to say it
was Hikaru who was on the back foot the
whole time okay so Hikaru now gonna have
the white pieces in game two what do you
expect well I mean if I were to say like
to use a football analogy you know it's
a game of it's like a game of chess
right and there's a game of football I
would say it's Advantage to Wesley um
Hikaru now needs to actually do exactly
the same in the the second game yeah so
all the players are working hard in the
winner of semi-finals and we hope you
guys at home are working hard as well on
today's puzzle it's from a study
composed by the youngest player in the
air thinks muscles gukash what is this
Apostle or study about you yeah I mean
you have to remember he composed this
study when he was just 15 years old I
mean he's 16 now but I mean it's white
to play and the whole you know so
in-game study and the whole theme is
that white must take advantage of
something right now if you wait too long
then of course Black's forces will unify
and there will be some defenses so it's
very very very clever and gather your
friends take selfies show me don't don't
turn on the computer
don't cheat to get your friends together
have a good old natter and see whether
you can solve it together because after
all that's the best way of solving
puzzles definitely and tweet your answer
using hashtag chess Champs One winner
will get a fantastic air things device
fine by Magnus Carlson and Magnus
Carlsen is getting ready for game two
here in the winners semi-finals
we're off it's a King's Pawn opening wow
guess what move has just landed on the
board context porn the only one we were
saying would never happen Hikaru
worsening his Pawn structure wow Magnus
just widening his eyes there I think
shocked by this last decision is by Eric
icy Arjun is about to resign losing on
time as well and he logs off immediately
all right are we ready for game juice in
the winter semi-finals of course yeah
Carlson playing Arjun era Garcia
Nakamura what more could you ask for I
know I mean can you believe the lineup
these four amazing players yeah it's
stuck this whole field
yeah I'm expecting a lot more fireworks
it's a long match today it's four games
in the winners bracket so Erica he has
time to fight back but uh yeah Magnus
whoever he plays uh in the next round
whether it's the win or loser bracket I
think uh he's been in top form so far
he's gonna be the one to stop yeah Arjun
eragite with the white pieces he lost
the first game to Magnus but still has
time to turn this around and what are we
seeing on the board in this game Tanya
wow it's a Queen's Gambit accepted
Magnus has decided to pick up that Free
Pawn and I have to say losing that first
game definitely a big setback for Arjun
when you're playing against Magnus it
really sets up the dawn for the match so
with the white pieces super crucial that
he gets his chances from the opening
Magnus making a bit of a risky Choice
there with the picking up that C4 Pawn
Yeah so the Queen's got bit accepted
this time but this last move maybe not
the most common it does kind of provoke
white it does try to tempt white into
occupying the center white is
temporarily down one Pawn that black
Pawn on C4 the double Pawn won't
necessarily survive that long but Magnus
is saying okay if you don't go for it
now I will defend it and uh Arjun does
open up his light Squad Bishop not
pushing the pawn two squares which was
maybe a more risky but more ambitious
approach instead he's ready to capture
that Bishop he's saying to Magnus defend
it at your peril and Magnus says yes
I'll happily cling to that extra Pawn
can Arjun punish him this is often the
way to try and undermine Black's Queen
side uh structure there what do you
think Robert is this something you know
I must say I'm out of book at this point
I think it's becoming increasingly
popular just because these type of
variations they force a large series of
Trades that these A4 Pawn for the B5
Pawn the Rooks will come off the board
there will see some other Queen side
pawns come off so with Magnus Carlson in
the lead he says I'm okay being slightly
worse perhaps and making a draw he does
not want to give Arjun Eric icy the type
of tactical positions that he thrives in
I think it's a wise opening Choice even
though Origins should be slightly better
yeah man just to show all the traits
that might well happen over the next few
moves if audrian is feeling peaceful
um okay he plays B3 first of all uh
keeping some tension but now question is
for Magnus how do you answer this one he
could have traded Pawns of course he
could have traded Rooks he could have
then gone B3 hoping to break his Bishop
spring it free to capture this Pawn but
black would just leave this tension and
give back the pawn and I think this is
what you're alluding to Robert A
variation like this where long-term
black will get rid of his only isolated
Pawn trade-off and very hard to imagine
White having much of an advantage here
Magnus is doing the same thing but he's
saying okay there's still this tension
along the a file I don't think white can
profit from that so we might see a
similar white will regain this Pawn at
will most likely now and Magnus he'll
just try to shore up his defenses he'll
just try and curl up and equalize which
he might well do I'm sure he studied
this one before Magnus the speed with
which he's playing at least that's what
it seems to reflect but I think arjun's
got reasons to be pleased with the fact
that he gets this combative energetic
opening you know it's hard to beat
Magnus if Magnus decides to be solid but
in these kind of positions we can
imagine fireworks in the middle game
very good idea to pick up that extra
Pawn right now because you anyway need
to finish your development you want to
get that Bishop on C4 eventually hope
that the C7 Pawn might be a weakness and
the counter for that often for black is
to strike in the center with C5 as soon
as possible yep I think we'll see this
on the board this is the most likely
continuation right now and when C5
happens it's like we'll swap off his
only weakness but black is slightly
lagging behind in development if you
look at all of these guys still at home
tucked up in bed and uh okay Magnus
first decides to solve that issue he
first develops his Knight so early days
but Magnus solid definitely playing for
equality Arjun will try and keep as much
attention as possible if you can we have
been discussing ways of studying chess
here in the studio today with some great
questions from you guys on Twitch and we
have another one from Kevin winter I'll
direct this to you first David so is
there Merit still getting out the chess
set to analyze positions Etc youngsters
use apps on their phones to prepare and
practice uh shout out to Kevin I believe
he's a fellow Brit so hi
um I do like the chess set I'm old
school
um not that I have a chess set in the
apartment
but there's a different feel to it at
least back when I was kind of playing
professionally full time I would always
put things on a board because you
somehow see things you understand a bit
more if you are kind of just seeing
things in 3D and um yeah on a computer
screen somehow doesn't feel the same
often I'm just clicking buttons saying
okay the computer says this so it must
be right but I don't activate my brain
and it's only when I get to the heat of
the action get to the board when I'm
like why didn't I study this move it's
so obvious for a human and I think
that's the difference I
chessboard over computer yeah
yeah that's a great question and I think
it really depends on how you see
yourself as a chess player if you want
to focus on online play and playing more
and more games online then you can let
go of the chessboard try and practice
and get that board vision from online
chess itself but if you have Ambitions
to play over the board it definitely
helps to bring out the chess set your
vision improves your understanding of
positions just getting the feel of the
pieces it's so different online chess is
just such a different animal from OTB so
if you want to play tournaments get that
chest set out all right what do you
prefer Robert
not studying chess yeah I prefer doing
my job and then watching you know
something on Netflix now but I do prefer
the physical board because if I'm going
to look at a position and especially if
you're working with somebody you want to
just look at it over the board really
dig deep and think about that way
because I think the screen is a bit of
distraction I know that I get some
headaches from staring at the screen too
often and you kind of don't always feel
fully focused because I don't and I
think that especially when you have the
eval bar off the side you're looking
like okay a white is better because I'm
told so but you're not turning on that
switch like David was saying and
calculating for yourself aha Stay
playing online somehow I enjoy a lot I
really enjoy playing online but uh in
terms of study I think over the board is
just as effective at least and I mean
well Magnus Magnus castles his King is
this a pawn sacrifice this black A6 pawn
it seems to be the theme of the day
every player we've seen with the black
pieces seems to have a weakness on this
square that tends to drop off I'm trying
to figure out whether Arjun can get
ambitious and just capture that pawn
right now why not why not that's a great
question because you can pick it up and
if black picks up the bishop on E6 tank
that Knight on D2 that is defending the
Rook on B1 black can swap off the bishop
hit the queen but white doesn't care
simply captures back and you can take
the Rook on B1 the Knight will make a
retreating move and everything's under
control white ends up with an extra Pawn
Yeah I know lpdo is a favorite saying of
Chess commentators but here no loose
pieces no loose pawns everything's
defended in the white Camp so uh what
has Magnus worked out now we do see a
tweet from Grandmaster Jonathan Tisdale
uh praising magnus's form I agree he's
looking good but he needs to at least
justify this Pawn sacrifice otherwise
Suddenly It's all about whether white
can convert
um I'm still struggling to see it I must
admit do you think it was intuitive or
he really has this figured out because
it's one of those Pawn sacrifices
sometimes you just do because you know
it should be the right answer and then
you're saddled with decision um why did
I give that pawn am I actually going to
get this back so I feel like from Magnus
here he's likely to maybe swap off some
material and try to go after the a pawn
it is a pass Pawn it's an extra Pawn but
it's also an isolated Pawn not so easy
to defend and Magnus does trade the
Rooks there and I'm curious if his move
now bringing the queen all the way to
the corner to the AIDS we're offering a
queen trade and going directly for that
pawn on A4 yeah but it's become a race
if white can keep that pawn while
reactivating his pieces on the back rank
then Arjun is going to take this one
home he's going to win but if Magnus can
somehow Corral that pawn and just uh
somehow regain the material equality in
the next three or four moves then he
should be safe enough I'm very surprised
if it was intuitive then
perhaps it was just a shocked that he's
in such a complacent mood Magnus because
he looks so sharp it looks like he's
calculated everything uh in all his
games so far in the tournament but there
we go Robert you predicted it uh it
feels like the only logical follow-up to
justify that earlier sacrifice and Arjun
immediately Retreats saying no trade uh
instead hitting that isolated Pawn on C7
now does black defend it does black just
say okay I'll trade off my weakness for
your a pawn get rid of that past Pawn
definitely feels like black is the one
fighting for equality now well looking
at Magnus on camera he doesn't look
super happy with the way things have
gone so far Queen C4 I like that Arjun
decided to keep the Queens on board
rather than just handing over the a file
to Magnus where the Rook would have come
and attacked the weakness one of the big
problems for white in compensation for
that pawn is that he needs to get those
pieces out he needs to develop as soon
as possible that night on B1 the bishop
on C1 get that Rook into the game but
that gives black a lot of time I like
the idea of just going for C5 you've
been screaming about this plan and it's
on the board finally Magnus does it the
problem after C5 for Arjun is going to
be that if you trade these spawns the
Knight can jump over to C5 and hit that
A4 Bond gaining more time yeah gaining
more time and the only way to defend it
now would be to bring White's night out
but the black Rook could swing across
some serious threats along this C file
it's going to be hard to envisage White
clinging onto the extra Pawn here it
feels like black has mobilized just in
time so is there another solution for
Argent does he have to allow black to
improve his pieces with Tempo the
problem is this is also a threat going
for the pawn with the Black Knight
hitting the White Queen in the process
maybe I didn't give Magnus enough credit
maybe he did work it all out and it was
just checking the details now that
you've pointed out the super crucial
threat with Knight B6 maybe it's time to
not trade on C5 but actually develop the
Knight on B12 C3 defend that Bond on A4
fighting against these threats that we
are talking about and Arjun now this is
a bit of a surprise for me when your
pieces are not out you don't move the
same piece over and over again the queen
has been all over the board falls back
once again I have a bad feeling about
this one
and that's the fourth or fifth time he's
moved to White Queen meanwhile these
guys still uh I think they're angry at
the White Queen right now don't forget
to use us but uh how can Magnus take
advantage of this well at least he
stepped away from the fork right Knight
to B6 was hitting that Queen on C4 and
the pawn A4 at the same time now Knight
B6 that only threatens the power on
which can either be defended or pushed
up to the A5 Square so I do think that
origin he is just trying to avoid
Black's easy play and now the onus is
back on Magnus what's your plan are you
really just trying to swap pawns you are
down upon after all so entering an end
game you're always taught that you do
not want to trade pieces when you are
down uh you can trade some of them but
not all of them and I do think that
origin just taking a safe step backwards
he puts the task back in Max's hands and
it's not an easy decision to make yeah
here I'm expecting Magnus either to
start mobilizing his Knight maybe bring
his Rook to a more active Square I'm not
not sure exactly which one uh maybe
trade off the pawns but as you guys
mentioned that only helps whitesnite to
jump into the center lots of questions
for Magnus to answer slightly lower on
the clock yeah at least it might be a
strange move this queen retreat but it
is asking Magnus those questions
and it might be time for Magnus to try
to swing his Rook over to the queen side
as well while the queen is ideally
placed on one file capture the other
file Rook B it comes into mind as an
option for black here just trying to get
more piece activity still waiting for
white to really blink his eye in the
center and capture on C5
yep it is very tense it's still that
type of race but neither side seems
eager to win the race in a way to
develop their pieces to activate uh yeah
I do feel if white gets one more move
Magnus is going to be suffering forever
so he needs to take advantage of the
tempo he needs to create a threat he
needs to go for that white a pawn and at
the moment is now and look at him he's
all leaned into the camera he realizes
what you're saying David that this is a
very critical moment he can't give a lot
of time to White Once the Pieces come
out the initiative is gone
White's next move might just slide the
bishop up to D2 develop it push your a
pawn it's on a protected Square so I
think Magnus senses that the moment is
dire not that he will lose if he makes
an inaccuracy here but it might become
uncomfortable and then hard to defend so
I think that he is thinking about your
night jumps David maybe Knight up into
E4 over to D5 and instead he brings his
Rook to C8 that does prevent the white
knight from developing the C3 tax Elite
but Arjun makes the simple and strong
Bishop D2 I'm liking arjun's winning
chances move by move unless Magnus
proves that he could stop and maybe
capture that pawn on A4 I think that
Arjun will just have all the fun here
yeah really nice classy move there
Bishop D2 preparing to advance his a
pawn controlling squares feels like
magnus's last move it was yes an
improving move but it doesn't
necessarily threatening threaten
anything and yeah I'm inclined to agree
I'm starting to worry for Magnus Carlson
in this game but now with this bishop on
D2 David your idea of jumping forward
with the Knight to E4 hitting that
Bishop becomes even stronger so maybe
it's time to do that bring the knights
into the enemy camp yup black needs to
activate and uh starting with one of the
night jumps looks the most logical and
Tanya it's late in India right now and
we know last season on the tour uh Arjun
he was playing up until the early hours
4 5 a.m even uh do you think that's
going to affect him in this one I can
tell you one thing for these Indian kids
they are night outs they love to play
chess late into the night the worst of
the lot is nehal oh really he is up till
seven in the morning eight in the
morning that's his usual sleep pretty so
it doesn't matter argent's a bit more
discipline I think Prague is perhaps the
most disciplined when it comes to
sleeping hours of course you know you
want to play at a better time and Arjun
spoken about that that sometimes to
adapt to these Champions chess store
playing others he's had to work out at
night so that he can stay up late in the
early in the morning wow wow I wish I
had his drive this energy yeah but
definitely it is something of concern
but for these kids probably not as much
as uh as one would feel it they love
sleeping late and I think that's a
challenge that they've learned to
overcome with time with practice and wow
we've had the idea of night jumping into
anime camp but after a central trade but
I'm wondering because as you were
talking I was calculating a little bit
can white just get a night sacrifice in
there with Knight takes Pawn on E6
because the black king is In Harm's Way
and many of Black's pieces will be
hanging so the queen that we didn't
really love sliding back towards uh the
A2 Square now it might venture into E6
with devastating effect yeah bang night
takes pawn it might be possible here
Magnus surely has calculated this unless
it's just a blind spot we have seen
Magnus from time to time over the last
few moves uh over the last few months
sorry uh make these one move blunders
but surely there must be a counter in
mind just to show Robert's idea after
the pawn recaptures the White Queen
swoops in check and this looks deadly
you're hitting the king but also hitting
two pieces one of these two will drop
off next move so I don't really feel you
can get away with uh with capturing that
white knight but if you don't take it
back your two pawns down how do you
justify that but he doesn't need to
answer the question because Arjun
decides not to go for it very shocking
and I wonder if this was Mutual
Blindness by the two players Magnus
missing 96 and then Archer missing 96
because he just makes the move Rook from
F1 to C1 offering an exchange and this
could be a big Miss by Arjun huge Miss
and it's quite a thematic idea in all
sorts of openings not just here but also
in Sicilians in caricons in French
defenses overnight sacrificing itself on
E6 so I'm shocked that both players
could potentially have missed this one
unless Magnus had some really creative
reply that we're not seeing right now
but Knight takes porn looked like it
might have backed a second pawn and
potentially won the game for Arjun
instead a rook swap maybe he's still got
the advantage I'm expecting uh Magnus to
acquiesce and agree to this exchange but
then what what is the idea how is he
going to regain this past Pawn before
it's too late if the coins disappear
white is most likely going to win this
Pawn will be too strong marching up the
board but sir I'm still shocked you're
shocked because Knight E6 is just a move
that I feel Arjun will at least take a
bit of a tank on and spend a little more
time here but him really just blitzing
out Rook C1 it's a strange decision and
we saw him in his match against alireza
he was so up to these tactics he was on
top of his game he showed
eight a level form there absolute top
form and he needs to come up with that
energy and that precision and 96 can
come back to haunt him to miss this
opportunity
yeah maybe we need our viewers help to
figure out what what was wrong with
Knight takes E6 it's a bit of a mystery
uh yeah I'm not Sherlock Holmes but I
can't figure out why 1966 wasn't just a
strong movement and it could be in a
sense trusting that Magnus wouldn't
blunder it one move tactic so maybe
there was some miraculous defense there
but it did look like white could get
away with it now all of a sudden Black's
pieces are flowing that night hops up to
C5 it attacks the pawn that extra Pawn
that white has in front of the queen and
that can also jump in towards where the
other Knight is and attack the white
king so all of a sudden it feels like
Black's task is much easier I think that
Arjun will be kicking himself maybe he
played a little bit too quickly trying
to use the clock as a weapon but that
was a missed opportunity yeah you can't
trust these top players they might be
very very good but occasionally they do
slip up and you've got to be ready to
pounce when the moments come interesting
game we should mention it's a draw
between Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so in
game two as well they are still tied
after two games
quick draw in that one yeah it looked
like good preparation from Wesley so
just neutralized uh hikaru's advantage
of the white pieces and uh yeah just
very solid draw so very professional
game from those two and what are you
predicting this one Robert draw the
drawer for sure just the way this game
has been going the pieces coming off the
board already this A4 Pawn under attack
it's the only extra piece for white I
think we're gonna see liquidation and a
draw in the near future yeah let's try
maybe and keep this Pawn intact at least
for a move or two for ardrin let's see
what happens if white for example steps
the pawn forward it's under a fire twice
right now so if we Step It Forward maybe
the issue is that the black Bishop can
come and start hitting it now actually
all blacks pieces are working so well
together you've mentioned these nights
uh the knights will dance in toward the
white Camp if you're not careful start
coming in with some threats but yeah
first of all you just go and pick it off
and Arjun first asks the question of
this night uh he steps forward F3 you
never really want to weaken your king
like this the white king is very very
loose but at least you're saying okay
Retreat please and when the Knight steps
back maybe the idea I'm not sure where
the Knight goes but maybe the idea will
be to step forward and at least now you
have the D2 Square to defend this Pawn
with your Bishop
clever with the Knight going back you
can also think about developing your own
Knight to C3 after the bishop comes out
to D2 it's all been about development
here White's been really lacking it
Arjun went for that Bond but I think the
slight in accuracy once again uh when
you're playing against Magnus and you
get these opportunities you just have to
take them because they're not gonna come
again and give Magnus one chance and
he'll be all over the board
so this I think it is the worst is over
for Magnus now F3 it's a long-term
weakness on the king side I won't be
surprised if black decides to drop back
with the Knight to D6 as well instead of
F6 it's a more centralized square and uh
feels like controls the board a little
more at some point it can for example
you can improve your queen to the light
squares on A6 try and bring it into
enemy camp also from the Knight to D6 it
can jump over to C4 so going to be
interesting to see where Magnus decides
to retreat with the Knight he's got
about four minutes Arjun still almost
double double the time on the clock yeah
super Speedy stuff from Arjun era guys
see in this one and what's Magnus
thinking about it seems to be a straight
choice between two Retreat squares
unless he has a surprise up his sleeve
is he really tempted to jump in with the
other Black Knight hit that white Bishop
I would be scared of that piece getting
trapped yeah I think he learned that
lesson from Alexi Serana that if he
drives a jump into his night it will be
trapped in enemy territory so he goes
back after a quite a substantial thing
and now for Arjun it's time to develop
bring the Knight out to C3 I do believe
that Arjun he has the advantage that is
undeniable but I do think that Magnus is
playing this perfectly well he is a stop
that past Pawn before we keep going up
the board and he has pieces in the right
location to prevent his progress but the
clock is what I'm worried about from a
magnus's perspective
yep and the Knight does develop to C3
finally it feels like he's getting
mobilized he's getting motoring Arjun
and uh Magnus unable to restore the
balance at the moment still a pawn down
the longer that continues the greater
aeroglyce's chances will be but uh
Magnus is activating slowly that black
queen now along the diagonal might start
jumping in to some juicy squares can I
drink you control speaking of Juicy
squares it's got to be that D3 Square
you bring in your queen there hitting
that Knight on C3 threatening Queen D1
as well I really like this move and it's
all about peace activity for black in
compensation for that Bond and Magnus is
making sure that he plays with the queen
he plays with the two knights and keeps
the pressure on yeah
while white is distracted defending this
past Pawn actually it's the white king
that has no Defenders around it and this
is a very common pattern that plays at
the top level are very sensitive to uh
what especially once the queen is uh far
away divorced from her own King then
there are often counter-attacking ideas
so in regards he offers a queen exchange
like don't think Magnus will agree to
this one you can't really accept a queen
trade while this Pawn still lives it
will eventually win the game for white
so Magnus will run away but the question
is where
and I like this move because after this
wherever you run away White Queen can
jump on to C4 and from there it guards
the A4 pawn it can also go to B5 once
again offering a queen trade but also
from a much active spot than where it
was earlier so really nice Queen
maneuver by uh Arjun here yeah really
nice and Magnus still on the defensive
I've got to say this last move
especially from Arjun offering the queen
trade with Queen E2 really classy and
Magnus doesn't give white the time to
offer a second Queen trade because he's
attacking this white knight so maybe
Tanya's move to defend this Knight looks
very appropriate although I'm slightly
scared of the landing Queen in with some
back ranker back uh later watch out
watch out David Knight C6 is a huge
threat after the queen lands on C4 true
actually both sides have threats this
would be a nasty Fork hitting the black
queen of course hitting the black Bishop
in tandem so suddenly it's anyone's game
but Arjun with some accuracy looks like
he could turn this group put some more
pressure on ah and should Magnus be
worried about his clock Robert yeah he
definitely should be because now things
are not clear there's no easy path to
trading off pieces or stopping this a
pawn uh just a few moves ago I felt like
it should be a hold and I don't really
think anything's been misplayed I think
origen just playing the Acker moves F3
was a nice fine but I'm kicking the
Black Knight out of the center now after
Queen C4 as both Tony and Dave were
highlighting Knight C6 is a threat the a
pawn is protected uh that sort of
Checkmate on the back rank there are
some funny lines where there's almost a
Checkmate in Black's favor but I just
don't think it's in time so uh this is a
bad moment here for Magnus as he barely
has over three minutes and for Arjun he
has you know almost doubled his time and
with great winning chances yeah maybe
that's why uh earlier Tony you mentioned
the Black Knight going back to F6 it's a
bit stranded over there it wants to be
on the other side of the board helping
out its teammates helping out the other
pieces at least if the Black Knight had
gone to D6 as you mentioned earlier
White's Queen jumps would never be
possible so it's tiny little details
like that that kind of decide results at
the top level but uh yeah suddenly
Magnus hasn't done anything clearly
wrong but somehow it's still Advantage
for Arjun and uh spending his time again
wisely this is is a critical moment if
you let it slip if you play one or two
inaccurate moves the pawn disappears
draw so Arjun might as well invest the
time now five minutes to try and create
some winning chances we're expecting a
queen move you could make an argument
for just defending this White Knight
with a bishop for example but uh he has
to decide soon I think he has to at
least put Magnus under pressure on the
clock because there will come a time
later where you need that extra minute
or two to work things out he's
definitely looking at the alternative of
Bishop to D2 as well and trying to see
if black does get greedy with that pawn
on A4 does he have a strong discovered
attack on that Queen on A5 I don't see
it at first sight and queen C4 or that
nice juicy Square as you call it David
so the queen just looks so attractive
and with the Knight jumping on to C6 I
would be surprised if Arjun chooses
another way to defend this Knight on C3
yeah we should mention between wow he
plays a great move there from Arjun uh I
was about to mention that he actually
has a terrible score against Magnus both
online and over the board losing in
fight Kansai recently in their most
recent uh in the most recent classical
game but he has had one win against
Magnus one individual uh win and that
also came with the white pieces when
Magnus wasn't quite finding accurate
moose so uh something to build on but uh
I see it's not just us who's enjoying
the position
as well what is that we have an owl
watch what
how cool is that you guys an owl
watching very nice truly breaks barriers
yeah it definitely does and owls are
known to be wise right yeah and
nocturnal like chess players at least
the Indian ones the Indian kids it's the
younger place
and uh wow that's a lot of nights in the
center of the board when Knights land in
a pattern like this there's so much
calculation to be done there are some
threats here some traps for both sides
trying to work out quickly what tactics
are happening and Arjun also has to work
that out with only three minutes left
and uh Robert what do we think here can
white get away with jumping in with his
Knight at some point to C6 does he
capture this Knight just to show one
threat the one you don't want to capture
is this one because suddenly whoops back
right Checkmate you need the White Queen
to come back and defend for example here
if black had given a check first there
was a defensive uh resource you can
swoop back with the queen and neutralize
the checks so Arjun he has to be careful
once you see things like this ideas like
this
the fear of God is in you the ghosts of
checkmates they'll always be in the back
of your mind so what is the most
accurate defense he places and I think
he's setting up a brilliant tactic
because after Knight takes Knight on C3
you'd expect an automatic recapture on
the Square but no he wants this Knight
C6 jump hitting the queen on A5 hitting
the bishop on E7 and Knight C3 can be
captured on the next turn don't forget
white has an extra Pawn trades will help
him try to win this end game so that is
what Arjun has in mind and that is bad
news for Magnus as he has dipped below
two minutes on the clock there are
tactics Galore here I think his best
option is to slide his Queen all the way
back to eight in the current position
you protect your knight on D5 and you're
trying to dislodge White's Knight on C3
because as soon as that Knight leaves
the A4 Pawn will drop I believe that
mags has to bring the queen back to
eight but he just doesn't have that much
time to figure out these complications
yeah crucial position uh let's go back
to the players and maybe we can get
stockfish we need a bit of help here it
looks like Robert dropping that Queen
you might be right is that the only move
how big is the margin for error for
Magnus Carlson right now one minute on
the clock and queen A8 is not obvious
it's not an instinctive move it's where
it's the move you can get to by process
of elimination by Deep calculation but
Magnus hasn't played it yet he's Frozen
one minute on the clock this is so much
tension on the board right now just
everything hanging the night jumping to
C6 trying to find a good Square for that
Queen
I'm shaking yeah he needs to play
otherwise Arjun is going to strike back
he looks frustrated mine was then let's
bring up uh stockfish stockfish
suggestions
does he have several options Magnus is
he walking a tightrope here 40 seconds
now calm down and wow Robert you're
completely correct he can minimize limit
the damage by dropping his Queen all the
way back to the corner but very
difficult for a human to spot it does
take time to work that one out anything
else gives white a significant Advantage
not decisive but uh something to play
with 20 seconds are you gonna find it 20
seconds yeah the second option bring the
Knight back to B6 allows white to trade
the Queens that's clearly not what he
wants but Queen A8 there's still so many
pieces of it and he's down to about 10
seconds on the clock and did he lose
connection he needs to make a move seven
five seconds for Magnus Carlsen Gotta
Move Magnus and he finds the best move
wow he drinks that water look at him
he's like I deserve a little refreshment
and he plays Queen eight so the Knight
on D5 is defended and you look at the
best suggestion is White Knight hopping
over to F5 that is too wild but Arjun
has over three minutes remaining he can
find those kind of ideas you see that
says it's about level though so Magnus
he still has a lot of work cut out for
him but Queen 8 was the step in the
right direction yeah especially with 11
seconds on the clock and uh out of those
three suggestions we saw for white all
of them are very tricky for black to
deal with uh so Magnus has questions to
answer Arjun now his job is to just set
a trap at least set a pitfall for Magnus
to fall into and yeah I still think
there's some twists and turns ahead in
this one Arjun doing a great job of
forcing Magnus onto this tightrope and
uh yeah one of those night jumps now for
White's just force Magnus to think don't
give him time to calculate come on Arjun
you can go for it I'm stunned that
Magnus found that move in just seconds
and this is why getting a good position
against Magnus is just half the job done
the guy is so hard to beat even with
seconds on the clock he finds and I'm I
mean queen 8 was a very difficult movie
it's a retreating move and you've got
only seconds on your clock just amazing
stuff there arjun's got a lot of
pleasant choices but he needs to make
sure that he keeps the pressure on the
clock because that's equally important
yeah two minutes enough it feels like
the tension of this game is getting to
both of them and at least in terms of
time consumption here and I'm not sure
which one I would go for Knight F5 once
you see it it's too tempting but uh
seeing it that's the first challenge
he'll find it Well he has great success
he's been able to thrive in the lowest
of time drills he won the junior
speeches championship by beating nihal
sarin who had won in consecutive years
so origin has proven on the biggest of
stages that he can do it but there's no
bigger stage than facing off against
Magnus Carlsen kind of a must-win
situation I feel like he lost game one
it was quite convincing in Max's favor
he really needs to win this game because
the draw he'll still be losing on the
scoreboard you don't want to go into a
Magnus Carlson white game when you're
down a point so this is a big moment for
Arjun I think he needs to play some kind
of move that keeps the pieces on the
board it's huge this is the moment that
he has to strike back in this match he
has to make the most of this position
that he has and Argent taking his time I
have a feeling that he will go for
Knight F5 yeah you don't get many
chances against the world number one you
need to take this chance Arjun everybody
see yeah and if he doesn't take this
chance if this game is to draw Magnus
has a chance to end it in the next game
in three Magnus will have white again so
everything writes on this next few moves
for Arjun under one minute now oh David
he's playing on seconds as well yeah in
this type of situation it will be so
easy to take the kind of solid way out
but here you just have to go for it you
won't get a better chance than this
Arjun will he land a knight in will he
just trade off Knights if the white
apron drops it's going to be a draw so
Stakes are very very high okay he pushes
forward this was one of the top three
moves according to stockfish how tricky
is it though and uh Magnus calculated
this one super quickly gobbling the pawn
immediately this walks into some
discovered checks some double attacks
but Magnus I think he's worked it out
yeah he has because you know there's a
stare down between a bishop and a queen
so when the Knight moves out of the way
those pieces will be looking at each
other so there are attacks look at this
it's like a pre-move Magnus takes that
Knight back his Queen is hang on A5 but
if you take that Queen you lose yours on
C4 and if you take that pawn on D5 you
lose your Bishop that is saying there on
D2 around 10 seconds and you've lost
your time Advantage as well has Arjun
messed us up he could lose this I mean
both sides could lose this now it's a
bullet scramble wow Magnus dropping down
to a few seconds he moves his Queen so
calm but uh the worst is definitely over
he has Consolidated equal material
isolated porn for black in the center
but not easy to attack it for white
and uh both Kings some threats against
them it might be completely equal but
still far from a drop but watch out for
Forks all of a sudden they're Forks if
you move your queen to the B2 Square the
Knight hops to the rim of the board and
it Forks the queen of the bishop so
Arjun he's in big time trouble just like
Magnus it's a bullet scramble it
seriously is and keep moving yeah yeah
very much pre-moves here and Black's
Knight has planted itself on a solid
Square white tonight is on a dream
attacking Outpost could be anyone's game
but the Knight is getting kicked back
risky move there for Magnus opening up
the black king slightly further but oh
this nitrate and now the game will calm
down I think we're headed towards the
draw
wow
we've got to catch our breath that was a
really tense battle but a draw is almost
inevitable now it's four versus four in
terms of Pawns no passports and
everything else being equal the Queens
will also cancel each other out okay so
even with the clock still ticking with
seconds uh left on the clock there
should be a draw yeah not much left to
play for we see checks on the board and
there's just one weakness that black has
which is the D5 Bond and can easily be
defended by the queen and I think it's
just a matter of time that the players
agree for a draw it doesn't matter how
many seconds they have now and I think
we're going to see a repetition right
here yeah the yoyo string Queen slides
the G3 check back to E1 if a Black's
move uh White might be the first to give
these checks but I think that if Maga
slides his King over to H7 we will see
the queen G3 Queen E1 back and forth
there's nothing that white can do but I
guess Arjun gets to land the checks and
force the draw but he's definitely the
one who's disappointed with this result
this was his big chance his big game
against Magnus and you can see it on his
face he kind of bang the table there
almost and uh he does look frustrated a
draw is confirmed and Magnus device wow
that means Magnus Carlsen is still in
the lead winning the first game the
second one is a draw do you think Arjun
is disappointed now uh Robert yeah he
must be kicking himself because he had
the white pieces he was up a pawn he was
doing everything it took to continue his
advantage and then suddenly in the
critical moment he was up three minutes
and yet the advantage dissipated
immediately so even though the result
was never winning for Arjun there's not
that big of an advantage he's probably
upset that he let slip that quickly yeah
and how about Magnus then Tonya do you
think he's feeling
relieved he got away with this or do you
think he's upset that he actually did
get into some trouble here 100 relief
that was a difficult game right out of
the opening for Magnus he showed some
combative defense there but Arjun kept
the pressure on I think it comes down to
that one moment where he pushed the pawn
gave up that Advantage Magnus is happy
with this result he survives it every
white game for Argent guns and he's just
left with one yeah we're seeing some
awesome chests between Magnus Carlson
and Arjun eregaisy and here is today's
Lisa vetta learning point
today's learning point is about not
trusting your opponent don't miss those
tactical opportunities just because you
assume your opponent can't have
blundered and it was here in the game
between Arjun eragisi with white Magnus
Carlson with black that we spotted a bit
of mutual blindness Magnus plotted his
Knight in the center of the board a very
logical move but it did momentarily
allow a bit of a trick Knight takes porn
now was available to White using the
fact the White Queen from afar is about
to land a nasty check if the Knight is
captured White Queen replaces the Knight
checking the black king hitting this
bishop hitting this Knight and one of
these two pieces will drop white will
emerge with two extra pawns and a big
decisive Advantage magnus's plan here
wasn't really clear maybe he would have
moved his Queen up the board but then
why has he given up a second Point white
would happily step back with his Knight
and the pressure would certainly have
been on the world number one to justify
that momentary blindness it did feel
like this was the missed opportunity for
Eric guys he can he turn around the
match now that's the question it doesn't
look like much but neither would a
Sicilian Defense to the untrained eye
this is a performance enhancer you don't
see it how about now manage your air
quality sharpen your performance change
the game with air things
it's all about air things and the air
things monsters and having great air
quality we're going to talk to an expert
on the field but if you're not a
subscriber on Twitch uh here is a twitch
break
[Music]
we're joined now bye Stefan Kuhn he is
an associate professor at Maastricht
University recently done a bunch of
studying on air quality and chess and I
want to start asking you Stefan do you
also play chess
oh uh well I played when I was when I
was a kid but never end down that level
of course so I know she has a bit but
I'm not actively playing chess actually
none of us in our in our study is
playing chess really so why did you
choose to use chess when
uh doing this big study that you
recently have done
well let me yeah I'm a labor Economist
so I'm basically interested in how the
environment and conditions air quality
in particular affects our performance
and we have the problem then you know if
we think about our own productivity as
academics or managers lawyers doctors
whatever
um how do we measure our output and
that's super difficult and so we came up
with chess because with chess we can
always compare the performance of the
player to what the shares engine would
predict and then we get kind of an error
rate that gives us a performance measure
and we can link that the playing you
know performance of the of the player
um to the air quality that the player is
exposed to Aha and sort of the title of
the study is how a chess tournament
exposed the hidden cost of air pollution
can you explain how did you carry out
this study
well we first uh set up um we had a
collaboration with uh a kind of amateur
Club in Cologne in uh in Germany so they
allowed us to monitor their their
tournament so every year they have a
tournament that's the main Tournament of
that chess club and we were allowed to
install sensors indoor senders next to
the players when they were playing so
the monitor their their air quality and
then we link this to the performance of
the players and in effect that is our
our main that was our main study but
then of course we also brought into
whole study and but we did we analyzed
um the all of the bonus Liga so the
first League uh chess league in uh in
Germany all the games that have been
played between 2003 and 2019 uh to also
see whether our results that we you know
um analyzed based on the small chess
club in Cologne also holds for the
universe of games that have been played
all over Germany and we find exactly the
same results and what what is those
results what did you actually find
yeah well uh what we see quite clearly
throughout all the specifications and
all the different tournaments that we
analyzed that if players are exposed to
higher levels of particular meta
pollution
um then they they're playing performance
goes down so that they make more errors
and also larger errors and in particular
and that was was quite nice with the the
chest tournament that we observed and
also the the Bundesliga chefs
tournaments that we observed they have a
Time control so after 1 10 moves they
have to uh sorry they have to make the
first 40 moves within one out of 10
minutes and we see when they approach
this time control uh the effect is
largest so we we concluded that the and
if they make if you make decisions
cognitive decisions under time stress
this uh you know lead to particularly
more errors if they are higher if
there's higher air pollution wow how
interesting
yeah so we found as well and that also
in the end led to the result that we uh
published
um that the results of our study in in a
very good Channel
stuff and it's been so helpful to have
the air things device at home to guide
us with the air quality I am from India
I live in delhi now it's helpful but
also a little depressing because it's
always red the daily air quality is
super famous and I know one of the big
advice when air quality is bad is to
open your windows but I will tell
everyone watching that's a bad idea in
Delhi so Stefan what do you think when
that's not an option to open the window
for fresh air how can how can we
actually improve the indoor air quality
then
but I think there's a short term and a
long-term solution so the short-term
short-term solution of course you can
have error filtration systems within
your house so to keep the windows closed
and try to create your own you know air
quality by by filtering the air that's
kind of a short-term solution the
long-term solution is more on public
policy from our perspective I mean we
are only one piece in the whole puzzle
um in in science and there are these
effects of particular particular meta
pollution is huge so they they harm our
health uh quite clearly to their lead to
more to more mortality they affect our
physical productivity they affect also
now that we show our cognitive
performance so I think that it's time
for Public Policy to act and to to fight
air pollution on a more you know broader
public level either that or I'll just
have to move to Norway yeah do that yeah
I would like that that's that's uh also
a good idea but let me remind you I mean
of course in Daily there are sometimes
you have a level that you even see the
air pollution so that in Europe usually
we never have but we have very uh but we
we run the study in Germany where you
would say from it coming from now daily
that's a very clear environment but even
here we find these significant effects
on our you know on our cognitive
performance
first of all
for us all about this and uh for joining
our show
thank you for the invitation it was a
pleasure pleasure to have you here
wow I guess it's not a huge surprise
that uh air pollution will affect the
brain but it's a little scary right
I'm also glad that I can just uh put the
fact that I'm not a Grand Master on my
back
that's a great excuse I've found now
it's the only reason right it's the only
reason David yeah have you do you have
any experience uh Robert you know
working a lot from home that we're doing
these days uh and playing chess at home
as well sort of sensing how bad air
quality can affect just the brain
capacity yeah but as a commentator I'm
not allowed to open my window because I
live in New York City and there are
Sirens everywhere yeah so anytime even
with my window closed you hear the
ambulances coming by so I don't have an
option so I don't want to know what the
answer is if I should open my window
because my producers they don't let they
should let you open the window oh all
right well well the players have good
air quality they need it because it's
good and quite intense in the air things
monsters these are the results so far
today in the winners semi-finals Magnus
Carlsen is in the lead winning the first
game our generic guys you put on a good
fight in game two but it was a draw and
he has to win either game three or game
four to take this one to Armageddon
Wesley so nicar Nakamura they are still
tied two jewels so far in that matchup
what has that matchup been like is it
intense is it fighting it's high level
chess not the most adventurous games but
both players are very solid they're just
testing each other out there have been
very minimal advantages for each player
in the two games so we'll see what game
three has in store but so far there's
nothing separating those two yeah we're
gonna follow the next uh game from the
start between Magnus and Arjun there
guys the if Magnus wins this game he
will be the winner of the match Arjun
cannot lose this next game they have
played each other a bunch of times on
the Champions Chester over the past two
seasons and it's very one-sided 10 wins
for Magnus Carlson yeah ten to one
indecisive games that is huge and it
looks like Magnus Carlsen is I
regardless he's Kryptonite he's
everyone's Kryptonite let's be honest
but uh yeah everybody needs to get over
that mental block it feels like that
last game some huge chances especially
that uh one opportunity with 1966 but
somehow Eric Icy not able to finish him
off not able to put the finishing
touches on these decent games that he's
playing
but it's going to be a challenge though
first of all he needs to survive this
one with black and missing those
opportunities is exactly what makes that
mental block even deeper in your mind
that when you get a good position you
still are not able to make the most of
it we've got liftoff and an English
opening this time by Magnus uh I'm happy
about that very patriotic uh thanks
Magnus English opening but it will of
course transpose maybe to the Queen's
government decline to a bunch of
different lines depending on what Magnus
is feeling right now and the triangle
system for black uh kind of hybrid
between the slav and the Queen's gamber
declined and okay now the players after
this pawn exchange will head into a
Carlsbad structure Magnus is maybe the
world leading expert on the plans for
both white and black in this type of
setup but the game definitely takes on a
quieter nature after this last couple of
moves Robert do you think Magnus is just
in a peaceful mood here or is he gonna
try and
end the match now it's funny because as
we look at this opening I'm used to
seeing Magnus having the black side of
this position famous games against
Vladimir krumnik and many other top
players but I think that Magnus he
doesn't need to really do much of
anything he's not forced to play for a
result he can just play his moves he's
playing a stable opening and the
pressure is all in origin I we do
acknowledge that origin in game two had
a quite a sizeable Advantage but that
missed tactic that was really the one
major chance to win the game I just feel
like Magnus has nothing to worry about
from the perspective that he is the best
player in the world he is Magnus Carlson
last time I checked so he doesn't need
to take any risk he can just play his
normal stuff
but I like what arjun's done David now
even with the black pieces he is trying
to create an imbalance in the position
or at least asking Magnus does he want
to trade that Bishop for the night very
often that's what ends up creating a
messy middle game so Knight H5 and now
the ball is in magnus's court does he
trade this bishop for the night yeah
Archen is also saying I'm in preparation
you aren't and uh 15 minutes he's
actually gained a few seconds since the
start of the game Arjun this last night
move planting a night on the edge of the
board we've seen it backfire several
times on the tour you only want to put a
knight on the edge if you're 100 sure it
actually achieves something uh but
you're saying to Magnus okay I've looked
at this I've worked out the consequences
of any potential minor peace traits and
uh Magnus now is going in the tank just
to try and find a way to get Arjun out
of that prep and uh yeah a bunch of
moves here we most likely will see white
having to part with the bishop pair but
who's that gonna favor it is a very
locked Pawn structure in the center so
it's not clear here necessarily the
Bishops are superior tonight we had that
debate earlier but let's keep in mind
for this one and this is a super rare
move I've got about seven options that
black has that has been played a couple
of times and Knight H5 doesn't figure
anywhere you could have improved the
Queen's position to B6 hitting that B2
Pawn taking out the other Knight
developed it to D7 uh improved the
position of his King side Bishop
continue to develop it he moves the same
piece twice brings the Knight to the
edge of the board and this is why Magnus
is going into a thing tank because he's
never seen this before it's a new move
by Arjun and you're right it looks like
it's part of his prep yeah just the
breadth of his knowledge Eric I see he's
so young but he knows things about every
different kind of side variation of
every opening it's uh yeah I'm very very
impressed whoever is coaches I want to
learn he impressed viciana in the title
still India events where they were
analyzing a game and but she looks at
him as like are you not done with your
preparation and RJ went like 10 moves
deeper and it has already moved 30. so
it's clear that he knows what he's doing
in a variety of openings we've just seen
that Knight capture the bishop and then
the White Knight captured Black's light
score Bishop so if we take stock of the
current position white with a light
squared Bishop black with a dark Square
bishop and you typically you want to put
pressure in the direction of your pawns
so black has this Pawn chain from B7 C6
D5 we see those three Pawns in a line
there and white has the pawns from F2 to
D4 so black may be trying to make
inroads towards the center of the board
on the king side whereas white May angle
towards the queen sites that Carlsbad
structure oftentimes white tries to push
pawns forward with B4 and B5 when the
time is right yeah I'm having fun with
aristance Robert but essentially those
are the plants uh White often starts a
minority attack later you're actually
playing on the side where you have fewer
pawns whereas black often tries to uh
play on the king side or in the center
and meanwhile Magnus as well going for
just basic strategy here if you have a
light Square Bishop put your pawns on
dot squares so you control both color
complexes and uh yeah just very balanced
so far I don't think Eric IC is upset at
all with the outcome of the opening it
looks like he's achieved a solid base
from here it's going to be very
difficult to outplay the world number
one because Magnus as we mentioned very
experienced in this type of Pawn
structure but uh yeah he survived the
opening no problems at all last time we
checked in an opposite color Bishop
position Arjun had a massive problem so
he definitely needs to make sure he
doesn't allow a big attack on the king's
side very often when there are major
pieces on the board and you've got
Bishops of different colors you have to
watch out for attacking ideas that
Knight on F5 needs to be kicked out at
some point you need to make sure that
white doesn't set up a battery on the
b187 diagonal and starts targeting your
king Arjun cannot go all out in this
game he has to at least try to get a
game four because that's when he'll have
the white pieces he can then throw the
kitchen sink Magnus he needs to make
sure this one doesn't go too wrong yeah
is not the type of position you can just
kind of go all in just burn your Bridges
and throw everything at your opponent
it's very much a maneuvering battle and
about where you put your pieces which
Pawn breaks you can go for later and uh
yeah
technically kind of on paper at least
this should be up magnus's alley let's
see if Arjun after a bit of thought now
can find a way an effective way to place
these pieces he needs to make a decision
does he kick out the night now or does
he improve the position of his other
night maybe get it to F6 I don't see a
great Square for the bishop right now to
be taken out he could potentially also
develop the bishop so what approach is
he going to take will he go for the more
direct G6 that you were pointing out
yeah I don't know what he's hesitating I
would pick that white knight out of my
camp and out of my half of the boat as
quickly as possible and he has
eventually done it meanwhile I was
checking out the air quality here in
Oslo it's like we're okay yeah we're
good are you guys feeling healthy good
and uh yeah Magnus meanwhile retreating
all the way back with his Knight
slightly surprising but uh he's just
looking for fresher pastures does it
seem like magnets who knows that with a
win in this game he's going to win the
match is he going for a win in this
match is it possible to tell by the way
he's playing I think he was caught off
guard so I think right now he's just
trying to right the ship because in the
opening origin played something very
rare and now he just has a stable
position but I do like arjun's position
from the point of view that he sort of
controls some of the pawn breaks that
look at the bishop on the light Square
staring into all of Black's pawns
nothing there the dark Square Bishop for
black and from the King it is slicing
across the board so at some point there
will be tension between the pawns once
the C6 Pawn goes up to C5 so I typically
say the side that controls the pawn
breaks the side of the advantage I feel
like Black's pawns are a little bit more
mobile and especially the queen side
pawns they can start moving forward and
meanwhile Magnus is paused which means
he's about to make a big decision and I
think that's to do with his King is he
going to Castle inside and just initiate
that quieter game with minimal risk or
is he gonna maybe I hesitate to say it
Castle the other way because that's
where Black's Bishop is pointing as
Robert mentions you tend not to want to
Castle on the side where your opponent's
pieces are ready to pounce and I think
black could exploit that by opening
lines I think Magnus as well could just
consider not castling as I say it
I was going to say just leave it as long
as possible play a bit of a waiting game
keep your opponent guessing but he does
commit and uh that's due to the match
situation he's a point up no need for
Unnecessary risks so do you think he
would have gone the other way if he was
down a point in the match it feels a bit
too risky but at least he would have
maybe hesitated or left it as long as
possible you could have made an argument
what I was going to say a bit earlier is
you could throw Harry the H Pawn up the
board especially this fianchetto porn
formation that black has in front of his
king that's often a signal to go and
attack but meanwhile we mentioned
playing on opposite sides of the board
normally white plays on The Queen side
place on the center every guy sees
making a mockery of us this B5 Pawn push
it's strategically extremely risky
Robert
well that's a move that you can't take
back and you could regret depending on
what happens here look at Magnus quickly
replying bring his Rook aiming towards
his backwards Pawn on C6 a pawn chain is
only as strong as this base Pawn there
was a pawn back on B7 just a turn to go
and now the C6 Pawn becomes the base
pawn and it's much easier to Target so I
think that Arjun has been in the
pressure of the match he made a move
like B5 If This Were a tournament game
round one of a long Swiss tournament or
something like that or even a long term
like if I can say it's like yeah I'm
black I'm making a solid effort here
let's just hold the position but I think
he feels like he must play for more but
that could play to Max's benefit and we
see Magnus throwing his H Pawn up the
board so we see Arjun play with Barry
then we see Magnus play with Harry and
that pawn going up to H5 could be
dangerous for black yeah I'd rather be
playing with Harry right now because
white has a clear plan of attack you
step your king forward at some point
maybe you shift your Rook across back to
the H file to attack and uh support the
pawn push over there meanwhile yeah
where are these Pawns going if you ever
step forward with this Pawn the White
Knight actually happily lands on the
edge of the board and potential outposts
for it later and maybe this is what Eric
icy is going to have to go for just to
break out and just completely it explode
the center to open up his Bishop it
takes a bit of risk but uh you want to
activate this piece instead he's keeping
the tension and advancing all of his
pawns it's not clear what that's
achieving it's got to be said but uh
yeah it's at least aesthetically
pleasing that black is throwing pawns
forward so uh yeah very much influenced
by the match situation but not
necessarily that effective
all right this is uh game three between
these two in the winners semi-final
there is another winner semi-final match
going on Wesley so against Hikaru
Nakamura they have played two draws so
far and are tied
what does it look like in game three
I've got to say it looks like deja vu
it's exactly the same opening they had
in game one of the day which was a very
balanced draw maybe Wesley had slightly
the better chances in that game but both
players have come back to the board with
small improvements uh Wesley set up his
pieces in a different way but same port
structure equally tense and uh very
balanced at the moment okay so we should
stay on this game
for now for now yeah at least the other
match is guaranteed to game four Magnus
if he wins this one could end it here
and now
and Magnus thinking after black has
advanced that Bond gained so much space
on the queen side I think what he's
considering right now is does he
continue with Harry the H Pawn is H5 a
move that Magnus is looking at because
that's clearly what he was hinting
towards but another plan that he comes
up with is to first move the king
forward so that the Rook can join into
the attack from the h file just sliding
down to that H1 Square because once the
H file opens that Bishop on D3 and that
Rook on H1 will be eyeing the black king
with big trouble I think for Arjun he
needs to break in the center as soon as
possible he needs to try to get the C5
break in and the only way that's going
to happen David is if he advances the B
Pawn to B4 hit that Knight so that it's
not hanging anymore once the Knight is
out of the way get that C5 break in open
the center yep Kick That Knight away and
uh I'm not sure what the C Pawn is
called Charlie
I used to live in a place called Barry
so I think starting with Barry the B
Pawn is uh the way to go and uh Gary the
seatbon yeah yeah Carrie
that movie is a classic but you don't
want to be on the receiving end so after
C5 the point is the bishop one G7 sees a
new lease on life opening across the
diagonal but we've talked about the
isolated Queen Pawn a number of times
that if there is a trade of D4 for C5 at
some moment the D5 Pawn will be left
behind the good news though is that
Bishop on G7 becomes extremely powerful
and the bishop on D3 still doesn't have
a great home or a great diagonal to work
with so this would lead to it a good
activity for the black pieces and you
have to like that if you're all generic
icy yeah he's hesitating it feels like
you might get another opportunity but
you might as well go for it now and uh
what is forcing him to think step this
Pawn forward I say going this way you
could also go to the edge of the board
and this would result in a couple of
extra trades perhaps after uh Paul takes
porn we'll see a set of knights come off
the board and still the points remain
still this bishop is superior to its
counterpart on this nice long diagonal
yes you've got an isolated Pawn but it's
not the end of the world it's like to
make a move yeah he's about to make a
move he reached out for the mouse and he
makes it he goes with the queen movie
first sidesteps with the queen to E7 so
still keeping this option open of going
B4 to C5 but I'm just wondering if Arjun
is playing just a little 2kg just a
little too cautious yeah now I think he
maybe sees the clock Magnus has been
burning a bit of time a couple of
minutes down there and he says okay I'll
keep the tension uh normally in if
you're in must win situations which Eric
I see is almost in then you just want to
force your opponent to kind of stay in
their own head don't give them forced
decisions don't give them one or two
obvious moves at least uh make them
think on their own two feet and after a
while the White Knight drops back at
least now it's impossible to push carry
because Barry would then be on priest
but I do think this was a little bit
aimless from uh origin here because now
if you do want to push the C Pawn you
have to first push your B Pawn as we're
talking about but as soon as you play B4
it doesn't come with a Tempo the Knight
has already moved out of the way and
anytime you push upon you leave some
squares behind that B5 Pawn is covering
the light squares and the queen that
sits on D1 back at home will venture
into the black camp start attacking some
of the pawns so it's a big moment for
origin I don't think he can afford to
sit and do nothing because White's plan
with H4 to H5 throwing that pawn forward
bring the Rook behind it opening it up
for an attack it seems very clear I
don't see Clarity in Black's position
whatso what's at all whatsoever at all
one of those pick one but either way I
do think that white is about to take
advantage of some squares Left Behind
whoa and Robert he goes for the move
nevertheless and I think we have to
point out the move that you mentioned
there because it looks critical now to
White's trances you have loosened up
some light Square some serious
weaknesses either we can come in with a
bishop maybe attack The Rook or as you
mentioned drop the queen in to this
newly created Outpost and some serious
targets for the White Queen attacking
this Pawn of course uh ganging up
against this Pawn I guess the idea is to
just continue marching down the board
ignoring uh that maybe a pawn will drop
just to create a pawn Mass on the queen
side but uh yeah risky stuff from Arjun
meanwhile Magnus isn't obliged to look
at that side of the board even he could
continue push Harry the H Pawn forward
open that line for the white Rook you're
about to get an open file towards the
black king another
um this is my favorite Pawn structure
I've got to confess I mentioned I love
the bishopath the only thing I love
equally uh as much as the bishop pair is
double death pawns for black and for
white and to play Knight to F4 hoping
for a trade and yes it looked like I was
in my pawns but actually I've opened up
a line for my Rook I've created a nice
Outpost for my knight on E5 supported by
two strong pawns and actually I've
gained extra Pawn cover for the white
king and Magnus goes for this he plays
Knight F4 this is very thematic in lots
of different openings than the Catalan
and queen's gambits in the caricon a
bunch of different openings and uh
Magnus he's hoping for a trade he's also
said to Eric I see yes you can break
with Carrie but you can't do it now I've
prevented you at least one more move
because suddenly this Pawn would be
undefended David the Deep one
it's probably not David but uh but uh
yeah he's making life difficult the
knights are off the board Magnus has my
favorite porn structure but uh will he
be able to turn this in his favor Eric
he finally though has broken out
and how scary is this that Carrie is
advancing
well I was the only break in the
position for black he had to make it and
I think it's all going to be about how
big a Tempo was that queen move for
Arjun should he have stopped this
nitrate on F4 because it just looks like
it's coming but with a little less power
now and white has got this idea of
advancing Harry the H Pawn as we've been
screaming but he can also win a tempo
right now with the e-file open The Rook
can slide over to the open file attack
the queen rookie one and you've still
got to find a good Square for that Queen
because let's say you step over in front
of your Bishop David then the idea of
White's Knight jumping forward becomes a
big threat in the position yeah attack
the queen ask that awkward question to
her and as you mentioned you don't
really want to block your Bishop because
the Knight can step in and the trade
here will allow white a very nice
Advanced pawn and uh A Change Report
structure here for example well maybe
white just winter Pawn but at the very
least you isolate this guy uh David
Again David no mates the isolated Pawn
in the center and uh yeah looking very
good for white I've got to say this move
is almost automatic what else could
Magnus be considering is he just going
to ignore the tension perhaps uh he
could for example just push a pawn I
don't think you want to allow black to
connect for and to continue advancing
it's just very very intense right now
but it feels like momentum is on
magnus's side five minutes though
against nine and a half he's got to
speed up
I register at least doing the right
things breaking up asking questions
he might build attention further with
the move H5 and then it's really all
about who wins the spawn race I have no
doubt that Arjun wants to keep marching
down with that c Pawn try to maybe
create a passer already and meanwhile I
don't see a clear attack on the king
side but things could get out of hand
very quickly on on the open H line yeah
uh Magnus somehow he hates allowing his
opponent long term Trump cards like that
and if he allows the black porn to
advance all end games will be favorable
for black so it feels like Magnus will
want to avoid that certainly that idea
is up his sleeve and it's going to come
soon but maybe he'll take a timeout
first but it's interesting because he
was the one who invited it he brought
his Knight to F4 and after the trade he
doubled his own Pawn so if he didn't
like that he made an interesting
previous move to offer that exchange so
I do think he had oh wow he pushes F
Pawn so he had a double Pawn he doesn't
like the double Pawn but the pressure on
the D4 Square behind it the pawn on B2
that's what led him to leave the pawns
as they were he does not not want to
open up that great Bishop on G7 instead
he's going for the attack in a different
way and here's the big question if black
pushes the pawn forward to C4 that
releases the tension in the center the
bishop can slide back all the way to B1
or even to C2 I'm not sure which is
better but the files remain closed
that's good for the attacking side
because when you're being attacked you
have to open up the center here the
center would be closed yeah and then
Magnus would go in that attack I think
Tanya was completely right that I I'm
surprised I must say that Magnus went
for this decision because now black does
have this long-term advantage of these
two very scary Advanced pawns but he's
not playing for long-term factors he's
playing short term going on the attack
towards the black king note how it's
four versus three on the king side in
terms of Pawns and once we eliminate
this Pawn far less shelter for that
black Monarch so uh yeah very tense some
surprising decision decisions for both
sides especially for Magnus on this last
uh last turn four and a half now against
eight and a half minutes could the clock
play a Factor last time he left it very
late Magnus he went down to his final
few seconds could we see a repeat and
very important for Arjun here to not
pick up that free porn on D4 now it
looks like you're just winning a pawn a
Central Pawn but it's really here you
know you have to focus on as Jovi says
quality over quantity don't pick up that
Bond because once you trade it white
gets a free hand your Bishop on G7 is
blocked white can trade off pick up that
rook and see it and let's just show that
line because it's so instructive to not
get greedy here David oh you pick up
that rook and see it you pick up that
pawn on G6 create a weakness on the king
side and then just go H5 March in and
what is that Bishop on G7 doing it's
absolutely dead the D4 and the D5 pawn
mean nothing at all and this would be a
happy position for Magnus extremely
happy you could even temporarily go down
two pawns but look at the black
structure doubled and isolated pawns
here isolated Pawn isolated pawn and uh
more importantly this bishop on an open
diagonal far superior to its counterpart
whites Knight will just jump in landing
on this night uh this night on F5 where
it will definitely Thrive the White
Queen will join the attack everything is
a white trailer yeah yeah this is beyond
uh Beyond contemplating here you cannot
allow this for arrogacy so greed is not
good in this position as you mentioned
Tanya it would be what you call
compensation uh you know that term is
often vague what does that mean someone
has extra material but they have
competition that would be very clear-cut
that white would just control the
Dynamics of the position so we see
origin thinking here it is a critical
Choice he has been ahead on the clock
his lead on the clock has now been
halved and he's thinking do I take undie
for do I leave the pawn C5 do I push
into C4 not an easy question to answer
because where's the build up what's the
improving move if he slides a rook from
f8 to EA yes that's an open file but
you're not actually accomplishing
anything because why has all of those
squares under his control and let's not
forget that at some point H5 is going to
hit you and you need pieces around your
king so I think that Arjun is doing the
right thing here to really consider and
weigh his options but he's taking too
much time and I'm getting a little
worried on the clock we've seen that
come to haunt him in the last game in a
good position when he was well close to
actually taking the point just not
having enough time to convert that win
and when you're playing against Magnus
you really cannot spend this much time
on a move
and if we didn't know who the players
were if we didn't know the clock which
side would you guys take right now white
or black wow okay I think after f 5
happy to take black right now as long as
I'm not playing Magnuson look at did he
just decide to pick up the pawn on D4
it's exactly what we said not to do
Tanya as soon as you said you'd prefer
the black pieces
[Laughter]
oh my gosh we've seen this exact
variation the Rooks were traded no H5 on
the board no this is a big problem I
mean unless Arjun sees some direct way
to trade pieces off and save his King
the threat is clear just Pawn takes Pawn
on G6 will win white upon and if you
take on H5 we already showed the
variation the White Knight could hop in
uh the black king is exposed so it's a
that was a decision that Arjun I don't
think he made easily I think he kind of
was unhappy with some of his choices
anything that he could have done would
have given Magnus some play on the king
side but this looks very straightforward
for the world champion yeah again it
feels influenced slightly by the match
situation at least where he's grabbing a
pawn he's hoping to survive the oncoming
Onslaught and uh then he might be a
pulling up as black but
will you survive that long it's uh it's
a very very big question and white has
such natural moves it's so difficult to
play especially in speed chess we say
that it's easier to attack than defend
here it's certainly white attacking on
the light squares that color complex is
all his uh magnuses right now White's
Rook is going to slide across to the H
file why tonight is jumping forward as
we said how does black defend you need a
bunch of time to try and even figure out
uh the foundations of a defense here for
black you have to go move by move but
with these opposite color Bishops where
which proved his downfall actually in
the first game today
hard to find any advice for him once
that H bond is down on H5 I will
definitely pick white every day of the
year this is such a difficult position
and the fact that Arjun took so long to
capture that pawn on D4 and then once
again goes into a think tank is not good
news for the Indian fans and I think
Magnus almost looked like he was on
pre-move mode you know when he took on
D4 he immediately snapped up The Rook he
immediately snapped up the G6 spawn blew
out H5 on the board and sure Arjun can
be two pawns up but he's going to be a
king down if he picks up that H5 Pawn
it's going to be suffering and he tries
to plug the horse uh in his King side
with his queen queen F6 holding together
a Pawn on G6 he's defending everything
but a trade only loosens the light
squares I imagine the White Queen coming
in at some point she can try a few
different angles to try and get towards
that black king look at the black King's
diagonals they're all on light squares
and there we go just occupying the open
E file first of all and controlling some
squares there very flexible with the
white Rook White Knight save enough
later just a nice little Queenie too
because it's multi-directional like
black can try to bring that knife
forward to C5 to attack the bishop The
Rook can slide over to pin that Knight
on the C file so the queen slides out of
the Rooks path it makes use of the
default maybe there's an exchange
sacrifice in the works if you take that
Knight with your rook and bring that
blackwork off the last rank there could
be some danger for the black king so
that is not out of the question at all
the G6 Pawn is a target the white king
is perfectly safe and no risk whatsoever
the black king it's exposed and the
white Rook as we're mentioning go to H1
it can slide over to D1 at some point or
C1 or E1 a black has way too much to
look out for yeah still an ugly
structure you might be one point up but
actually this one you wants it out of
the way you want it out of the way of
your queen of Bishop on this uh diagonal
it's just blocking up your own position
clogging up your play and now down on
time for the first time really uh how
much an Eric I see in this game and he's
starting to realize the consequences of
his greed earlier we said greed was not
good and it really has backfired now he
just has to somehow cling on maybe he
just has to put a knight on f8 at some
point the rhyme goes Knight and f8 there
is no mate but the rest of your
opposition might collapse instead he
does go for Knight C5 and now Robert
your move looks extremely strong pinning
that Knight
don't see any downside to that what is
the plan suddenly some awkward tactics
along this file Magnus goes for it
instantly and he's in the flow Madness
yet again uh as soon as that turn in the
position happened he's played every move
instantly you know is that Nakamura
advice that I was giving everyone before
that you need to play good moves quickly
in these kind of time controls and it
might have been the best move but look
at arjun's clock now he's the one down
under three minutes his King is exposed
he did just play Bishop to f8 a very
good move that frees up his Rook on C8
because he defended his Knight but still
the problems persist for our generic I
see even if he's eventually able to take
this bishop on D3 he's left with the
worst minor piece and his King Remains
the problem so I think that Magnus he
can build on his Advantage right now but
he needs to keep a lead on the clock as
well yeah he's still pinned Eric I see
so Magnus has a move or two to create
some threats maybe you can approve the
White Queen the White Knight you want to
look at your pieces and think how can I
cause damage to that black king side but
uh yeah it's all about the clock as well
and Magnus won't want to repeat of that
last game where his uh yeah he was
really suffering on the clock went down
to two or three seconds when he played
that crucial only move yeah
we're the winning this game Magnus
Carlsen will win the match uh our guys
he needs at least a draw to take it to a
game four the other winner semi-final
match Wesley so against Hikaru Nakamura
they have now played three draws they
are still tied it's all going down to
game four if we have a winner in that
game that will be the winner of the
match if it is another draw then we will
see another Armageddon today
meanwhile Magnus playing a bit of a
strange move retreating the white Bishop
it might well just get locked in on that
square if you're not careful you've also
released the blockade of Black's Central
Double D pawns and uh Rook C7 there just
at least putting the Rook on a dark
Square going for that dark Square uh
control unpinning his piece the Black
Knight now might be free to retreat
what do you think some chances of saving
this Pharaoh I see or is it just
long-term suffering that last move by
Arjun makes it so tricky because he's
also threatening to put the Rook on the
open E file surviving that bin hitting
that Queen and then we'll see this
Knight jumping onto the center of the
board so magnesia needs to be careful
it's a little telling that our silicon
friend the eval bar seems to say that
white is fine now generally the bar
loves material right but here despite
being upon down it says that white is
still doing fine but this is tricky
stuff now and Knight to H4 so really
freeing up the path for the queen so
that if black was to threaten on the E
file then white has the option to
actually jump over to G4 and Target that
weak G6 Pawn Yeah White's Queen has been
opened up and uh direct threat against
the pawn next to the black queen on G6
White's Bishop yeah I just love Bishops
a long range piece here poaching from
afar and it's still hard to see any way
that black Will Survive the coming
attack I'm surprised the evaluation bar
is roughly in the middle I've got to say
because it feels so pleasant for white
it's one of these positions where the
evaluation bar does not tell the story
you see it hovering in the middle that
means with objective best play our
generic geissi can hold this game but
look at this there's a knight and a
bishop staring towards he makes the move
G5 and wow that is a huge decision
because he allows that white knight to
hop forward in front of the black queen
take over the light Square so all of the
light squares are whites for the taking
but he is defending he's making sure
he's not giving up that pawn a huge
decision with just over two minutes
remaining for our generic I see I think
the White Queen should step in front of
that pawn pinning it towards the black
king and just trying to bring your
pieces closer to the enemy camp wow and
Robert there is some mad tactics after
G5 Knight F5 that we were mentioning was
so tempting but I think D3 was something
that Magnus didn't like really blocking
that Bishop's defense of the Knight and
the tactics just seem to work out for
black hair and set Magnus going for the
other idea that we were mentioning of
getting that Queen to G4 pinning that
ball so you still can't pick up the H4
Knight as the king is pinned yeah and
next move Magnus can either go back to
try and win this Pawn the last shelter
for the black king or he can jump into
that beautiful Square on F5 now that
it's a bit safer uh black does have this
past Pawn however and he has at least
temporarily locked in this white Bishop
but Magnus Retreats there are threats
including Bishop takes Pawn due to the
fact the Black Knight is pinned cannot
recapture but also swinging across with
the white Rook you could swing over and
start going for the black king right now
it's very very tense Arjun he's still
alive he's still got counter chances uh
while this Pawn is on the board but yeah
definitely from a human point of view so
much easier to play with white yeah
keyword while the phrase while they're
posted on the board White's next move
might be the simple Rook over one square
to go ahead and win the pawn it's not
about this B2 pawn and things like that
that's irrelevant I like the move Rook
D1 just get rid of that pawn the
problems persist in Blast Camp white is
so safe and sound the king Knight and
queen they make sure that everything is
nice and compact nothing is hanging here
I think Rook sliding over to D1 is a
good choice right now just get rid of
the biggest thorn in your side yeah some
point sometimes the simple approach is
the also the strongest one and uh Rook
D1 guaranteed to win the spawn back next
and the black's Position will collapse
long term both sides around one minute
though will Magnus go for this he often
looks for something a bit more
sophisticated which probably isn't on
the docket right now I think you should
just be eliminating that one source
account to play for black both looking
very calm how are they doing inside
right now Robert especially Arjun
aragaisy you're super nervous because
this is one of those games that's about
50 50. like all three results are
possible and so for origin this is his
chance he knows that he doesn't want to
rely on a win in game four with magnets
in time travel he can make the most of
it here yeah
wow taking to one minute now Arjun
aragaisy he cannot lose this game he
needs a win in this one or the next one
to take it to Armageddon
Magnus made a bit of a face we've got to
say just for a second he uh quickly got
rid of all his emotions again but he
just for a moment he looked unhappy with
something I'm not sure whether it's his
last move he played his Pawn forward one
square a bit of a nothing move just a
bit of a cagey cautious one there and it
has given black the time to slide across
with the queen threatening a potential
Queen exchange if the black queen lands
on e4 in the center of the board if the
Queens disappear black should be
relatively safe
with the Kings as they are Black's
King's so weak out in the open a queen
exchange is whatever guys he's dreaming
of right now what needs to stop that
threat it needs to stop the black queen
from coming to E4 because the trade on
that will also solve the bond structure
problem Magnus does it with Rook to E1
and now it just looks like the momentum
is slightly shifting towards archon he
does offer a rook trade the pawn on D3
is still alive very importantly once the
Rooks are traded off let's say you go
rookie seven the bishop takes it off and
Magnus says no trade because that would
make Black's life so much easier let's
say you go Queen D4 black can come in to
to E4 offering that trade and this is
bad news for Magnus Magnus steps back
with the Rook uh to D1 and it just looks
like arjun's done everything right can
he well he can't go Queenie for right
now uh David because the G5 Pawn is
hanging with check or can you the
evaluation bar we see that
he's played it he's gone in Black's
favor the bar here and Magnus maybe not
realizing the strength of this pin yes
you can take a pawn restore the material
balance but after the black Rook blocks
this check suddenly where does your
queen go no attractive squares and uh
maybe you just slide one square across
suddenly there are all sorts of night
jumps and the Knights threatening to
come in with a check uh hitting the king
remember this Pawn in front of it it's
pinned big attack suddenly brewing and
this is the position of the wood yeah
and originally all the best moves Knight
F4 check is a winning threat and you see
the evaluation bar dipping in Arjun
aragice's favor that white king is
suddenly the more exposed one of the two
the bishop on B1 is a bystander not
doing anything and Magnus slides his
King back to G1 so Knight F4 doesn't
come with a fork but it still is a
playable move attacking the Queen the G3
Pawn is pinned and we see that Knight F4
is indeed the best move with a winning
Advantage for black Wow Let's go back to
the game will he find his this move will
he plant his Knight on this powerful
Square it looks like he's gone for
something else no he attacked the queen
with his Rook instead not strong letting
Magnus back in the game perhaps and wow
a quick few moves there the knights have
been traded off but a Checkmate threat
on the board Black's Rook All Blacks
Queen want to jump in to the H1 Square
three seconds margin yeah Checkmate was
threatened but no longer the blackbrook
forced away from the open H file can
Magnus defend maybe survive the worst
playing with seconds Magnus Carlsen is
struggling on the clock yeah six seconds
against eight there's going to be
blunders there's going to be mistakes
they're only human but the Queens are
off the board this is great news for our
generic icy look at that black porn in
the center it's tying down the white
rook and the white Bishop he's
essentially playing up a piece and
Magnus gesturing wow he's gave away the
pond and he's lost he's giving away the
game
arjun's gonna strike back wow what a
turn around this is with the black
pieces David which means he goes into
the final round with white but there's
still work to be done it's not over till
it's over against the world champion but
this game is over because Magnus just
resigned our generator wins and we have
a level match wow
huge original guys he strikes back he
ties the match before the fourth and
final rapid game Magnus Carlsen loses
his first game of the Champions chest or
20 23 season
what is your reaction to that Robert I
don't know how to feel it just happened
it was surprising it was a bullet
scramble and this is Arjun Eric icy at
his best he knows how to play When the
clock is ticking on his final seconds he
kept the Queens on the board offered a
trade at the right moment and he made
Magnus come up with the tough Solutions
and the world champion the number one
player in the world he was unable to so
an earned Victory a career victory for
our generic icy I mean India must be
celebrating 19 year old there you guys
he beats Magnus Carlsen in a crucial
game
how impressed are you with him now Tanya
this is a big moment just the way he did
it was just so impressive uh Kaya the
way he played the last few moves
especially keeping the tension and the
pressure on the board forcing Magnus
into Muddy Waters and that's where he
went wrong it was just impressive start
to finish with this he levels the score
goes into the final game with the white
pieces big moment for India and crazy
stuff going on in that third game what
happened in the under David and it was
all the turnaround we were favoring
White's position we thought that Magnus
had uh everything under control it
looked very good for white but this was
the key move offering a queen trade
sacrificing willingly this black pawn
and after it was captured suddenly it
was black on the attack attacking the
White Queen and as we saw going for the
white king to just to fast forward white
survived Magnus survived to an end game
but uh this one was simply hopeless
these two black pawns too strong the
bishop about to come in and Magnus made
a further mistake and lost it very
quickly self-destructing but well played
to our generic I see getting the win
welcome to Landover a kitten inspired
hexagon resource game for up to four
players
use the feature-rich map Builder to
create unique and creative Maps host or
join custom games where you can play
Live or daily games with friends other
Landover community members or even solo
games against the Landover Bots
choose your initial settlements wisely
and then outweigh your opponents to
expand your Empire
more Villages and cities means more
resources for you to build outward and
upward
use landover's unique trade to build UI
to quickly and easily build whatever you
can afford
race up the culture Tech Tree to gain
additional abilities collect depth cards
and grab the all-powerful Metropolis
don't forget to upgrade your military to
defend against the impending Barbarian
attacks and launch raids against other
players
prove yourself in rated gains to earn
promotions and climb to the top of the
ladder
download Landover for free at
landover.io available on Android iPhone
and browsers
we're gonna head into a quick twitch
break if you're not a subscriber for
everyone else oh we're building up to
the final game in the rapid portion and
the winner of semi-finals
foreign
[Music]
how do you imagine our generously is
feeling now after beating Magnus calls
he's in Cloud number nine and uh well
and also he has to be very careful now
because he can't be too happy because he
still has one game left to play and
Magnus he did look like he was flexing
early on you know it looked like he was
a supreme form but they do say Pride
becomes pride comes before a fall and
there you go there's his full and Magnus
will be raging so Eric I see if he wants
to take it to Armageddon Armageddon he
just has to hold tight yeah but uh if he
wants more then uh go for it yeah why
not yeah they are tied before the fourth
and final rapid game in the winner
semi-final in the other one Wesley saw
and icaro Nakamura three drawers how
will you describe this match up so far
Mind Games these guys are just messing
with each other just mentally because I
have to say still Advantage was because
Wesley of course had that critical first
game where he put Hikaru on the back
foot but these two other games I mean it
just seems like Hikaru was getting
nowhere and the last white encounter
with sorry in Wesley's last white
encounter he didn't really get much
either and Hikaru just managed to
wriggle through now Hikaru has the white
pieces and it's gonna be crunch time now
yeah
wow it's not unlikely that we will see
Armageddon and the winner is semi-finals
but first the fourth and final rapid
games are coming up very shortly
we've got liftoff and an English opening
this time by Magnus oh and Robert he
goes for the move you have loosened up
some light Square some serious
weaknesses he tries to plug the horse in
his King's side with his Queen he makes
the move G5 and wow a huge decision with
just over two minutes remaining for
Argentina guys
what a day in the air things monsters
you guys and these are the results so
far in the winner is semi-finals Magnus
Carlsen won the first one the Arjun Eric
I see striking back in fantastic fashion
and game three they are tied heading
into game four Wesley Seoul and Hikaru
Nakamura also tied three draws game four
is starting in only a few seconds what
do you think David will we see
Armageddon chess in the winter
semifinals yes and uh I think we will
see it in between Wesley so and hikara
Nakamura just because they're both so
good they're canceling each other out
they're playing really high quality
chess right now but uh also this one
depends on our generous approach if he
goes for it he might well have a decent
shot at Magnus especially while Magnus
is recovering from that uh that last
disaster but uh if I Regice he wants to
draw I think Magnus actually would be
happy to just survive this game and take
it to those armageddon's if you if you
were arjun's coach Robert what would you
advise him to heading into this final
game with the white pizzas to find a new
coach
a good one but I do think that he should
play it relatively safe because Arjun
had the white pieces against Magnus
Carlson in tata Steel in her classical
time Patrol Magnus won with black so
there are no guarantees just because
you're the first move advantage that
everything is safe and well you want the
toss-up as the low rated player I think
you want to head to Armageddon you don't
know what the bidding is going to be I
don't even know what color either player
wants but I think that you want to send
this to Armageddon if you're urgent and
guys I think we're about to get an
Armageddon confirmed because uh the game
between Nakamura and so is racing
towards a draw I think it's going to be
confirmed any second now there we go 2-2
that game was a Berlin draw the Infamous
game that's actually we predicted here
on the show yeah
true so if you did follow us from the
get-go today uh David did put up a
little bit of a hint in the studio uh on
the chessboard that we have in in the
studio and you were correct yeah it was
bound to happen these guys have played
the same exact draw plenty of times in
the past and it makes sense for both of
them to conserve energy it's gonna be
come down now to that Armageddon game
and uh who will be faster simply I think
they both want the black pieces it's my
guess they keep drawing right so you
want you don't have to win in that game
incredible so
right now Nakamura and Wesley so we'll
make their bids for the Armageddon and
the player with the lowest bid can
choose colors and will play with that
time usually they will then choose to
play with the black pieces and with the
black pieces you will win the match with
a draw or win the player with the white
pieces has to win but first this game
has to finish so they have to wait for
Magnus Carlsen and Arjun aragaisy to
finish their game if this is a draw
these two as well will head to
Armageddon yeah and this is a very
topical branch of the nimso Indian
defense it's an isolated Queen spawn
that seems to be another theme of the
day keeps cropping up everywhere and
this time it's Eric icy with the
isolated Pawn in the center black has a
nice blockade of blacks Knight on D5
Rock Solid well fortified but a small
threat there from him on the last move
White Queen the white Bishop did create
that battery forcing black to commit on
the king side there are some holes
around the black king especially on the
dark squares Canada guys you take
advantage of that if not then Magnus has
a very solid position
yeah I tend to like these positions from
the black side honestly I love playing
against the isolated Queen pawn and
Magnus himself have this isolated Pawn
structure in tata steel he used it
against Wesley so when he had the white
pieces so we'll see if Arjun is going to
be able to create inroads because you
create some weaknesses on the dark
squares that is clear the black pawns
all on light squares in the king side
but a very likely plan from Magnus
Carlson's point of view is to drop his
Bishop his darkest Bishop back home as
soon as I finish my sense he plays it
and now there are threats with Knight
Forks on the score the bishop just left
so that's why Arjun scoots his Queen
away but I feel like black is very solid
here yeah as soon as black solves the
issue of that problem child the bishop
on C8 the lights go ahead Bishop then uh
I think he'll call the opening a success
but still a couple of moves away for
Magnus Carlson to do that I mean while
white is very flexible the two white
Bishops do Point their Glarus all
towards that King side towards the black
king don't be surprised as well if Harry
the h-born makes another appearance and
uh starts to try and loosen up the black
structure over the that wall of thorns
on the king side still early days of
course and uh Arguments for both sides
who to prefer here
yeah I think Eric I see it's nice to see
him keep some tension playing ambitious
opening not heading towards anything
safe not heading towards the drawer I
think Armageddon it's just a toss-up and
Magnus is super uh experience there
might give him the edge so everybody see
going for the win just developing his
Bishop now Magnus though and I think
that's important for Arjun he's got the
white pieces he needs to try to make the
most of his chances when it comes
without going super rush but I did not
expect to see any quick draws here and I
think you were talking about what you
would do if you were argent's coach I
know arjun's coach is three knot and
definitely he's told him to fight with
the white pieces with Magnus you know
you have to take every single small
opportunity that you get this last move
that Magnus has made Bishop to D7 at
first it looks like wait a second what
about the pawn do you not lose it off
the trades on D5 but notice that Knight
on E2 David if white does pick up Knight
D5 off the trades and you pick up that
pawn the real Garnier it opens up and
you can gobble up tonight so the pawn is
not on pre so definitely a little trap
that Arjun sees I would be surprised
while he does pick up the Knight fixes
the pawn structure in the center and
develops the bishop to E3 now that the
e-file is blocked he has a direct threat
of picking up that D5 Pawn yeah and he
can Target it with his Knight as well he
can go for it with his Bishop so some
pressure for Magnus to try and deal with
in this position how about magnus's
coaches Eric and Amman how do you think
they're advising their student right now
I also saw Ari antario was streaming on
magnus's Twitch channel so I don't know
who's the coach but if you're a Max's
coach you say just get out of this one
head to Armageddon you are the stronger
player so if you get the white pieces in
the arm again use those to your
advantage if you have the black piece
you just need to hold the draw so I feel
like four Magnus just don't take
unnecessary risk in this game and he's
not doing that I think he's following a
strategy of let's just be solid after
that topsy-turvy game three when you
were talking about what Eric and man
might be telling Magnus and he said get
out of this one I thought you were going
to say and head to the bar okay
put on some techno you know yeah
I wish we had sound on the cameras maybe
there is some techno going on in the
chess bra house that's a pretty strong
house right now with area come on Ariane
Magnus just all hanging out yeah
average rating in that house of what
like 20 is 600. they could win the
Olympia with that Squad easily
and uh they're playing in the protest
League big favorites for that one
potentially yeah meanwhile just uh the
game following the plans we mentioned
some serious pressure on black isolated
porn it's mutual weaknesses now the
white d-pawn is protected for now but uh
potentially a Target later blacks
Central Pawn is the one that Magnus has
to take care of I'm expecting him to
just take a kind of sad defensive move
maybe plant the bishop on E6 and hold it
for one move longer but I've got to say
I prefer White's position here minimal
risk as well for Arjun yeah I like it
and even though the center is fixed it
just looks like white is faster to
attack the D5 Pawn yes you've defended
it with one piece but what happens if
white just gets more pressure onto the
D5 Pawn bring that Knight into the game
you can go to F4 you can bring it to C3
stop putting pressure already and it
looks like arjun's strategy of trying to
get a game with the white pieces has
succeeded so far it's definitely paid
off and now Magnus is he forced to keep
retreating for example Knight E7 just to
defend that pawn uh looks like it might
be the only way no Magnus finds it more
creative uh approach he plants his Queen
here saying yes you can win a pawn but
now I will totally wreck your Pawn
structure and uh yes you might be a pawn
up in the near future but you will live
to regret these weaknesses Arjun has
shown tendency to grab Pawns in the past
not just in that last game but uh
throughout the tour throughout his game
so he might be very tempted but I don't
think uh this is something I would
advise no definitely not if you take the
other way with the bishop trip instead
of with the Knight what happens is black
takes back and then there's a rook that
gets planted on d8 so you don't hurt
your Pawn structure but you're not going
to remain upon a head a look at Black's
activity here both Rooks staring down
the center of the board the D4 Pawn will
be captured and that will ensure likely
material equality and maybe some extra
activity for black because of the more
active Rooks Yep this one I don't think
you need to give Magnus that much fun
you can you have a bunch of options
where Magnus is the one on the defense
so uh yeah maybe just bring a rook into
the game just improve this piece which
is doing nothing right now bring it to a
semi-open file maybe just push a pawn so
you don't get checkmated on the back
rank a bit later first he shuffles his
Queen across equally distant but now
maybe Magnus has an idea of jumping back
with the Knight I was going to say that
was necessary anyway but the White Queen
is a target for the night once it
arrives on this Slack
um still in the balance still very level
on the clock as well the standard
strategy though even in the French
defense where you have this kind of Pawn
structure if the white knight ever takes
on E6 you take with the pawn but that's
no longer possible after this move after
Knight takes E6 you have to watch out
because if you take with the pawn in
comes Bishop to G5 you skewer the queen
and the Rook behind it that would win
some material for white so Magnus has to
be a bit careful here I don't think it's
the end of the world if he takes back on
E6 uh with the queen after the Knight
takes the bishop uh so I think that
that's what he's relying on and honestly
we talked about how good the bishop pair
is here the bishop pair doesn't look
that great in fact I would prefer to
have the Knight and Bishop in this
structure yeah this is especially a bad
piece another big Pawn on the board and
uh yeah it looks like Magnus has solved
most of his issues let's see if Arjun
can whip up anything can he be creative
and uh push Magnus off balance
potentially
what do you guys think if it was to go
into the Armageddon who would that favor
more do you think Arjun has better
chance than the Armor getting compared
to the rapid games or do you think
Magnus will just Crush that and and who
would want black we mentioned Wesley in
Hikaru they both probably want the black
pieces draw odds but it's not clear
between these two well I think that all
things considered going into the match
of course RJ wants to get to Armageddon
but I think that Max is the favorite
overall but origen has better chances in
Armageddon than he does in Rapid time
which is just because Magnus is the
stronger player between the two uh art
has been playing a great match I mean
he's been very impressive to be down a
point and then to be pressing in game
two not quite make it work and then it
game three with black to beat Magnus
when it's tactics everywhere he's been
informed these last couple games but
Magnus Carlson I mean he's won how many
world championship titles 15 is that
right too many 15 I think is right yeah
but we did hear him say uh as late as
yesterday that he he feels that he is
slower than he used to be Magnus Carlsen
can we see that or is that just
something he's saying I don't believe
him yeah I think he's just saying it so
that people will start thinking it and
then he'll show everyone who's the boss
so I really think that we should let
Magnus Carlson's moves do the talking to
this point in the air things Masters
yesterday he was just amazing against
Alexi Serrano and we've seen what Alexis
Iran is capable of today as he took down
alireza faruja that was not an easy
matchup on you know look like on paper
higher rating two and a half no big deal
Alexi Serrano is super strong so Magnus
is fantastic I think he's just kind of
letting people think they have a chance
against him but when it comes to the
Whiteboard who's the favorite in the air
things Masters in the Championships or
myself duh what's his answer yeah yeah
he is confident Magnus cross and Arjun
arag I see
with the white pieces in this game I
mean looking at it now do you see
chances for both players to win this
game at first I thought wait a second
White's got his chance here you can come
up with the Rook Kaya here to the
seventh rank after this night retreat
but it doesn't really get you anywhere
does it David a black continues with the
plan to hit that Queen bring on the
Knight to F5 and at the end of
everything you can always challenge that
Rook on the seventh rank bringing your
own Rook to the seventh Rank and
offering a trade so everything's still
under control Kaya and I think draw is a
likely result I'm up for another
Armageddon ah definitely yeah if you
look at the skeleton of the position as
well all things being equal okay Knight
takes Bishop just happened but uh it's
exactly the same Pawn structure you both
have isolated pawns maybe they'll both
disappear a bit later on no chance for
passports on the king side Queen side
everything's symmetrical and uh okay the
first small imbalance of the game Knight
takes Bishops white has the bishop here
but as we mentioned earlier not an
impressive uh set of pieces a night
coming to F5 and very important here
that Magnus does pick up the Knight with
the queen because it would be a huge
blunder to pick it up with the pawn uh
David massive pressure once the bishop
jumps on to G5 hits that Queen Knight on
E7 has been if you fall back to F7 then
The Rook comes to C7 and this would be a
devastating attack on the night and on
the position uh I'm a little surprised
that Magnus is thinking here because
Queen E6 just looks like the only move
what am I missing I don't think you're
missing anything Tanya perhaps he's
considering okay he does play the best
move I was gonna say perhaps he's
considering a counter-attack not an
automatic recapture using his Knight to
attack the White Queen but why bother
calculating this when you have a very
healthy simple straightforward
alternative he does Recapture the Knight
and the threat remains of uh Landing his
Knight in F5 trading off more pieces and
getting closer to that draw so uh still
very balanced I'm not sure who I take to
be honest I think Arjun and Magnus both
equally safe in this position I think
I'd take black I just feel like black is
first of the punch all of a sudden with
Knight F5 about to be played D4 is lose
their back ranked checkmates that white
has to look out for and they're also
immediately threatens to win a pawn
forking the queen and the bishop on E3
so I'm actually a bit nervous here uh
for origin I'm sure they're good with me
Bishop C2 it actually might be the most
prudent let me take that Knight as soon
as it lands there but we've said this
before that in a position with Bishops
of the same color you want the pawns to
be on the opposite color of your Bishop
black spawns on light squares but look
at that Bishop on E3 staring into its
own pawns a bit defensive it's not a bad
position for white but that's a small
little Plus for black I think that is
the easiest path towards the quality for
Arjun because otherwise he might find
himself in some danger yeah so now might
be the moment to pull the brake just uh
heading to reverse gear and go towards
that draw don't entertain chances of
winning anymore it will just backfire
and this is a big threat after all so uh
Arjun thinking this is a critical moment
in this game he doesn't look too excited
about his position I've got to say Arjun
just looking off to the side there maybe
looking at the clock thinking okay I'm
down on time let's just uh neutralize
this one let's move on to the next game
and Armageddon it is just a one game
shootout and uh at the top level in one
in a one-off encounter you can see these
big surprises from time to time in a
long match that's where it's harder to
beat the likes of Magnus so he's done a
great job I think Armageddon uh is now
most likely what is the history of
Armageddon is it something quite new in
the Chess World or has it been around
for a long time came from that movie
Armageddon right
wait he was in that it's been a while
since Ben Affleck Ben Affleck oh that's
true Ben Affleck is actually Tyler is in
that oh yeah it's a good movie yeah
that's a good question
um I guess there's been debates for a
long time how to separate players
especially in knockout formats and I
know back in the days of the World Cup
which was called the world championship
in the late 90s early 2000s that's where
kind of these playoffs became more and
more popular but um it's been around for
a while it's only kind of recently that
no we need it because there's so many
strong players in the world that we need
it more and more often and this bidding
structure I think it was introduced by
Norway chess uh maybe it was somewhere
else originally but uh that one is quite
new that's a new innovation yeah sure do
you think they have started already to
think about the bidding process do you
or do you think actually they headed
into the match with the strategy for
bidding I think Magnus Carl since they
were winning this game because he has a
lead on the clock and the position is
not just completely dead in the water
it's not the one where okay we just make
simple moves and draw so I probably they
have some sort of strategy but I think
Magnus is like very far away from the
mentality of let's go to Armageddon he's
going to try to outplay Arjun in this
position because arjun's pieces are kind
of all over the place right now whereas
the harmony is in Black's Camp I guess
that's what makes him the best in the
world he's just focusing and trying to
win every single game yeah and meanwhile
some tactics on the board that black
Rook on the light square is attacked
White's Bishop on A4 staring down at it
and the White Queen keeping those Rooks
on us the black Rooks can't move for
fear that they will lose defense of each
other meanwhile Magnus does have some
threats against this dark Square Bishop
it's tactics everywhere suddenly I'm
trying to do some quick calculation but
I think I need a bit more time yes and I
expect Arjun Eric icy Magnus both to go
into the tank over the next few moves
there is a cool sequence here that saves
white because Knight takes E3 as we'll
bring up a now sporty it looks like it's
almost crushing because after Knight
takes Bishop Bishop takes Rook on E8
Knight takes Rook on D1 you say oh give
me that other Rook on dude that looks
great give me the material but Queen E1
is not just check it's mate that King
has no Escape squares that would be game
over so that's why you don't take this
Rook on d8 right away you instead throw
in Bishop takes F7 with check
distracting the queen away and once the
queen takes the bishop the White Queen
takes the Rook with check the Knight on
D1 Falls at the end of this variation
and that leaves white way too much
material ahead so this is what origin is
relying on here because Knight takes
Bishop 23 looks very powerful but it
actually would not be as good as it may
initially appear and that's why Magnus
has stopped he's for sure calculated
this whole line he's probably seen
exactly the same moves that Robert has
just there and now he's looking for
Alternatives that's how they play
players calculate they look for the most
direct attempt if it doesn't work then
they backtrack and look for Alternatives
because if Knight takes Bishop was
strong then he could just go for it
instead he has to try and figure out how
to keep this Rook intact and not many
two not too many squares for it I guess
you just have to sidestep that's not
ideal it's a bit of a sad Square bit of
a passive one but you have to protect
your fellow on d8 and still you have
ideas of Knight takes Bishop I think
white has to take a timeout now to
defend against that and the game goes on
White's Queen can't quite go Pawn
hunting yet I think you need to take a
time out to defend your bishop and
you've got a good way to take that time
out because you can jump over to the G5
square with your bishop and hit that
Rook on d8 because notice that pawn on
B7 that you were pointing out David and
I'm just wondering can't Arjun on the
very next move once you save The Rook uh
pick up the B7 Pawn because you never
want to play a rook B8 that is just ugly
very ugly move here black work on a
passive Square suddenly white has ideas
maybe jumping in with the Bishops and
threats just adding up worse comes to
the worst you come here and you take the
Knight and then you say okay at least I
have more active pieces the white
Queen's really nicely placed and still
no risk for Arjun so Magnus may be
looking for something better I'm not
sure if anything better exists other
than just moving this route to safety
you need to step it out of this diagonal
he could also be looking for example at
shifting this Rook across attacking the
White Queen this looks very tempting and
maybe the tactics change if the White
Queen is forced onto a different Square
again you've got to calculate the
implications of Knight takes Bishop but
rather than going down six seven moves
variations let's let Magnus do that and
uh yeah in this position it feels like
Arjun is certainly trying to press maybe
he doesn't believe in his chances in
Armageddon but he is taking significant
risks and move like Bishop A4 you've got
to calculate really really well because
suddenly there are these types of
sequences that require Precision this is
ambitious play by Arjun if he wanted to
bail out then I love that idea of
dropping back with the bishop and trying
to trade the Knight and the bishop and
not allowing this activity that we see
by Magnus but these last few moves have
definitely hinted at Arjun wanting a
game in this one Queen C7 on the board
and big questions big tactics Magnus is
taking his time he's about two and a
half minutes behind on the clock in a
critical moment yeah maybe he is getting
older and slower he's really slowed down
this last game or two maybe the
confidence dented by that last game but
uh yeah it's surprising that he's
thinking so long now because doesn't
seem to be too many decisions if you
can't take that white Bishop you have to
react to the attack on your Rooks right
and so he oh he finally moves The Rook
to C8 so he attacks the queen and just
like earlier if the pawn on B7 is
captured I think it's a slide that Rook
on over again chase the queen behind it
is his Pawn on B2 and the white king is
kind of Airy so there are many ideas for
black to go after that white king
especially if the Knight captures that
bishwan E3 at some moment this is a very
tricky key position of both sides with
their chances but Magnus and Arjun that
they're showing that they're not making
a peaceful draw like in the game between
Wesley so and Hikaru Nakamura they want
to Duke it out here in game four yeah
and uh this is really impressive both
players still continuing taking really
ambitious decisions on every turn I'm
wondering where that Queen goes now
you've got to be a bit careful it feels
like a bit of a dance between the White
Queen and the black Rook wherever she
goes she's gonna get attacked how do you
sidestep how do you evade all of those
threats but
be greedy can we continue porn hunting
that's the acid test of the black idea
I'm not sure we can it's not too many
safe squares there's one two three maybe
or you could offer a queen trade if you
want to play it super safe but uh can
Queen takes Pawn happen I'm a bit scared
of this uh type of skewer hitting the
queen and also hitting the Rook behind
it but we do have this move to try and
offer the trade of Queens this feels
like a safety first approach if you get
the Queens off you should be safe you
should live to fight another day but
Arjun says no no Queen trade yet I'm
continuing to play for the win and still
this threat remains what is magnus's
idea maybe he'll get this Rook out now
with Tempo uh he has given up a pawn
Magnus so he has invested uh some
material into this sequence and White
Once uh once archery moves the queen
will perhaps remain a pawn up at least
remove or two but as Robert says counter
play on B2 counter play on E3 once black
steps with the with the other Rook
attacking the queen I don't see another
Square for white except to go Queen D7
and offer a queen trade but that would
mean that black will have the option to
perhaps pick up the B2 pawn it just
seems like we have so many trades the E3
Bishop will be picked up the queen will
be traded The Rook slowly traded the
pawn will be picked up and eventually
we'll have this rook and opposite color
Bishop end game yeah
I don't know how that's going to end
let's take a look not sure how I think
I've done it the wrong order already but
let's say I flicked in a rip trade first
and everything just disappearing off the
board a moment ago it was so tense and
uh three moves later we have this just a
really simple end game with opposite
color Bishops this one I think we can
say should be a draw with best play but
uh I think I would take black slightly
just because this Rook is so active and
potential weaknesses in the white Camp
uh so Arjun reluctantly seeing it going
for this yeah could we see that whole
sequence happen starting perhaps with a
rook trade uh Magnus just hoovering
everything off the board and a draw the
most likely
yeah it's a big decision here for uh
Magnus because if he missteps right now
it could be like game two where Magnus
gave up a pawn early and then never got
it back until the very end when he was
able to secure a draw so he needs to be
careful I thought he's been playing very
well energetically but he is down
material so I think okay we're seeing
all the pieces swap off it's about that
time uh are there any winning chances I
don't really see it for other side I do
think all the pieces are gonna be
swapped and we're heading towards a
split point
yeah and uh two armageddon's potentially
that'll be exciting super fun
for choice I have to say you know a lot
of people think that Armageddon it seems
like an unfair way to sort of end it we
see so much flagging I love it it is so
much fun and it really comes down to a
different form of the sport you know it
has to you have to keep you have to keep
control over the clock your nerves just
need this different skill set yeah to be
good at Armageddon it's Bill fire and
you need to make a strategy for the
bidding for which color you want to
choose
I would love to hear the players
thoughts when they're making that bid
yeah what's going through their mind and
why they decide on a certain time I'm
always curious what they predict their
opponent is about to be right like if
you bid say 14 minutes is it because you
thought your opponent is going to go
very low and you just want white anyway
or do you think your opponent also is
going to go quite high and so that you
at least have more time to get the black
pieces because uh you know it's a
strategic thing that is hard to figure
out in advance and you never know what
your opponent's thinking I do believe it
changes based on how the four games have
gone and we do know that usually the
white player will have 15 minutes
because the player with the lowest bed
will choose the the black colors how low
can you allow yourself to go
hello can you go I think I think Rishi
answered that question that was Robert
that story he uh bid seven minutes and I
think everyone's 15 against 15 and
everyone's like are you sure you know
the base times 15 he said yes and he
played Pablo pancreatov and punk girls
have crushed him because he just didn't
have time to calculate the position so I
think most people bid around 11 12
minutes uh that's the safety and we saw
that in gukesh and momentov they both
did 12 minutes then 11 45 and 11 minutes
so uh that's the standard I would say
okay yeah
yeah I mean well all of the porns all of
the pieces are disappearing from this
game still some chances while the Rooks
remain on the board but if we do see a
rook trade which might well happen in
the next few turns then this game will
be a draw I mean well we also see Magnus
Carlson's uh air quality stats for the
first time I think this tournament and
uh oh not looking great in the chess Bra
House yeah and the chess Bra House red
CO2 levels it's been a long day he needs
to open a window perhaps air quality is
poor oh it's quite humid there as well
very warm though out in Toronto right
now so Magnus as the day draws on that
could have an effect on his level of
play uh we noticed that in past Seasons
where it uh yeah definitely has direct
consequences
I've noticed in armageddon's Magnus
usually likes to get the black pieces I
remember the first that epic Armageddon
that happened between Magnus and Hikaru
in when it was back with the Magnus
Carlsen Chester and what a match that
was and Magnus eventually went on to win
that with the black pieces and
Armageddon it's gonna be interesting to
see how much he's willing to bargain on
the clock to get the black pieces yeah
and actually is this format almost
unique I know chess.com have done it for
a while but normally armaged interest in
World Cups for example over the board
games it's normally just with blitz
chess five versus four and uh with rapid
chess it's a different strategy right
you have
10 11 minutes if you uh if you choose
black sometimes that feels like enough
time to still play an objectively strong
game and it gives the players the choice
because if you're in an Armageddon where
they just tell you you have six minutes
your opponent has five but that's just
how it goes it's cool to see the players
they take different strategies and well
there's not much strategy left in this
game the pieces have come off the board
opposite colored Bishop in the end game
even though white is up a pawn it
doesn't give good winning chances so I
think we're just seeing the final moves
on this one before we do head to the
bidding and Armageddon
Magnus looks really chilled right now
most of us wouldn't be if we were one
point down against a giant like our
generic icy but uh Magnus knows you just
blockade on the dark squares whites only
past born the extra Pawn on the D file
easy to blockade and uh we'll see a
bunch more uh trades we might even see
the players repeat I don't know how much
longer Eric I will press this
the one thing that I think black needs
to be careful about is not to allow the
two connected past Pawns in the center
it might still be a job why go for that
especially with the air pawns still
alive it can get a little bit tricky so
once white goes for the G4 break exactly
keep that F Pawn on F5 so that white
doesn't get two connected pass bonds
yeah so allow the trade but on your own
terms you need to stop the white Pawn
the white epon joining it's uh it's made
that the d-pawn and everything else is
blockaded yeah we're not hanging around
here Armageddon right
it's getting close you guys we will see
two armageddons uh most probably to
decide the winner is semi-finals two
players will go through to the winners
final and two players will be knocked
down to the losers bracket to play
losers quarterfinals tomorrow
wow yeah I think that after this win
earlier from Magnus Carlsen I just
assumed he'd be there I assumed he'd be
uh in the winter semi-final but wow fair
play to Argentina Regice he does get the
draw in this one and we're there two
Armageddon scouted out the drama
continues this is fantastic news we're
going to see two Armageddon games to
decide the winner is semi-finals Arjun
that Eric icy taking Magnus Carlsen to a
tie break in 10 minutes it's gonna start
they now have a few minutes to make
their bids so Robert what what do you
expect now what will happen
I think that Magnus Carlson he will pick
a lower time than our generator so I
feel pretty confident Max will get the
black pieces in this Armageddon game how
you don't agree
I think that's what Magnus wants but I
think that's exactly what archon wants
as well if he definitely doesn't want to
give Magnus the Jaws that's going to be
super tough so it really just comes down
to the bit it's so important but also to
find that balance that if you do get the
black pieces you don't fall too short on
the clock and then we have another
armaged on as well David Wesley so
against Hikaru Nakamura what do you
think will happen in the bidding process
there I think it's going to be a bidding
war for the black pieces they all start
at 14 minutes 59 then they'll both say
14 minutes 58 and I don't know how low
they'll go but uh it definitely feels
like a draw is the favorite in that one
so whoever gets the black pieces will
start with the advantage all right it
will be revealed very soon what is the
results of the bidding Armageddon is
coming up get ready for the action you
guys
[Music]
thank you
welcome into our new video lecture
series here with the one and only the
14th World Chess Championship
world champion and it's taking longer
than two words there's something wrong
with your adventure there's something
wrong but I believe in when we're
talking the 60s and 70s even the 80s and
90s
you could see that
the match format produced something
unique and I remember there was a funny
moment at the press conference where I
was trying to tone it down
uh not get very excited and also I had
not had time to collect myself in fact I
already wanted to calm down and think of
the next game because I knew this is a
wounded animal there I knew that I had
to play a game against a man who was
desperate for the match to be over so
that he could clinch his title he wanted
a draw at any price I mean you can make
a joke that he had spent a week out of
the swimming pool already so he must
have been exhausted and waiting to
finish the night so for all of us there
was this feeling of
uh we got to grab this chance with both
hands because it's not going to come by
way
[Music]
the great viciana I'm probably cheering
for his fellow Indian Arjun aragaisi
right now getting ready for our Market
on against world number one Magnus
Carlsen right now we're going to take a
quick twitch break for everyone who are
not subscribers for everyone else coming
up very shortly we're gonna reveal the
answer to the puzzle that we had today
foreign
[Music]
But first you won't go wow two
armageddons to decide the winner is
semi-finals this is going to be dramatic
certainly I mean I personally can't wait
to see who will choose the white pieces
because last year on the tour we saw
everyone who chose white one yeah so I
reckon these players are so fast that
it's going to be a big advantage to have
more time on the clock yeah Magnus
Carlsen originator guys here after four
rapid games they are tied two points
each ordinary guys he must be heading
into the Armageddon feeling quite
confident winning a game against Magnus
I think he will be doing his exercise
and just getting pumped because this is
his moment in the Sun and of course if
he wins he goes on to the winners
bracket and Magnus Carlson goes down to
the losers wow and oh gosh I mean who
would have ever thought about that yeah
and Magnus Carlsen in Armageddon no
increment do you think he is less of a
favorite against the origin or bigger
oh you know backness is Magnus you know
I don't think I've seen him lose too
many Armageddon matches
um he's quick he's fast he's got great
instincts and Arjun is quite honestly
gonna struggle there yeah and then we do
have uh Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so
they played Four draws today so
it's like David said you know you could
think that they want to have the black
pieces where with a drawer you win the
match so what will happen in the bidding
process with these two
oh I'm not actually sure whether we will
see Hikaru actually bid to have the
black pieces I think he's so fast he
knows how to draw out the game to Great
length so I'm going to suspect that he's
actually going to put in a high bid and
they have to remember when he faced off
Daniel dubov in the play-ins I mean
Daniel duboff actually bid quite low and
Hikaru just dragged the game on for all
eternity so my prediction is that Hikaru
is going to go for a very conservative
bid all right well no matter what
happens two players will go through to
the winners final tomorrow two players
will be knocked down to the losers
bracket and the loser between Magnus
Carlsen and Arjun aragaisy will face go
cash tomorrow and the loser is
quarterfinals and go cash has been a big
topic for us today he won his match
today on the losers bracket against Mama
Dom
and the young Indian
also has composed a study that we made a
little puzzle from and we're going to
reveal the answer to the puzzle now yeah
he uh he's a genius in every sense of
the word and of course we were following
the end of this study that cash had done
and it was a very complicated study and
a lot of people didn't actually get the
answer right Hey so uh okay shall we
take everyone through yeah the answer
before we reveal today's winner let's do
that we're going to bring up the puzzle
and reveal the answer to this very
sophisticated study composed by go cash
so Ivanka take us through it okay so a
lot of people actually guess that white
should simply go which is good Pawn
hunting grab the rook and uh take that
pawn and unfortunately this would be a
big big mistake because simply it allows
the Knight back into the game the Knight
would jump to the F3 square and older
and some extra Defender so go back to
the original study and that we can see
here that you've got to use the right
time the Knight is offside now is the
perfect time to hunt the king and you do
that with your own King by playing King
to E8 you're closing the net upon the
king and unfortunately there really
isn't that much that black can actually
do black can try to go Pawn Hunt No not
Pawn hunting porn promoting and actually
push the G Pawn one square further and
here is where the magic happens as they
say the Rook will give a check to the
King King has to travel on dark squares
and now this is good technique the white
king will actually follow the black king
but travel on the light squares and
again there's a lovely lovely mating net
being set up and once the black pawn
steps forward again then The Rook comes
to the edge of the board on A6 and look
at that the rook and the bishop are
combining very nicely and mate on A8 is
just unavoidable so Rick comes whatever
mousse and there you go there you see it
incredible it is absolutely incredible
because it's it's just comes from
nowhere that's the thing about this this
whole study and the fact that he
composed it on the age of 15 and also
this is like move 12 along the whole
variation it's just incredible yeah good
cash what uh chess genius the young
teenager is we did announce we will pick
a winner someone who has given the right
answer to this puzzle and it's Gustav
correctly guessing King E8 because Black
Knight is trapped and black cannot
defend Checkmate very nice answer and he
will get an air things
and it's even better because it's been
signed by Magnus Carlson so it's a very
very special prize congratulations to
Gustav Magnus Carlsen is right now
getting ready for Armageddon coming up
in a few minutes
it's a very topical branch of the nimzo
Indian defense
decision here
for Magnus looks really chilled right
now most of us wouldn't be if we were
one point down against a giant like our
generic icy fair play to Argent arrogate
he does get the draw in this one and
we're there two Armageddon scouted out
still no vids ask how many you guys and
only minutes until the Armageddon is
starting what are the players doing
each other guessing uh it's that
psychological warfare of the bidding war
yeah
all right well we are waiting now for
the bids Robert can you remind us again
the regulations for the armageddo for
sure so 15 minutes will be the base time
you cannot bid above that the side that
chooses the lower amount of time let's
say you choose 10 minutes I choose nine
minutes I get to choose my color you
will get 15 minutes and if I choose nine
minutes I will likely choose the black
pieces and if we draw our game I move on
sorry to say Kyle that is yeah I likely
would again
those are the regulations
we're very curious will the players what
will they Bend who will get the white
pieces who will get the black pieces
both matches here in the winter
semi-finals have gone to the Armageddon
Magnus Crossing against sergeant
aragaisy and Hikaru Nakamura against
Wesley so we are waiting now
impatiently for the bids and in the
match between Wesley Sony car and
Nakamura you have predicted that they
both really want the black Pieces Just
judging by the flow of the previous
games there's been nothing in it really
whoever had the black pieces was Rock
Solid and found really convincing ways
to defend and uh yeah opening wise as
well they have bulletproof repertoires
so I feel that yeah black is a
significant uh Advantage here for
whoever gets those pieces and we have a
bid coming in here we have it Wesley so
has been 9 minutes and 44 seconds Hikaru
Nakamura 9 minutes and 28 seconds I mean
Hikaru Nakamura could choose colors
obviously he has chosen the black pieces
he will play with 9 minutes and 28
seconds Wesley's over the white pieces
will have 15 minutes you're saying wow
Tanya
wins the bid by 16 seconds
unbelievable so he gets to choose the
black color and gets the result or he
will most likely pick that because
that's the Armageddon strategy that
we've seen and you know we've got these
two armor Gardens coming up but what's
really striking to me is how different
the two matches have been Wesley and a
car we just look like the approach for
these two players from the very start
was to get to this point yeah incredible
we have the other bed as well in the
other match up let's see
Arjun airgasi he's been 11 minutes and
59 seconds Magnus Carlson bidding 10
minutes and one second that's
very close and Magnus winning the bid
has chosen to play with the black pieces
you will have 10 minutes and one second
versus Arjun aragaisy with the white
pieces having 15 minutes what do you
think of that bed uh David well I think
we better strap in because it's
definitely going to come down to a race
on the clock later for the place with
the white pieces they're going to have a
huge clock Advantage from the get-go and
uh yeah they'll be needed uh they'll
need to be quick on the mouse almost
five minutes Advantage for archon and
about six minutes for Wesley and we saw
Magnus and Arjun in that photograph I
think both of them are pleased yeah
Arjun gets a five minute Advantage
Magnus gets the pieces that he wants and
it's um yeah John has to win on demand
not an easy task and in the other one
Hikaru with a little over nine minutes
on the clock you said you should have
around 11 minutes is this danger for
Hikaru Nakamura well for any mere mortal
11 minutes sounds good hikaran Nakamura
has not proven to be mortal I don't
think anyone's checked his blood
pressure recently he is just amazing at
bullet chess he moves so quickly but for
Wesley so he is as solid as they come he
needs a stop that right here he needs to
play an opening that challenges Hikaru
does not allow him to go forcing
variations and use the Croc as a weapon
I think Wesley can do that he is the
chess.com Global champion from a year
ago he beat ikar Nakamura not an
Armageddon but in the match he's shown
he's capable of doing so I think Wesley
will have to go for an opening the
Hikaru can't possibly expect and I think
for Hikaru this is a big grudge match
exactly because of that he wants to get
his revenge yeah
and it'll be refreshing to see Wesley
kind of let loose and just go for his
opponent go all out for the win it's
very rare that we see Wesley take risks
we know he's capable he's so talented
his instincts are so good but wow it's
deja vu yet again it's a repeat of game
one and game three of the match it's the
Italian game where we see this become a
very quiet maneuvering battle has Wesley
come with some surprises up his sleeve
he hasn't got anywhere he hasn't made
any ground uh in terms of an opening
advantage in those previous two battles
but here he needs something a bit
different look at this we're already on
move eight nine and and Hikaru has
played every move almost instantly but
once there's more time it started with
so I don't believe armor again has
increment so that's true uh that these
games might have to be restarted oh
might be an abort that because yeah and
we see a guy would throw his hands in
the air he's like what is happening
technical issues that there's not
supposed to be increments and you know
very often this disturbs Hikaru a lot he
said about how much he hates being
Disturbed once the game is on he's not a
happy guy right now and also just gave
away what his plan was because if Wesley
repeats this opening all of a sudden now
his car is think uh should I go for the
same exact plan or will I have to mix it
up because now Wesley knows what to
expect oh this is a crush says he car
Nakamura now with a smile on his face
but shaking his head yeah this is a
disaster this is exactly what you don't
want in an Armageddon and Robert the
point that you brought up that the
opening is gone what you had up your
sleeve your opponent knows now and look
at both these pairs they're absolutely
stunned what do they do now just shift
switch shop openings yeah it looks like
Wesley was reading a computer screen
maybe he's prepping this line now that
he knows what Hikaru is going to do
um I wonder if there's a restart in the
other game it looked like both games
started with the Italian opening but no
we're off again and the clock times will
be corrected I hope there we go Hikaru
down nine and a half minutes to play
this game and it's a race to the Finish
sudden death now uh no increment and
Wesley changes it up no more Italian
game oh my God yeah Hikaru is not going
to be happy about this and this is
exactly what happened in his playoff in
the Swiss qualifiers as well when he was
playing against Daniel DuBois and I
think he had the same situation where
eventually they had to restart the match
and it was an absolute disaster and
Hikaru mentioned that in his interview
later
yeah and meanwhile strange strategy here
from Wesley so to change things up it
feels like you might as well just repeat
the same moves get back to the same
position and you both fight from the
same uh kind of the same level playing
field but okay he's gone towards the
Berlin and a very closed locked up
situation here and looked up Pawn
structure black has double pawns but has
the bishop pair that's compensation the
reason I'm surprised is that Hikaru
Nakamura he has a reputation of being
the expert in this type of structure to
both colors do you think this is a bit
of a dirty play by Wesley to change up
the opening once it's been revealed it's
just so awkward for the players no yeah
yeah I mean but you just have to they're
professionals they've had to deal with
all sorts of circumstances it's LED them
to be the best of the game and uh
they're playing a normal opening right
now so I think that for Wesley he's
using his time uh Hikaru moving very
quickly to start as David said he is the
leading expert perhaps in the black side
of these exchange Spanish and what we
see is black has these double pawns over
there on the C file a white Pawn
structure uncompromised it's in perfect
order but black has the pair of Bishops
and he'll try to use that to his
advantage and Hikaru he often keeps his
opponents which side he's uh kind of he
keeps his opponents guessing which side
is he gonna Castle we do see that the
pair of Bishops is gone white spent a
couple of moves uh trading off Black's
light Squad Bishop normally a very
strong piece but the remainder of the
pieces blacks pieces here they look very
well placed in offering a queen trade
he's bullying Wesley now with a thought
of a drawish type of end game and uh
Wesley in a must win situation I would
be surprised if we see the Queens come
off there we go he Retreats you just
can't take the Queens off and uh allow
Hikaru to lock that up with the draw
very easy play for black if the Queens
disappear at least now a bit of
maneuvering and uh yeah Hikaru playing
super fast still a five minute
difference between the two players
though or four and a half minute
difference will that come in handy later
for Wesley the white nice is on a nice
Square now sorry very nice Square as you
were pointing out because it also wants
to find itself to land on the F5 square
at an opportune moment and very
important for Wesley to keep all the
pieces on the board as many as he can to
keep the pressure going to low on the
clock this is an Armageddon there's no
increment flagging your opponent is a
huge part of the game strategy here no
shame in that whatsoever and Hikaru
going all out here he pushes Harry the H
Pawn forcing White's Queen to fall all
the way back to its original Square yeah
not good news necessarily for Wesley so
but wow Hikaru in a situation where he
only needs a draw he's pushing all his
pawns forward it's like you said earlier
Robert uh your baseboard now is a bit
weak pawns don't move backwards some
holes in the black Camp uh what do we
think of this one where's the black king
gonna go most likely it's gonna go long
to the queen side now and the problem
for why is there no Pawn breaks that's
why he pushed the pawn up to G5 he took
away control of the F4 square look at
Black's pawns and Bishop covering all
the important dark squares so all he
pawns on the board the Rooks are not
doing anything all of Black's pawns
protected I like what Hikaru has done
here he is playing an excellent game
thus far and as Wesley you need a win
therefore you have to open up lines you
have to open up with those Pawn breaks
and he prepares that with C3 getting
ready to push his Central Pawn but David
when you have to win a game this is
exactly the kind of position that you
won with Wesley has to win on demand
this is a position where you're playing
for all results where draw is the least
likely he's aiming and he's dreaming to
get that Central break-in but Hikaru
stops it to me the way hikaru's played
the last few moves it looks like he's
channeling his anger about what happened
to the start of the game into the
position
now he's doing a great job gotta say I
like what he's done he's actually kept
his King very flexible in the center if
the black king had gone to the queen
side there would have been levers there
would have been ways to open up lines
for uh the white pieces but now he's
advancing slowly towards the white king
not necessarily uh leading up to an
attack but at least putting that fear
into Wesley and uh as well in a muscle
in situation you have to burn time on
the clock here the onus is on Wesley you
are the one trying to find those ideas
trying to create something and at some
point Wesley will slow down my biggest
question is where is this style of game
every other time they play each other
like they're so solid they essentially
are kind of holding back a little bit
and now when a draw does not suffice for
Wesley he shows that he can make the
game interesting from the very start
black has finally Castle kingside this
game reminds me of the one from the
candidates between five and a carwana
and Hikaru Nakamura five on a one night
game with the white pieces because
eventually he opened up the position and
here that is exactly what Wesley needs
to do I think he is going to take this
bishop we just saw that the Knight Will
recapture and then d-pawn pushes forward
finally the position opens up that's
good news for the Rooks that have been
sitting idly in this position and now
all of a sudden it's full steam ahead
West is going for just that this is
getting into dangerous territory for
hikaru's King which looks okay for the
moment but watch out keep an eye on him
yeah that beautiful Pawn white uh porn
center right now I can barely talk it so
quick but uh yeah that beautiful Pawn
Center for white so flexible a threat on
that D4 Pawn right now you can step it
forward you can step the e-pawn forward
you can just hold things together with
the White Queen a bunch of choices for
Wesley technically in uh Armageddon you
should try and keep the tension as long
as possible that's what they advise at
least but if you spot an opportunity go
for it and force Sakura to calculate
he's still got more than seven and a
half minutes though this should be
enough still in the balance despite
white structure looking really nice and
healthy right now and uh who would you
pick here Tanya Robert oh my God like
neither I do not want to be in that
situation in an Armageddon look at the
position David the D4 Pawn is hanging it
just feels like black is the one who's
putting the pressure asking the
questions here Wesley needs to answer if
he pushes that pawn black snide
eventually after the trades can find
itself on a really nice Square on F4 uh
it is looking dangerous for both sides
but this is Armageddon and that's
exactly what happens yep and Wesley
keeps the tension not stepping forward
with either of his pawns yet keeping
hikar regressing very wise I feel and
now it's pressure on black how do you
unravel how do you keep the black king
safe while uh finding better squares for
your pieces I think it was smart not to
initiate the trades because that gives
Hikaru some easier moves and easier
plans now with seven pounds remain
preside we see hikara step forward with
his own pawn and Wesley can do the same
he does not want to just trade push your
Pawn for a D5 keep the position closed
uh you have connected pawns your knight
can reroute from its Outpost on C4 I
would love to go and venture over to the
king side and cause the black king some
harm so that night would love to
eventually get to the F5 Square I think
Pond pushed D5 is absolutely necessary
right now for West you cannot just trade
that gives hikar way too easy of the
next series of moves yeah and big
question if the Black Knight does land
in the center at some point do you
consider taking this Beast off the board
maybe this Knight is worth a rook and
you do get a pawn in return you are left
with this Rock Solid Center for white
and uh if you had time now to just play
one more move you'd have maximum control
as Robert mentions and not an F5 here
and black will not survive but uh does
Wesley have that luxury and I think you
should start with this one uh pushing
the pawn forward and later try to
re-route the White Knight
Hikaru looking pretty relaxed and the
time Advantage is disappearing less than
two minutes between them now he's played
so Speedy Hikaru and that's the dream
scenario for Hikaru right if he's able
to get wrestling down to the same amount
of time as he has and then he's got the
result odds also this could be big
disaster and Wesley trades on C5 that's
a shocking decision just allowing black
to solve the pawn structure problem as
well as the Knight gets so much activity
yeah suddenly this Black Knight stares
down at some really weak points if you
ever move your knight out the way now
then the black queen will be ready to
swoop and pick off these weaknesses and
look at what hikara has done he's
throwing a thorn into the white side
this black H Pawn if you capture it your
structure is ruined the white king is
going to be weak forever if you bypass
this pawn and step forward then there
will always be checkmating ideas against
this King thanks to this Pawn Hikaru
he's using all of his experience here
and it feels like Wesley
he's let it slip no Advantage for white
at all and remember Wesley has to win
this game with the white pieces any
other result means Hikaru Nakamura goes
through to the winners final in the
other one we have Armageddon between
Magnus Carlsen and Arjun aragaisy as
well there were no technical issues in
that game as far as I know so these two
are playing Arjun aragaisy with the
white pieces Magnus Carlson is playing
with the black pieces
happening in that one I'm just looking
over Magnus is a pawn up I don't see too
much compensation for eriggaity but
still complex in that one I think
magnus's uh big favorite now the biggest
problem from Magnus he's down four
minutes but he sells five and a half
minutes remaining for himself he's doing
very well he's in control over the board
and the clock manager is there all right
and you guys shout out if we should go
over to that board it seems like there
is a lot of drama on this board though
yeah potentially and wow Wesley just
bypasses this Pawn I'm shocked I've got
to admit okay we see the bar react
because now look at the white king it's
caged there's going to be all sorts of
mating threats against it and it has to
take a time out to step back towards the
center I would be terrified of the black
queen the Black Knight combining as a
fierce endure against that King later on
and what you want to really do is get
that Queen working with that age Pawn
you want to Target that E4 Pawn well who
is the defender the pawn on F3 get rid
of that push that jeep on all the way
down to G4 attack the defender Hikaru
finds another way to get the queen into
the mating action he wants to open up
the e-file if Wesley picks up that F5
Bond at some point that Queen will drop
down to E2 threatening a deadly mid on
G2 yeah let's just show that because
that would be a huge mistake now uh
capturing this Pawn would allow the
black queen in and uh black would win
yep simply this is going to end in
Checkmate some huge material losses I
think for white if you want to prevent
this so uh okay maybe Wesley has
something else up his sleeve you could
try and attack this Pawn which is
temporarily temporarily loose uh you
could slide your queen across to
threaten it but black then I think would
be very happy to continue stepping
forward and opening up lines yes you're
opening up the black king but here the
white king is a big Target as well and
black species have more control over the
center therefore switching over to the
king side shouldn't be too much of an
issue time Advantage completely gone wow
ah looking very good for Karu that anger
has really driven him in this one yeah
and you see it on his face right his
body language is like all right I got
this one look I can lean back a little
bit but her car is playing a perfect
Armageddon game from the start it was
great opening preparation a type of
position that he thrives in he is one of
the world's leading experts he has so
much experience and now it's an open
position the white king in worst shape
than black oh and plus it did take on F5
and queen E2 we were just talking about
that maybe there's Rook D2 that saves
the day but we're starting to trade
pieces off Wesley so needs to win the
game there are no winning chances that I
see in an end game yeah here if you just
want to draw a Sakara you just trade off
the Rooks uh the White Queen has to
defend you trade off the queens and then
you just pick up this Pawn it's level
material if anyone's better here it's
black these pawns are extremely weak
clear path for the black Rook towards
these pawns and uh wow I think he's
gonna take the win in this one and uh
okay Wesley defending with his Knight
Instead This is hanging by a thread for
white yeah but you can just attack the
Knight the e-file is open bring your
your Rook on that file hit that night
the defender of that G2 mating attack
this is getting worse and worse for
Wesley but I don't think he had the
option to trade the queens and go into
that end game which is just suffering
for white and playing for two results
this has gone all wrong on the camera
he's like a hunter he's focused in on
his prey now he's trying to get climb
into the computer screen he knows that
the win is near and he Bobs his head
he's going for that white knight that
final Defender if he eliminates it just
make my company there's a brilliant
tactic here I mean if we just can bring
up a variation it looks like white can
save that Knight with sliding The Rook
over from D1 to E1 the problem is that
the BlackRock will still take the Knight
the queen can take the Rook you gain
some material right no you get checkmate
on the G2 Square that's game over so it
looks like Wesley so is losing material
in this position unless he trades the
queens and if he trades the Queens the
queen C4 check he's not going to be up
any material it's going to an end game
where black actually will be ahead F5
will drop B3 is in trouble rookie two is
coming now west has no winning chances
here yeah black is the one playing for
the win if anything and you can see on
the body language now Wesley he is not
enjoying his position at all and let's
go back to the players Hikaru so focused
up on the clock up on the position
yeah just a Master Class
the only good news for Wesley is that
this is not happening over the board so
he doesn't get to see Hikaru like this
right across because that can be so
intimidating look at hikaru's body
language you've been talking about it
he's going back and forth and he knows
he's got this in his hands he was
furious at the start of the game and
with the black pieces this has been
crushing actually yeah and it's also an
end game between eragasi and Carlson
where Magnus has a big Advantage so you
might come down to the clock there with
Eric icy can flag Magnus uh looking
unlikely at this moment but it looks
like having the black pieces in the arm
again big Advantage yeah
and you guys call out if you think we
should shift the boards it's looking so
good for Hikaru Nakamura
and now all he needs to do move the Rook
to a safe Square there we go retreats
think Wesley has to start a
counter-attack maybe bring the white
Rook on the open file there we go up the
board I up some of those weak black
pawns you do have the three versus two
advantage on the king side if you can
hit some of those pawns win some of
those pawns at least there'll be some
imbalance so uh not just that day
there's also an idea to pick up the A5
Pawn watch out for that you defend G5
with your Rook with your move Rook G7 I
think it's on the board can white
actually go for this tactic of picking
up the A5 Pawn you sacrifice your knight
but then black snide is hanging on C5
yeah I think you have to go for this
otherwise you might just be suffering in
an end game due to the weakness of this
pawn and Knight takes Pawn to show it
has happened it has landed on the board
if this Knight was captured uh then the
Black Knight drops you called it Tanya
but Hikaru ignores it he activates his
rook and he's so active right now still
some devastating threats against the
white king uh if the white King's forced
into the corner then there will always
be tricks White Knight moves and now I
would want to give a check I'm not sure
whether you need to rush but also this
Pawn is undefended suddenly feels like
black still has has this one under
control black is doing very well but for
Wesley this is the best that he's had
all game the objective evaluation is
good for black but now he's some chances
look at those black pawns on H3 and G5
they're going to be needing those Rooks
defending them but the problem is the
white king can't get into the action if
that King could just jump up to G3
somehow Through The Rook then you're in
good shape but you can never cross the
second rank that Rook on E2 can slide
two squares over in front of the white
King deliver it a check so yeah the king
is not escaping up the board and that
means that black is everything under
control and white needs to watch out for
a threat like Knight D2 at the right
time at an opportune moment because he
still might have the resource to jump
back with his own Knight to D4 in
response to that but definitely if
Black's Knight can join the rook and
pawn into the attack it will be bad news
for Wesley's King wow and he's advancing
his Pawn forward this is not going to
help him win though at the very least
you just trade off this pawn and every
set of Trades that happens black gets
closer to the win Hikaru looks away
maybe he's thinking of something else
else maybe the Black Knight could have
jumped in as Tanya mentioned anyway but
he does eliminate all danger and he's a
minute up on the clock very best Wesley
can hope for is to trade off all the
pieces but actually a night capture
would allow the Black Knight to jump in
decisively this one looks over almost at
least in terms of winning chances for
white just want to give a quick shout
because Magnus Carlson looks like he is
about to at least draw his game in the
near future so it looks like Magnus and
Hikaru in the driver's seat that would
mean a clash between them I believe
that's what everyone typically is
waiting for in these types of events
already on day three in the air things
monster is on the 2023 season clash
between a car and Magnus incredible wow
I think we're about to see a draw here
White's Rook steps up if Hikaru wants he
just gives a check and repeats the
position and dance between the Rooks and
you look at him and you know that's
going to happen he he's not gonna he's
not gonna push this one he might even
know that he's better but he's just
going to give a check Force whites Rook
to come back and then go drop backwards
yeah oh wow it's over Wesley so with a
draw in this game Wesley is knocked down
to the loser's bracket Hikaru Nakamura
makes it through to the winners final
that will be played tomorrow he's gonna
face either Magnus Carlsen or Arjun
aragaisy let's jump into that Armageddon
game Magnus Crossing with the black
pieces only needs a draw in this game
Arjun has to win it what's happening and
it's definitely not going to be Arjun
unfortunately he's pulling down in a
rook end game Magnus has three minutes
no chance really of flagging him here
despite the lack of increment and I
think the players have agreed to a draw
Magnus is through it's confirmed that
means ladies and gentlemen on day three
of the air things Masters we will see a
Winner's final between Magnus Carlsen
and Hikaru Nakamura we couldn't have
asked for a better Winner's final
completely unexpected Magnus Carlson
versus thought but the good news is for
the fans of origin erige and Wesley so
their term is not done the double
elimination format leaves them in the
thick of things and so of course our
eyes will be on Magnus and Hikaru the
beasts of online chess but Wesley so and
Arjun they still have their chances yeah
and uh Arjun what if it gave it today
winning a game against Magnus as well
just amazing stuff and coming back in
that third game with the black pieces
the way he played I think there is a lot
of positive to take away from it and he
knows he has one more shot he has one
more life left in this tournament he's
definitely gonna make the most of it and
I think that win gives him a lot of
confidence going forward yeah
Tanya it's good cash against every guy
okay do you know how commentators are
supposed to be not biased that's my
Approach for tomorrow yeah yeah and
David we got Armageddon chess today
what's your reaction what was it like uh
it was exciting unfortunately just for
the players with the white pieces Eric I
see and Wesley so they never got going
it's just a master class in terms of
control from hikaranakamura and Magnus
Carlson not taking risks controlling
things uh keeping the clock under
um yeah under watchful gaze as well and
yeah in the end it was just deserved
results for those two have we learned
anything in terms of bidding Robert what
seems to be a good strategy it shows
that Hikaru and Magnus they can go to
that nine and a half ten minute range
but we saw how close it was between
Wesley and nicaro they both desperately
wanted the black pieces so there's some
Game Theory involved someone call up a
professor get some advice because you
know at some point you're just figuring
out my opponent wants this and I want
that how do we bid properly in 9 minutes
and 28 seconds that was a car's bid he
thought that Wesley would go near that
time so both players on the same page
yeah the Strat seems to be that you want
the black pieces but you don't want to
fall below nine minutes
Magnus Carlsen what can you say about
performance today David it wasn't as
smooth as previous days as yesterday
where he was really in top form I think
uh he was really shaken by that uh
defeating game three against Zara guys
see where it did turn around quite
quickly when it looked like Magnus was
cruising in control but Eric is he got
the win so Magnus Hugh will be happy to
have got through today he'll be really
relieved but tomorrow what a fight it's
going to be he's gonna have to up his
game he's got to be better than he was
today Magnus to take down Hikaru I think
Magnus is really looking forward to that
one yeah he loves playing against
Chicago definitely I mean everyone is
looking forward to that one we are
hoping to get some reactions from the
players
the winner of the match against Wesley
so big congratulations Hikaru
oh thank you so much it was a tough
match but I've had a way to win the
really the one game that mattered
definitely uh take us through first of
all your thoughts behind the bidding in
the Armageddon there
yeah I mean I was actually very
surprised how close it was I thought
when I you know it's funny originally I
was going to bid in the 950s because I
thought there's no way Wesley would go
below 10 minutes I thought I was gonna
be like 9 50 9 55 just something under
10.
um but then I'm like okay I'll go as low
as I can because why leave its chance to
somehow a bit so basically my mind I was
thinking how much time am I willing to
give him like if I have to play with the
white pieces how much time is it am I at
the point where it's like if I can't
beat him with white Then I then it's
like so be it and I basically thought it
was nine and a half minutes or a five
and a half minute time Advantage which
is how I came with 928 and um yeah he
bid 944 I think whoever got the black
pieces if they survived the opening was
gonna have great chances to move on and
it just happened to be me yeah so you
basically bid on your limit there with
well I mean I I maybe maybe I'll play
Magnus a bit lower you never know but uh
sort of I I just yeah I basically looked
and I thought okay what is the time at
which you know if I have to play with
white and and you know I play and let's
just say I don't win the game where am I
going to be like it's like okay I have
this time Edge that's life you know
Wesley was better than me and I put it
at five and a half minutes so I wouldn't
say it's necessarily the max against
Magnus but at least for Wesley that was
my thought process and it worked out so
I'm pleased definitely it was a big
upset though in the start of the game
some technical issues increments started
running Wesley when you restarted the
game chose another opening what was it
going through your head there
I mean I have the same situation in the
in the qualifiers I mean I I play it
again so I think do Bob I think it was
and um I played do Bob in the second I
think rapid game and I played I played
like E4 c5936 and they aborted the game
and then we started again and you know
it's to me if the moves have been played
and it's not like one side is winning or
losing I I don't know it seems really uh
it feels like one of those Unwritten
rules that you don't just suddenly play
a different opening at least that's my
attitude because I did consider it when
I played dubo I thought okay maybe I'll
just play D4 something different because
I've seen these planks something was
like I mean you've played the moves you
shouldn't really take them back so
that's just my personal opinion I don't
I don't really feel like it's correct
but uh you know that's it's what it is
and when you're doing online chess
obviously things things can get a little
bit wild definitely and I think the
whole chess world is so excited to see
you back on the Champions chest or
Hikaru now with a new format double
elimination the time control being 15
plus three what do you think about it so
far
um I mean the format is great because
now I'm in the top three I think so I
definitely qualify for the next
tournament
um which which makes me very very happy
uh yeah overall it's very similar to
previous years in The Knockout phase I
mean I think double elimination
definitely makes it more interesting you
can have like a bad day and come back
and still win the whole event so uh for
the fans I think it's it's better
um and yeah it's it's just it's kind of
kind of crazy to be in this situation
but that's what it is yeah
and acara you and Wesley always neck and
neck and you often play this Berlin draw
so what was going through your mind
heading into game four making that draw
was it for the memes
well I mean first of all like Armageddon
is always better content than having no
Armageddon I think that's their tie
breaks our arm again are always better
than not having them that's the first
thing but I mean really Wesley and I
have played a lot we played in the uh
chess Global championship last year in
in Toronto and I mean that match was
actually very similar to this it's just
at the very end I tried really hard to
push a one with white in the seventh
game and it didn't work out it backfired
Wesley won that game won the last game
um and then he won the tournament very
deservedly so uh and this match was very
similar and I just told myself I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna do anything insane
there I have the white piece in the last
game and I felt very confident I'm just
I mean to me the thing that's surprising
is just how low Wesley did because like
I said I assumed that I was gonna build
lower than him I never I really never
thought there was any way he was going
to bid below like 11 minutes I just
didn't see it happening so I'm just glad
that I went with what I thought was Max
I think if the colors were reversed
there's a very good chance that Wesley's
in the final instead of me
but it is you in the winners final
against Magnus Carlson tomorrow Hikaru
what's going to be your strategy and
plan heading into that big match
um I mean no strategy no plan uh this is
pretty much a vacation from far worse
things that are going on in my life
right now or far more depressing things
shall we say so uh for me I mean this is
this is like this is uh almost a
vacation getting to play chess so I'm
just enjoying it as much as I can how
difficult is it when uh stuff is going
on in your personal life to be able to
focus in a mental sport like chess
well you know if the first thing is that
you know luckily I seem to be pretty
decent at this game called chess
especially in Rapid and Blitz formats um
and that definitely helps a lot because
I I mean like yesterday for example I I
basically was just pounding nothing but
caffeine for uh for about 10 hours or so
maybe not 10 hours but like right right
up until I played against
um you know like life is what it is you
know people people people pass on things
happen that's how it goes um but for me
I think really it's just finding the joy
in playing chess and separating
separating or compartmentalizing things
and just you know it's you just try to
play and for me I think um as I said
luckily I seem to have pretty set
openings I seem to be fairly decent at
it and um it definitely helps when when
you can kind of just play on feel as
opposed to having to waste you know
hours or weeks or months about world you
know on on Preparation and Magnus
obviously knows about that all too well
so that's what it is
uh Hikari we're sending warm thoughts uh
towards uh you and your family and wish
you best of luck in the winners final
tomorrow
thank you so much you guys appreciate it
thank you for joining us
it's going to be such a big Winners
final tomorrow Hikaru against Magnus
Carlsen and I think we're also joined by
Magnus congratulations on another match
by Magnus
yeah thank you so before I start asking
you about tomorrow's big winner is final
you end the day with Armageddon here can
you first of all take us through your
tactics your thought process in the
bidding process there
um I thought
uh 10 minutes would be uh would be nice
and I so I bid 1001 sort of hoping that
he would be bids exactly 10 minutes and
I would get white because I thought that
would be uh
um then then I thought that would be
good for for me as well uh so that was
um basically just uh
um bid something where I felt good with
both outcomes okay so you were even
though uh you were happy without the the
bidding turned out
yeah it was fun okay
um
so yeah no worries there could you
reveal to us what would sort of be your
limits were you bidding on your limit or
could you go even lower
I mean I sort of had to make it up on
the fly but uh uh I mean you can play
very decent chess with much less time as
as that but this is probably like close
to where I would feel like comfortable I
would say all right
playing chess not Magnus
um I wasn't so happy with the way that I
played the the final four games today
um first game was very good uh
good decision making
um but yeah the the last three games
weren't uh
weren't so good
um especially the third game was pretty
unnecessary
um he did find a lot of good resources
there I thought I thought I was out
playing him a bit but it turned out like
he was always staying in there and then
I got short of time and he found this
research with 24
so that was a bit relaxing because I
thought like after I survived the second
game I thought
um that uh
the match was if not over then close to
it but um that was not the case at all
Magnus it's been a few days now since
you've landed in Canada what's uh what's
it like out there
um it's pretty much the same as in
Norway the weather the culture
um also there are a lot of Norwegians
here so
it's pretty much the same
we've been wondering if it's a lot of
sound a lot of my music and stuff going
on in the background when you're playing
are they keeping quiet or or what's
happening in the house when you are
playing the tournament
uh no no no that's fine uh the the boys
are having having fun but I can't really
hear anything so uh it's it's a house
that's well set up for
um for people both streaming and doing
other things yeah definitely and
tomorrow Magnus a big Winners final is
coming up I think the whole world the
whole Chess World is cheering because
it's gonna be Magnus Carlsen against T
card Nakamura are you excited about that
uh I haven't thought so much about it
yet but uh it's been a long time since
we played rapidly again she thought
against each other
um and uh what he has shown here uh and
what he showed in the rapidm uh sorry in
the world rapid as well is that it's not
so easy to
um to to beat and today he managed to
feed them going through without a single
win so that's going to be sort of the
main challenge I think tomorrow to uh to
create winning chances
and Magnus your last extended match
against Hikaru was the speeches
Championship he of course took that one
down does that play on your mind at all
or is it a new tournament and a new
mindset
oh well he's done well against me
um for for a while now so I am
yeah it certainly won't be easy
and with Hikaru in the mix this new door
format Magnus also your you've been very
vocal about how much you enjoy speed
chess and playing these events also
about how you feel about classical chess
especially after Tata steel it was
completely spent uh you looked
completely spent uh no classical World
Championship coming up this year for you
how significant is the champion Chester
on the air things Masters for you this
season
no it's it's big and uh
now we have a have a unified tour with
um
with all the best players and it's it's
really a prestigious so I really want to
do well yeah minus we wish you best of
luck tomorrow and the big Winners final
and thank you for joining us
thank you
players are excited we are excited I bet
everyone at home is excited about
tomorrow's winners final between Magnus
Carlsen and Hikaru Nakamura this is the
bracket we're only two days into the air
things monsters day three coming up
tomorrow we're gonna start out with
losers quarterfinals Wesley so against
Alexa Serana Arjun aragaisy and you
catch two teenagers both from India up
against each other is that very
prestigious for both of those two young
players don't yeah you know the Indian
fans are going to be torn because I know
that they love both these players a lot
so it's going to be tough to pick one
it's a huge match for India for these
two players to keep in the race they're
good friends they understand each
other's style a lot and that's never
pleasant but I think tomorrow it's not
going to be about friendship all of
that's going to be forgotten they're
gonna come out all guns blazing yeah and
on the losers bracket it is best out of
two rapid games with Armageddon tie
breaks if now necessary we also then
have Wesley so being knocked down from
the winners bracket today
to face Alexa is running you are a big
uh yes you say many nice things about
about Alexa Serrano basically Robert
what chances do you give him against
Wesley so he just beat Ali Reza farooza
convincingly today so he can beat
anybody on the planet I don't say that
lightly we saw how happy Serrano was
today he was impressed by his own chest
it means the world to him and once they
saw he's coming off probably what feels
like a disappointing performance he drew
that final game but he really didn't
have a chance it was a solid Affair but
not nothing spectacular of the likes
we've seen from Wesley so so I think
Alexis Serrano has serious chances and
you have to watch out for the opening
preparation okay
exciting as well we're
guard out day three with the losers
bracket before the Big Winners final
Magnus Carlsen Hikaru Nakamura which I
expect David I can't wait I predict that
both of them will bring their best chess
they can hit these really high levels
but as Magnus mentioned creating winning
chances against these guys it's a mutual
thing there creating winning chances
that's going to be the hardest thing it
could well go down
to the Armageddon again yeah division
one is uh turning into something super
exciting you guys but there's also two
more divisions going on in the air
things monsters division three and these
are results from today in division two
and some big news to you guys
never turned up or has much
is that a surprise no it's not a
surprise and the reason why is not
because he didn't want to play he was
traveling he was in transit to his
over-the-board classical tournament I
feel pretty confident he'll be back
tomorrow that's what double elimination
is for but Yonder Palm she hands the
match over to Alexander predki but in
terms of people who are showing off
their chest might if I've been a carwana
beating a very tough opponent two and a
half he moves on great showing by the
American Superstar who probably wants to
find himself in division one next time
aha so winner is semi-finals coming off
in division two tomorrow as well as
losers quarter-finals and janapon yachi
he will then use his second life and
play on the losers bracket tomorrow
that's your predictions certainly all
right
what a day what a day you guys this has
been a long day it's been a fun day and
we have more excitement coming up
tomorrow with the big Winners final and
losers quarter finals so join us again
we hope you have enjoyed the chess today
and we'll keep enjoying it tomorrow but
uh wherever you are in the world have a
good night have a good day and we'll see
you tomorrow
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]